Previously an freakshow.fm.
Diese Tür führt sie nach Hause sie werden wissen welche Tür beeilen Sie sich nachher.
Music.
Hallo Neo wir haben nicht erwartet wer sind sie.
Ich bin da Liedtext der Schöpfer der Matrix und damit auch die.
Warum bin ich hier das große und komplexe Programm der Matrix wurde in Perl geschrieben.
Dementsprechend entstehen Golf da noch mal in eine davon bist du sie haben meine Frage nicht beantwortet in Ermangelung guter Dokumentation bin ich darauf angewiesen mit Nutzern der Matrix zu sprechen.
Erzähl mir von ihren Begegnung mit Anomalien und anderen Unwägbarkeiten.
Versuche diese dann zu beheben im noch bitte in unsere kleine Runde Platz.
Zu deiner Linken hatte bereits vor deiner Ankunft von einer Raumzeit Anomalie berichtet das Orakel nein ein Fehler in der Berechnung von Zeitzonen.
Dann möchte weitermachen ich habe jetzt schon viel erzählt.
Soll ich mal ein bisschen was erzählen mach mal du hast doch auch noch so eine kleine Anomalie ich hatte auch eine Anomalie die Anomalie war ein weißer VW Bus aus Cottbus.
Hospiz auf der schon alles eigentlich,
an Anomalie ja ne ja ich weiß nicht ob du überhaupt.
Music.
Ja jetzt Freakshow Nummer 212 und wir schreiben den 14.
Wetter um 18:09 Uhr.
Zweiter Schenkelklopfer.
Hallo Tim wieder eine Anomalie gehabt.
Schreib mal darüber definiere Normalität das machen wir die ganze Zeit Podcast,
ich möchte nicht drüber reden und sie ist wieder da.
Mit dir zurück aus der Sonne die zurück aus der französischen schöne wieder zurück in den Schatten.
Linke Seite des Kontinents ja ich habe mich wirklich nach Regen und grau halt und so weiter gesehen sah furchtbar.
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen und runterfahren.
Ich bin auch wieder da wäre es gut was das auch nach Nummer die ich schon lange her vor zwei Wochen.
Was ist ich weiß ja nicht was wirklich passiert ist das.
Ja aber übrigens sehen so dass das Dennis ja ja ich habe ja vor.
Scheiß vor zwei oder drei Wochen habe ich mir einmal die komplette Star Wars an einem Wochenende reingezogen den kompletten Star Wars heißt was genau alles Machete order.
Also ohne I noch mit I was er alles ja nicht Machete Ordner oder.
Ja also die Leute das gar nicht kennen das vielleicht ist es okay sollte man vielleicht machen.
Wobei die dann mache ich auch nichts davon wissen aber wenn man schon kennt findet das Machete order glaube ich irgendwie nicht so weil sie nicht.
Dann guck dann doch lieber wär so wie es dann auch kenne ja es ist jetzt macht ja nur Sinn für Leute die halt noch.
Noch nicht gar nicht kennen genau ja also Machete order falls jemand nicht weiß was Sache ist es ist hier vor einiger Zeit mal ich glaube vor zwei Jahren ist letzte Star Wars 7 raus kam,
na ja um den Hals herum,
Machete order verspricht quasi merex Admin wenn man sich Star Wars in der Episoden Reihenfolge 45236 anschaut.
Was ich auch nur so zur Kenntnis nehmen kann weil auch ich habe es natürlich anders gesehen und deswegen.
Fertig wär das Versuchskaninchen um es auszuprobieren,
das ist geil das Schlagzeug,
alle dabei deine große Rucksack mit allen DVDs.
Frisch gebrannt man kann viele Fragen aber ich habe nur eine.
Warum das schlimme ist.
Ich weiß nicht ich habe auch ich habe mich euch sagen aber ich glaube ich habe ich geschafft habe den ersten Teil von Matrix überhaupt zu Ende gesehen weil ich jedesmal eingeschlafen bin.
Podcast hören.
Kann ich nicht mal voll das nicht so gerne.
Ja ich find's langweilig und dann dafür Folgen von von only lovers left alive erzählst du hds2 Langweiler weiß,
langsam langsam und langweilig auf das andere du hast ja gesagt alle Filme sind langweilig,
nee nee nicht alle aber ohne lovers left alive von einer der wenigen wo ich wirklich nachhaltig hatte war auf,
was für ein geiler Film aber ich will da nur wenige gesehen hast dann muss er dann die Quote von tollen Film eigentlich relativ hoch sein ja nicht wenn ich hier so eine Empfehlung bekommen Sie was war das letzte was ich gesehen habe und mir dachte WhatsApp.
Blade Runner the original Blade Runner.
Meine fresse ich bin also fast eingeschlafen und mit der Person mit der ich geguckt habe mein Sohn heißt was nicht verstanden oder ist er einfach nur scheiße,
den original na ich finde den überhaupt nicht gut also Entschuldigung,
nein ich mich dafür gehört das Matrix und nicht.
Bitte wir müssen über das Verhältnis von Matrix habe ich allerdings auch erst auch nur den ersten gesehen.
Nachdem wir alle meinten dass die anderen Teile nicht so doll wäre ich den den ersten Teil schon so na ja.
Hätte man mehr draus machen können dachte ich nicht auch mein größtes Problem mit so mit so vielen Sachen dass ich einfach so maßlos enttäuscht bin was dann dabei rauskommt also.
Wenn man bei Blade Runner hat das Wasser nicht vorhanden waren Dialoge also sorry aber.
Vielleicht lege ich einfach Wert auf hochwertigere Dialoge aber da gab es eine oder zwei sind irgendwann inhalt war Schlussszene.
Weltmeisterin guckt Final Cut zu Director's Cut oder das nicht weiß ich nicht mehr,
navi war nicht lustig dann war der letzte übriggebliebene unterhält und sie wirklich so ein Ansatz von Dialog haben was das heißt was ist ein Roboter.
Dieser dieser komische letzte Typ über die Mainzer der blonde Haare.
Ja da fängt schon das nächste an ich bin nicht gut wenn ich bin echt nicht gut mit Gesichtern also mit Büchern habe ich echt mehr.
Nee ich weiß nicht ich finde zu häufig bin nicht enttäuscht von dem was ich sehe und was der Inhalt ist,
weißt dass dass dass dass dass das etwas ist was mich ins Grab bringt weil Entschuldigung dem Moment in dem Moment wo die nächste Generation.
Alles negiert was man selber für kulturell hochwertig gehalten hat und und Lebens definieren das ist der Moment wo man sich allein fühlt und dann in dieser Einsamkeit langsam verwelkt unter Hinsicht und dann bin ich tot mit Probleme.
Du genau wie du sagst das ist eine andere Zeiten andere Kultur gewesen deswegen hat der Film wahrscheinlich für euch funktioniert und für mich nicht mehr das mag sein und ich glaube trotzdem dass es Filme gibt die einfach den test of time.
Bestehen und die nie schlecht werden können weil sie dazu eigentlich viel zu gut sind also,
auch Filme sind dir ja also bladerunners insofern gerade wirklich ein interessantes Beispiel als das ja Bladerunner damals auch nicht funktioniert hat doch keiner verstanden,
die Leute sind ins Kino rein gegangen und dann so.
Und und oder war kein mega Erfolg wann der Film kam erst so mit den Jahren weil irgendwie auch die Filme Drama gemacht haben so ja okay also die haben es jetzt zwar nicht die Bude eingerannt mit dem Film.
Aber der wird immer wieder nachgefragt und der hat so Zahnärzte mit der Zeit die Popularität erreicht,
weil er dann er überhaupt erst erkannt wurde Marco standen halt auch und verstanden genau weil das ist ja auch für die und was bei Blätter noch dazu kommt deswegen hat der Dennis auch nach dem Kat gefragt dass das eben auch so Filme sind die,
na ja die Wunde halt gedreht beschnitten so und dann hat sie halt so Filmbörse die wollen halt Kohle Kohle Kohle und haben dann halt so.
Undercut gemacht nach dem Motto ja lass mal hier das Ende mal ein bisschen peppiger machen oder so wanderte ich im Foto Sonja Screenings gemacht die Leute am nix verstanden und dann haben sie ja wir müssen den wir können ja nicht so rausbringen und haben sie hat hier Harrison Ford muss mal irgendwie noch so eine,
Stimme aus dem Off oben drüber legen damit die Leute verstehen was da irgendwie abgeht das war damals auch so ein Film Noir haben die daraus gemacht das war ja so ein bisschen erzählte sowie.
Über so ein Film Noir so oder so haben die den Versuch ein bisschen zu drehen,
bin meinte übrigens auch ganz ganz cool so megamäßig ich weiß was sie jetzt sagen wollen und sie haben recht aber der hat ja die,
Higgins wollte nicht dass ich in den Garten gehe aber mir war das egal war das auch so bei,
weiß ich nicht also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher mit welchem karte ich angefangen habe aber ich will jetzt einfach ich lebe mein gesamtes,
Gewicht in diese Schale die da gerade versucht den Hebel hoch zu drücken.
Blade Runner ist einfach einer der fantastischen Filme die gemacht worden dass ich den immer noch nicht gesehen aber,
Jobsuche davaso,
ich habe ja so ein DVD Krämerladen habe ich irgendwo dann mal Blade Runner den alten und den neuen zusammen in einer Box,
zumindest schon mal gekauft auf DVD wie steht es bei mir zu Hause im Regal und immer wärst du dann auch mal gucken.
Wir sind kann man auch auf DVD gucken weil Qualität qualitativ mäßig ist er nicht so sehr sehr schön gemacht.
Und das war das einzige was ich dann was mich so ein bisschen versöhnlich gestimmt hat aber für mich war das ein bisschen also es gibt es gibt es gibt natürlich ein Aspekt den kann man tatsächlich nur.
Verstehen wie auch bei Star Wars im Kontext der Zeit weil es gibt so Filme da gehst du so rein.
Und du weißt nicht mehr wo oben und unten ist das Marco ja da jetzt 17 Uhr tatsächlich der auch,
ist auch so ein Film 10 Filme vielleicht in meinem Leben und es geht wahrscheinlich auch allen so,
wo man so rauskommt und und und irgendwie halt sucht wo man wirklich so mit der Hand immer in Richtung Geländer unterwegs ist weil man jetzt gerade überhaupt nicht also mir ging das zumindest so dass das mich Filme einfach so nachhaltig touchiert haben und ich und ich beim rausgehen,
schon fast zitterte weil weil ich wusste da da war jetzt irgendwie auch eine intellektuelle Ebene drin die ich vielleicht noch gar nicht voll ich erfasse aber die mich in die total mitgenommen hat.
Wann ist Karneval aus anderen Gründen so ähnlich da mal beim Altern definitiv dazu setzt dich nicht in die erste Reihe bei dem Film.
Und wir natürlich weißt du so 16 Jahre oder keine Ahnung wie alt ich da war als er nicht kam halt irgendwie.
Wieso komm das machen wir und dann saßen wir in diesem Film in der ersten Reihe und nach.
90 Minuten kommst du aus dem Film raus und hältst dich wirklich an der Wand fest lass mich raten,
Etikett auf koreanisch Katze nicht dass Kati ist es sind 90 oder 95% Zeitraffer Aufnahmen.
Dieser Film wenn du den im Kino siehst und bis 90 Minuten mit Zeitraffer Aufnahmen bestrahlt der dreht dir III so am Hirn dass Du hinterher rauskommst und denkst dir.
Ich bin jetzt auf Droge oder weil ich gerade eben noch,
der einzige Film nicht auf meinem Telefon habe,
der einzige Film Dennis auf seinem Telefon hat und.
Ist nicht ganz raus der Auswahl zwei Gründen fantastisch ist erstens.
Na oder fährt auch aus drei also erstmals ein Film ohne Handlung ist ja sozusagen Rainer ist Zähnen Film also du siehst also Film fängt an und sie ist ruhige Bilder.
Erde Landschaften Berge Wolken alles ganz ruhig und die Musik dazu,
Philip Glass muss man dazu sagen mnml music ist halt auch noch mal also die Musik ohne diese Musik wäre der Film auch nur halt so gut weil diese Musik sich so dermaßen ins Hirn,
Tretroller Aldi weil es extrem repetitiv ist aber halt Orchestermusik ja.
Music.
Und das coole ist die Bilder steigern sich also kommt halt immer näher der immer der Stadt immer näher ja also die Bilder werden schneller aus Landschaften werden Felder werden moderne.
Agricultural industry places so du kommst in die Vorstadt.
Straßenhäuser die Straßen werden größer mehr Autos mehr Häuser,
urbanes Skyscraper rein in die Häuser Rolltreppen Zeitraffer Menschen die wirklich wie wie wie wie Blut in den Venen wenn die durch durch diese Rolltreppen gedrückt und.
Du wirst total wahnsinnig was ich an der Stelle total geile der Aufnahme aus der Wurstfabrik und dann hast du so eine Maschine wo so in in in,
weiß ich wie viel sind vielleicht so 20 rein Würste aus so einer Maschine kommen halt auch im Zeitraffer die kommen da ständig raus und dann hast du so cute Centralstation,
Rolltreppe auch Suppe für 20 nebeneinander Menschen fahren die Rolltreppe Herzog,
Würste kommen aus der Maschinen Menschen auf der Rolltreppe und die dicksten ein Fest also quasi,
da schreibt man sich einfach kurz an und dann dann haut man sich das Reiben an besten mit der bestmöglichen Soundkulisse Kopfhörer auf und wie groß ist green,
schnelle mach mal die Brasilianer aber im Positiven Kernaussage ist ja quasi eine Betrachtung unserer Zeit und der ganze Wahnsinn in dem wir uns sozusagen selbstverständlich bewegen.
Wird in dem Film einfach dadurch dekodiert weil er eben diesen Übergang so hairlight und die Musik das halt so mitmacht und am Schluss hat mit der Film dann auch wieder mit.
Was kann ich Wasser die letzten algida wieder zurück in die Natur oder das letzte ist WinRAR key,
minutenlang irgendwie so einen sonnenstück Rakete runterfällt und immer die Flamme ausgeht wenn sie es geht doch mal wieder an und lautet ja auch mit dem Raketenstart ja das glaube ich,
sie startet glaube ich mit der Saturn V,
bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher stimmt also wenn Sie die Triebwerke also es gibt keine Szenen die in in realer Zeit sind es nur Zeitlupe oder Zeitraffer und es dreht halt auch so an deiner an deiner Wahrnehmung in dem Film,
weil du das dann halt auch irgendwann auch eine normale schnelle Szene nicht mehr ertragen würdest irgendwie und das ist das ist so geil so dieses zwischen dem.
Diese langsam sich emporsteigen Rakete und.
Ist aber auch ein Film da muss man irgendwie ich weiß nicht ob man wenn man den zu Hause komme ich dann die Lust aber du kannst auch prima auf einer Party anlaufen lassen.
Das ist aber das ist ja muss ich diesen Film,
aussetzen dass dass das Fischer weiß ich aber das von dir sagt dass man nur ein Gewehr fällt heutzutage euch mal ein bisschen am am am Riemen jetzt das kann ja wohl nicht sein dass jetzt alles.
Negiert wird so jung bin ich nicht mehr froh drüber auch noch andere Zuhörer.
Ja weiß der Geier was die für Filme langweilig finden die Du geil findest keine Filme ja du machst es dir da sehr einfach.
Nein Bücher jetzt aber noch bei Film mit denen du sagst wann muss ich auf den Film einlassen so ein bisschen ich finde dass es genau dass er über only lovers left alive viele sehen den Inhalt des Films nicht und singt gegen sich hatte ja so langweilig ist langweilig aber wenn du da irgendwie den Inhalt und diese,
geilen Bilder und Ausschnitte liebst als ich weiß nicht ganz mit meinen Eltern noch nicht gesehen ist noch,
den kenne ich auch noch nicht aber dazu muss man sagen das ist halt ein Film aus der Feder von Jim Jarmusch und Jim Jarmusch ist wirklich wert one of my favorite.
Es hat mich so geärgert danach habe ich gesehen dass der der macht ja auch Musik und durch ihn bin ich auf einen großartigen Künstler,
Kosten der Josef van Wissem heiß und die machen beide zusammen Musik und haben unter anderem auch für only lovers left alive Musik gemacht und die haben natürlich in Berlin einen.
Nicht nur diese Aufführung habe von dem Film sondern auch live gespielt und das habe ich natürlich kurz nachdem sie gespielt haben gesehen dass wir so eine Scheiße zusammen und der spielt laute also,
wissen,
Josef van Wissem ich nehme einfach mal dass ich schmeiß mal den Wikipedia-Artikel dazu rein der ist es ist,
auch sehr gewöhnungsbedürftige Musik wahrscheinlich aber die beiden zusammen haben coole Filmmusik teilweise halt eben für only lovers left alive gemacht,
und am ja die hätte ich gern live zusammen gesehen also ich wusste auch nicht dass das dumm da muss Gitarre spielt E-Gitarre hatte da jedenfalls,
es sehr sehr abgefahrene Musik und ich nach dem Essen find's furchtbar aber ich fand ihn in der Musik sind auf eine ganze Illustrator Weise verletzt.
Ich wollte ja eigentlich noch mal auf.
Matrix zurückkommt aber wo jetzt gerade im Sommer das Fass aufgemacht haben ein Sonntag bin ich gerne der von Batman.
Ihr könnt ich auch Stunden adrenaloop hören viele Leute ja nicht in der Satz zu anstrengend aber habe ich es nicht so im Ohr das ist hier von dir young E-Gitarre die ganze Zeit.
Batman das Dorf wo wo.
Johnny Depp ihr so als halbtoter durch durch den Wilden Westen irgendwie humpelte und er vor sich hin halluziniert.
Der ist auch ganz irre also Jim Jarmusch finde ich hatte also alles alle Filme die ich von ihm gesehen habe finde ich geil dass du das echt eine kurz.
Also kann ich an keiner erinnern den ich nicht wirklich geil fand und ich finde mindestens so drei totale,
Meisterwerke abgeworfen die man gar nicht oft genug loben und erwähnen kann also.
Also mache ich das auch ne.
Let's go Fitness Scream ice cream aha sehr wichtiges Detail also damit ist er bekannt als Parfüm gemacht die waren noch nicht so,
aber isst du die Verbreitung gefunden aber was sind ja total den durch,
beschert hat ist dieser phantastische Film down by law oder sieht man auch schon wieder Musik mir wichtig sind weil jonny ist ja Musiker und Tom Waits auch,
genau also das ist nämlich diecast laundry Tom Waits und Roberto Benigni Roberto Benigni der dann später auch.
Weltberühmt geworden ist aber der im Prinzip auch mit down by law so ein bisschen seinen Durchbruch gefeiert hat.
Fantastische Geschichte drei Typen die irgendwie in Louisiana glaube ich ne in Knast kommen.
Also in derselben Zelle landen.
Und du siehst von den ersten beiden von Tom Waits und von John Lurie siehst du so ein bisschen die Vorgeschichte wie das so passiert ist also Ganoven Typen die irgendwie ja schlecht Blumenladen haben und dann irgendwie hops genommen werden.
Und dann treffen sie hat auf diesen kleinen lustigen Italiener der fragt sie halt so wie sie denn warum sie denn im Knast gelandet sind,
ARD Fakt mich so alle meine Nummer ich bin um die reingelegt worden und die anderen sind alle Schuld und ich müsste eigentlich gar nicht hier sein worden.
Die coolen Typen halt na dann weiß auch irgendwie eine Story ausgepackt.
Hörner sowie ihre ihre Sichtweise dargelegt und fragen halt dann so den Robert oder warum bist du jetzt hier im Knast.
Der schaut so ganz stolz an deine Brust und sagt.
Michael Dammann.
When you throw the ball at me at the zoo.
Otto Factory der Film an unfassbar komisch und dann bringen sie aus und flüchten um durch die Moorlandschaften und das ist einfach,
unfassbar dieser Humor von Roberto Benigni alles wunderbar inszeniert einfach einen einen einen Film für die Ewigkeit voll mixen Sie auch nicht mehr über einen anderen bleiben immer ernst,
ja oder ja soweit Sie das können weil er bricht sie ja dann auch irgendwie aufnehmen mit seiner Argumente dafür immer oder ja darum geht's irgendwie so dieses,
aber erstmal sind die ganze Zeit nur über taff und hart und brauch nicht mehr ganz fähig dann irgendwie im Sumpf verloren so und dann kommt er,
kommt Roberto sie wissen schon einmal was sie essen sollen dann kommt Roberto halt an wir sind Hasen an Tequila,
oder Filter die ganze Zeit lustig also für dich fantastisch ja.
Wollte mal gucken auf jeden Fall macht was ich habe ein schlechtes Gedächtnis,
auf was Filme angeht auch Filme die ich gut finde und ich habe auch mal total vergessen irgendwie hat meine Freundinnen Musik von dem Sohne Filmmusik geschickt man sich hier heute erstmal an super geil und das war von.
Viper Jet elito diese Drogengeschichte,
ja schon mal gesehen und aber mir entfallen so eine Sachen bei Film extrem.
Das passiert mir aber nur so bei Film und Sachen nicht gesehen habe Sachen die ich lese halt nämlich nicht wirklich alle krassesten Filme der ist krass und den habe ich auch mit jungen Jahren gesehen und dachte mir dann so noch länger,
spielen wir heute aber nicht,
und euch kann nichts erschüttern euch an.
Jünger waren als ich und ich würde sagen nicht so viel junge aber vielleicht noch zu jung für diesen Film zeigen gleich drei Jahre jünger Verstand auf 5 aber ich meinen also mit 20 hatte ich will das könnte man diesen Film dann doch mal schon sehen.
Na Darren Aronofsky zu krass aber ja ich vergess sowas halt schnell aber wenn wir bei guten Film sind welchen ich auch kennst den ersten Film von Darren Aronofsky Requiem for a Dream Hassan II.
Werde wenn du mir Namen dass ich es noch meiner Wikipedia nachgucken vielleicht.
Wetter ist ja auch sofort zum Kultfilm aufgestiegen aus dem crazy Schwarz-Weiß-Film mit Sohn.
Paranoiden Mathegenie der und wie versucht die Formel hinter piros bekommen und dann wird es noch in so eine Shady anrufen.
Dori eingekauft mit dem Chip der Stelle ist ein bisschen cheesy aber der Film ist einfach.
Der ist auch krass aber der ist nicht so krass dass meine nicht sehen sollte sein der ist sehenswert krass während requiem for dream krass krasses.
Ja das ist das beste muss man stabil sein würde ich sagen für Requiem dann kenne ich ihn halt nicht und den werde ich mir mal anschauen Arbeit wenn ich das.
Yuppie ist Black Swan gedreht wusste ich garnicht weil der war ja auch irgendwie sehr intense.
Habt ihr denn gesehen habe die habe ich noch nicht gesehen der ja der ist für ich glaube der kann nicht anders als intens einfach intense der Typ.
Welche Filme ich wirklich sehr cool fun MOONRISE Kingdom von was ändert habt ihr den gesehen.
Aqua Dingens Filme macht dass ich da.
Na der hat doch hier diese und allerdings das mit dem Hotel hatte auch.
Mit dem Hotel waren wohl Grand Budapest Hotel den Film konnte ich aber nicht so richtig umsehen Budapest Hotel ist großartig russisch,
das schlimme ist da ich ja aus dieser Stadt, wo der Film gedreht wurde sind da so unschlüssige Schnitte drin und ich habe den zusammen mit meinem Bruder das erste Mal gesehen,
wer hat die ganze Zeit nicht nur bei den Inhalt gelacht sondern auch über die Schnitte die für jemanden geht und Öl verbinden sich nicht sowas.
Also so wirklich gegen also geografisch etwas größere 100 km Sprünge was heißt sehr lustig ist wenn du das kennst aber der Film ist großartig.
Na dann kann schon wieder trocken so jetzt müssen wir aber noch mal.
Nachher noch mal noch mal von Matrix was heißt du noch mal smatree für mich überhaupt mal zu Matrix.
Infanta bist du eingeschlafen bei Matrix ich habe ihn sogar zu Ende geguckt aber wenn ich schon so anfange gut also soll mal mit der Brille zu predispositions dass er immer so eine Sache aber ich würde einfach mal sagen.
Matrix hat das 21 Jahrhundert kulturell eingeläutet.
Da war halt danach war wieder halt mal alles anders du sende ein bisschen das Smells Like Teen Spirit des Films.
Genau also so ich meine irgendwie auch ein bisschen so erstmal das Setting so immer da bin ich natürlich vielleicht ein bisschen betroffen weil so auf einmal war der Hacker.
War auf einmal der Star oder zu Messezentrum.
Dieses Films und letzten Endes ist er ja in dem Film was die nicht zu Ende geguckt spielte er schon eine bestimmte Rolle er ist so warm.
Das war neu weil bis dahin war ja Hacker im Film immer.
Das hässliche Kind das wird am Roller das fande war wieder besonders an dem Film.
Das ist auf jeden Fall einer der wichtigen Aspekte dieses Films das Recht das an der Stelle des bist du gerade eben gesagt hast noch nicht aufgefallen weil ich meine das waren und Wahl Merchweiler auch nie wirklich ein Hacker also.
Ja natürlich ist ein Hacker weil er natürlich immer der er hakt.
Die Matrix kann gar nicht sein so ne sie muss noch mal gucken,
wie viel dazu dann ist er auf die A7 jetzt ein bisschen Probleme dann ist auch die Interpretation aber kannst du problematisch finden darf ich trotzdem dabei die.
Tricktechnik dieses Films war hat weil sie alles auf den Kopf gestellt was bis dahin war so Bullet Time all diese Sachen das kommt alles aus diesem Film.
Tricktechnik bei der Film ganz weit vorne danach war auch um die alles anders ist merkst ja auch schon da dran das Matrix selber ja auch schon ein komplettes Memis in dem halt.
Ganz viele Szenen aus diesem Film in einem Film halt wieder aufgegriffen nachgestellt die Tricks nachgebaut werden etc also allein die Bullet Time Sequenz weißt was ich meine oder Betty.
Bullet Time es gibt diese eine Szene wo er da oben auf dem Dach steht und die Mister schießen auf ihn,
und er neigt sich so nach hinten steht eigentlich nur noch so auf deinen Knie gebeugten Knien so nach hinten der Ledermantel flattert und es ist halt alles in dieser 3D.
Rundumsicht und Zeitlupe und so weiter dass das war einfach fantastisch also das ganze Setup gabs halt so vorher noch nie,
und es war einfach von vorne rein so ironisch dazu natürlich auch das ganze Auftreten Trinity etc.
Dem Telefon sind die Matrix abfliegen und überall diese andere Welt und diese ganze Thematisierung einer kompletten digitalen Parallelwelt und dass wir eigentlich eine Simulation sind das ist,
my mind blowing genau tatsächlich gab es den Film aber schon mal vorher.
Nämlich muss mal kurz schauen.
Und zwar das war 1973.
Das quasi Matrix schon mal bekommt der Faßbender jetzt kommt der Faßbender genau.
Welt am Draht habe ich auch noch zu Hause gehabt habe ich geguckt ja aber das ist also wenn man Matrix kennt.
Dürfte ich gerne als erstes Mal Mathis anschauen aber ich dachte Welt am Draht dass er sowieso thirteenth floor mit Armin Mueller-Stahl wenn ich mich recht erinnere habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen nur.
Welt am Draht ist im Prinzip auch eine Science Fiction Verfilmung von simulacron-3 ist der das Buch.
Und auch das spielt mit quasi so dieser Welt.
Simulation ist natürlich vom Film her komplett anders man ist von 73 und ich von 99.
Aber ich will like that movie you might be interested in history.
Sandra hat.
Rettungslos auch von 99 so wie Martin würde mich aber interessieren welcher von beiden zuerst raus kam oder ob das wieder schon so ein parallel drehen weil sie mitbekommen haben was die Konkurrenz Firma macht passiert ja öfter mal so beim Film Matthias Flohr.
Das ist nämlich eigentlich eher das dass ich mal höre was zur Welt am Draht kompatibel ist oder ähnlich oder gleich ist du was du denkst ach guck an.
Was soll das ist nämlich auch okay das ist auch explizit eine Adaption von derselben Roman den habe ich nun nicht.
Komm ja kannst du mal sehen ja keiner sehen.
Was ich noch kurz einwerfen möchte wenn wir schon bei Film sind was für mich auch also.
So ähnlich bisschen Augen öffnen öffnen Barbie Matrix wobei viele das nicht so sehen aber ich finde den irgendwie immer wieder wenn ich den gucke haut mich um is the Prestige der Film wo auch,
ui den Tesla spielt die beiden Zauberer die sich gegenseitig bekriegen und.
Hat jemand von euch gesehen letzte mal außen vor nein aber ich muss gerade an das nehmen denken wenn man zwei Fotos,
nebeneinander gepackt hat das eine Wahrheit der der Roadstar Mall,
Tesla Playboy und der andere Roboter Spielzeug.
Nee ich höre es erstmal davon ja dann darf ich ja gar nicht darüber erzählen aber ich finde der hat ja schick gemacht der Film.
Mit auf dem Ende was unerwartet kam also mitgespielt Nikola Tesla eine Kombination.
Und ich finde das ist ein Film den kann man den kannst du zum zweiten mal gucken und beim zweiten Mal weil du jetzt mehr Informationen hast,
siehst du den Film noch mal komplett anders und ich könnte schwören man kann ihn noch ein drittes mal gucken und entdeckt wieder Sachen weil man beim zweiten mal gucken ja auch wieder was gelernt dass man beim dritten mal wieder einsetzen kann wenn man ihn guck also es ist wirklich.
Also Michael Caine und.
Scarlett Johansson Kesternich oder Theater dann sind die beiden anderen die Taucher sind ja auch beide bekannt das ist ja hier.
Hugh Jackman diverser heißt das so und der andere ist Christian Bella sind ja alles top Schauspieler ja.
Bitte sogar auch noch nee das bitte mal über den Batman movies mit ne.
Auf einmal nicht mehr ist von Christopher Nolan der hat doch auch Batman gemacht oder nicht genau Rebecca Hall.
Ja Dark Knight und so kann man ebenfalls eine Menge Leute sind Film und ich fand dass ich von den richtig gut werde nicht gesehen hat sollte sich mal angucken ganz in Ruhe.
Ist auf jeden Fall schick gemacht hat einen sehr überraschendes Ende und wenn man das gesehen hat dann kann man ihn noch mal gucken und entdecke wo hängt.
Hätte ich das mal gleich gewusst dann machen viele Sachen plötzlich sind die ein vorher so ein bisschen so komisch vorkommen.
Prestige sein Film und danach kam Inception.
Danach interstellar.
Wir könnten den Film Podcast Blog November das machen ich finde es auch ganz gut dass wir uns jetzt so über solche Themen unterhalten immer wieder überhaupt nicht auf unserer Liste standen.
Ich habe da fand ich meine Empfehlung was ihr euch nicht angucken sollte um nicht die Zeit zu verschwenden wenn ihr gerade so tolle Sachen geschickt hatte diese furchtbare Serie altered km.
Die wurde irgendwie mal irgendwo gab es im App Store wurde die mal so gefeatured mit von wegen und total interessant und so,
wurde sich durchgequält was Wochenende und es war locker.
Ja es ist wahr.
Hätte besser sein können das ärgert mich halt dann auch manchmal so dieses diese Idee diese Story dahinter ist irgendwie ganz coole Idee aber in der Ausformulierung.
Das Wetter wirklich ein schicker Science-Fiction Thriller sein können sie haben da irgendeine komische Schnulze draus gemacht Schauspieler.
Deezer.
Ja stimmt der Vulkan der kann garnicht wie man schon von von House of cards gesehen hat genau oder The Killing da ging es aber noch da habe ich den habe ich nie gesehen den Hund.
Hier voll Beißer James Purefoy das also der der reiche thügida der spielte ja schon bei,
the following glaube ich irgendwie den Bösewicht und ja der geht auch gar nicht find das sind einfach keine angemessenen Schauspieler für diese Rolle.
Ja und auffüllen also wenn,
ich mich schon darüber aufrege das nur t***** und Geballer drin ist also hat mich nicht aufregen,
ja also hätten sie wenigstens schöne Frauen und nicht so eine Magersüchtige und dann diesen Volltrottel als Hauptdarsteller dadurch diese Schwester von dem,
Boiler,
diese blonde achso ja gut also die hätte wirklich ein paar Happen mehr essen können das ist also ästhetisch weiß nicht.
Also wenn schon nackte Frauen dann bitte auch Frauen.
Keiner du darfst es ja sagen wie auch immer,
das was dieser Joel Kinder waren zu viel an Muskelmasse hat hatte sie halt definitiv zu wenig aber der kann einfach nicht Schauspieler versucht die ganze Zeit so einen coolen Typen zu spielen schon seinen Gang und wir seine Arme so weit auseinander weil früher gab es von den Spruch,
damit du nicht im Gulli fallen oder wie war das ne bis wer kann der kann das einfach nicht cool,
Wer spielt das nur man merkt es dass es so künstlich ist Wer ist einfach nicht weiß ich dass du so aufgesetzt ist egal wir wollen ja nur positive Sachen erzählen eigentlich,
was sind HDR gedreht wenn man den passenden Fernseher hat dann ist es zu müssen schick eignet sich nicht mehr unter Lego zusammenzubauen.
Man muss ja auf dem Bildschirm gucken wo der Grad der ist aufregt Faktors war einfach.
So schlimm ja ja.
Gut dann können wir das Filmthema jetzt erstmal beiseite legen oder wirft ja genug Empfehlungen sein dann könnt ihr euch jetzt die Kiste setzen und bis zum nächsten Freakshow durch schauen gucken in Frankfurt Blade Runner an.
Nee also ich gucke nicht noch mal aber ich werde jetzt die anderen Sachen einfach gucken und Leberwurst.
Nadine habe ich noch nicht gesehen aber den uns darauf habe ich ja verstehen.
Du hast ja 9000 ich gesagt nee welche auf mich das mit dem Chewbacca oder,
ina weiland das Arena ist neu da war ich nicht so toll.
Music.
Ich erinnere mich nur daran dass wir schon mal eine Freakshow hatten wo wahrscheinlich,
Warum mit dem mit der Star Wars Maske im Auto,
gut anfangen.
Ebenso Danke schön,
steht da nicht deswegen weil das jetzt auf dem Kopf ich habe auch was bekommen jemand hat mir drei Sachen auf einmal geschickt.
Also sehr sehr großzügig der Name ich habe leider nicht gekauft der Zettel liegt zu Hause vielen Dank für Dank für Dank und ja finde ich finde ich voll gut weil irgendwie jetzt in letzter Zeit habe ich auch immer das Glück ich brauch immer gerade was und dann gehe ich müsste mehrzeilig mal folgendes holen und,
selber meine Sachen so das ist in meine eigene Wunschliste ganze jetzt brauche ich halt wirklich und und dann ding ding dann kommst du dass es da und jetzt habe ich genau das HDMI Kabel für mein Fernseher und wo ist jetzt gekommen und du,
Volvo super.
Schön da wo wir bei HDMI war der kann ich mich jetzt bedanken für das HDMI Gerät das nichts anzeigt.
Und zwar das hatten wir in der Sendung schonmal ja s'adapter der einfach nur sagt hier ist ein Bildschirm oder was richtig fit headless heißt das Teil weil ja der Mac mini.
Dein Problem hat dass er die Grafikkarte nicht an schaltet auf Hardwarebeschleunigung wenn kein Monitor dran ist.
Und dafür gibt's diese Teile man steckt ihn rein dann tut dieses Teil dieser dumme so als wäre er ein Bildschirm und dann brauchst du das weil du dass der Rechner glaubt da sein Bildschirm.
Aber warum soll das glauben also warum brauchst du die hat er beschleunigt Leinzell Kram oder was weil du remote.
Das Gebot drauf zugreifen und dass da auch ein Bildschirm ist weil wenn er kein Bildschirm ist z.b. z.b. um Test.
Auf dem Rechner laufen zu lassen also wenn du wenn du testing für iOS machst dann startet er den Simulator und der Simulator der ändert natürlich das user interface,
und wenn der Rechner aber nicht die Hardwarebeschleunigung von der Grafik anhat dann ist es so langsam das gerne mal Hotel fehlschlagen.
Das ist das ist er ich weiß nicht was was Apple da geritten hat oder ob das einfach auch ein Problem,
von dem verwendeten Art die Chipettes oder so also auf jeden Fall dieses Ding das ist ja geil wo es zu ist jetzt wahrscheinlich als nächstes verwenden werde ist dann doch eher für ich habe doch diese diese minikiste ist skull Canyon von Intel,
was im Prinzip nur ein Rechner mit da ist ein Prozessor drin und so eine m2,
SSD Modul und,
irgendwie ein bisschen interne Grafik und dann war's das im Prinzip ein McMenü und noch weiter abgespeckt und dafür habe ich ja dieses externe.
Thunderbolt 3 Gehäuse mit der richtigen Grafikkarte besorgt und Windows,
das jetzt wieder ein Windows Problem Windows hat das Problem dass er im Prinzip in der Lage ist wenn er die externe Grafikkarte findet auch auf der Externen Grafik zu laufen,
aber Windows kommt nicht hoch wenn an der internen Grafik kein nichts dran hängt kein Bildschirm dranhängt Bomann.
Und dann stecke ich den fit headless jetzt da rein damit der bootet ist ja die Technik wird einfach nicht besser das übrigens Würmer muss schon noch mal rein glitchen wenn wir gerade sind bei den externen GPU Gehäuse,
ich das richtig gelesen habe dann hat die neueste 10 13.4 Beta.
Also. 4 Beta 1 kann jetzt.
Automatisch umschalten wenn man diese externe GPU anschließen muss man sich früh immer ausloggen sehen User und wieder einloggen und dann ging das das muss man inzwischen nicht mehr machen sondern der kann jetzt live umschalten.
Das habe ich übrigens versucht habe extra noch mal neues frisches OS aufgesetzt aber das hat alles irgendwie nicht funktioniert von Beta Version 10134 B1 oder irgendwie so was erfand das stand da so haben die gesagt,
ja irgendwann probiere ich das noch mal das Problem ist das ja nur der Firmenrechner hatte es USB3 und den habe ich nur manchmal zu Hause egal immer an die Kunden denken ne,
was wenn die Kopfhörer ja weil ich zahle noch nichts Kapitel 1 Kapitel 1 Kapitel.
Du wolltest gerade Danksagungen machen jetzt seid ihr schon bei Software Update,
na ich habe mich bei Christoph bedanken für einen Anker Band Adapter für die USB lade Geschichte das großartig wenn man am Reisen und ist und für Stefan dem ja noch ein ich habe mal das Kissen Geschenk der was,
tolles werde ich im Urlaub jetzt natürlich versuche immer auf wenig Gewicht und trotzdem viel dabei zu haben und Sonntag los ist weiß und manche ne.
Soll man Urlaub formal loswerden Klaus ist weiße Magie.
Bin ich mitnehmen linetreisen mehr Geld wegen dem iPhone.
Aber denn das was ist ja ich habe das Kissen habe ich in groß.
Elgros schon ich kann aber nix reinschmeissen Thermarest ja,
allgemein also ich habe von Hermann genau ich habe von Thermarest meine Isomatte auch und die haben Tamaris Camping Kopfkissen genau und das gibt halt in verschiedenen Größen,
schon und du hast schon und irgendwann in jungen Jahren dachte ich mir boah geil ich will das XL Kissen haben.
Er ist auch großartig aber nicht wenn man dann doch mit dem Rucksack unterwegs ist und wenig Platz hat.
Ich habe mir davon jetzt noch das kleine Kissen gewünscht weil ich find's auch immer schön wenn man im Urlaub ist so ein so ein paar wohl viele Dinge dabeizuhaben viel Größen.
Ich habe Größe S und Größe XL jetzt also XL hatte ich vorher schon,
Anker wandadapter das einfach in USB Dingen zum direkten.
Sehr guten Laune auf dem Wunschzettel wandadapter achso mit mit Eurostecker dran.
Na ja das ist praktisch ohne Kabel aber da.
Verstehe allemal kann auch das andere gut hin wenn man das irgendwie anders haben möchte aber ich finde auch als Wand Dings auch besser,
weiß dass man kein USB C hat oder braucht es dieses wandadapter Teil cool und wenn du aber ein USB-Gerät mitnimmst auch im Urlaub.
Dann ist der andere mit dem Kabel wiederum cool der wirklich viermal USB und ein USB C.
Also richtig Urlaub,
bitte ja aber Telefon ist ja solange man was zum Podcast hören dabei hat das wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht aber,
mir wurde die Realität nicht komplett weggenommen dieses Mal beim Urlaub da habe ich mich dann habe ich den nicht widersetzt und habe dann auch ein bisschen Podcast gehört.
Im Urlaub denn ohne Metaebene ist ja auch kein Urlaub.
Ich habe versucht ich habe das heißt du da gemacht in den Sendungen,
wenn ich habe glaube ich ja in der Tat im Bus gehört das man muss ja mal sagen in Deutschland hat Maria completo Freakshow,
Andy Bus und Internet.
Also Deutschland Entwicklung 55.
Die wahrscheinlich auch schon längst tot sind hoffen wir mal ja das stimmt auch,
wohin also ich wollte einfach direkt mit meinem Urlaub rein weil.
Ich war ja auch in dem sehr hoch entwickelten Land nennt sich Costa Rica ist tausendmal besser als Deutschland weil nicht nur das auf öffentlichen Plätzen WLAN zur Verfügung steht nein mann hat sowas wie Reisebusse,
oder nee lass uns zuerst Shuttlebusse wohl man neuen Leute reinpassen da gibt es WLAN.
Heißt du sitzt in der Pampa im Bus einen großen Reisen Bussen wenn du Glück hast und wenn du noch mehr Glück hast funktioniert es auch.
Und da war wirklich so überhaupt keine Probleme ich sitze irgendein Kleinbus Pfeil Richtung Karibik Strand und konnte Freakshow.
Über deren WLAN WLAN in dem Bus und in Deutschland Dritte-Welt-Land geht das 2050 vielleicht gegessen weil wir das ja auch bei Logistik thematisiert haben.
Schreib ja auch an einer wenn du im Bus von Bogota nach Medellin,
Kolumbien wo VW im Jahr noch Krieg herrschte das kostenlose Livestreams und erfährt das sind doch in 22 Jahren auch weil Fernbussen haben will.
Womit es ist groß ist 32 Jahren in Deutschland flixbus ist es halt so.
Entweder sagt der Fahrer gleich am Anfang der Fahrt heute funktioniert das Wlan nicht.
Oder er sagt es nicht und es funktioniert trotzdem nicht oder nur also ich kann mich erinnern dass der Code geschrieben habe und irgendwie ein paar Zeilen in git eingecheckt habe und habe dann versucht ein git push zu machen und irgendwie soll.
Gefühl 2 Kilobyte wollten einfach nicht irgendwie ins Internet gehen weil es war nicht gut genug dafür.
Jaja Mittel und Südamerika nur zu empfehlen wie gesagt wo kämen wir denn eigentlich hin wenn wir im,
Stadtpark Friedrichshain Volkspark Friedrichshain wo auch immer WLAN vielleicht noch retten in Deutschland WLAN wenn man einfach nicht dagewesen braucht auch kein WLAN mehr,
ich habe dann am letzten muss am letzten Tag so ziemlich gewesen sein ich weiß nicht ob in Nicaragua oder in Panama gestern die Werbung von klar,
klaro,
was irgendeinen mobilanbieter ist der damit Werbung macht das ist keine Roaming bei dir und die haben die Netzabdeckung von gesamt ich glaube keine Roaming,
keine Roaming Gebühren für Südamerika genau wie kann man damit werben keinen ruins Amerika bis Nordamerika.
Hallo Zukunft und ich habe mir leider keine SIM-Karte dort geholt haben und Praktika auch.
Warum eigentlich auch nicht mein lieber Mann,
na ja aber das habe ich doch schon tausendmal beklagt aber das wird ja jetzt nicht der einzige Grund gewesen sein dass du dahin gefahren bist ne.
Nee ich wollte ja auch bisschen Sonne haben bisschen ja und eigentlich wollte ich den Regen nicht aber wir mussten dann von der Karibikküste so gezwungenermaßen fliehen an den Pazifik,
von der ganzen Regenschauer einen etwas größeren.
Also unklar warum das Wetter da so war ich weiß nicht ob das normal ist oder ob das mit dem Klimawandel zu tun wovon die Leute reden ne weiß man ja auch nicht.
Na dann sind wir halt am Pacific geflohen da gab es am wenigstens kuschelige 33 Grad und Sonne,
das hat sie mich schön an genau was noch in Costa Rica sehr Lust mir Nicaragua sehr lustig war da gab es auch gelbe Busse wie in Berlin also der Berliner Stadtverkehr ist gelb wenn sie BVG,
und in Nicaragua heißt das Chicken buses gelb passen viele Leute rein und alles was man so mitnehmen will.
Relativ günstig zum Fahren was aber nicht so günstig ist es wenn man da rein kotzt da gibt's ein Hinweisschild mit kotzen in den Bus kostet.
Dazu ein bisschen 55 Cent und die Vater 30 Cent gekostet also Kotzen ist teurer als die Busfahrt,
wenn hier einer kurzen Rosenmuster 5 € zahlen,
ungleich 50 Cent für seinen Bus ausgeben dann wird er nicht so gefahren dass man,
kosmokiller so DSDS ganz normal eigentlich gefahren ich weiß nicht warum das da stand was die was die so für Probleme haben mit ihren Fahrgästen weil da ist es so üblich dass er so drei Leute,
Bus gehören der Fahrer der fährt einer der an sag wo es hingeht und die Fahrräder auf das Dach hoch schmeißt und noch einer der's Geld einsammelt.
Unklar warum ist das auch noch aber das Personal scheint billig zu sein und diese chickenbuzz es sind alte US Schulbusse.
Die in Panama sehr gern auch sehr stark dekoriert werden also,
Musterlösung auch Geld weil die kommen ja sonst wo es angeht oder mit allen LEDs die man finden kann und vielleicht auch ein bisschen so ein Sehschlitz für den Fahrer damit der sieht wohin fährt sehr lustig.
Wenn wir da erlebt bevor der Urlaub losgegangen ist hatten wir so,
so eine interessante Erfahrung mit dem mit dem Systemen des Frankfurter Flughafens was irgendwie immer Ausfall hatte oder irgendwelche Probleme mit Ihrem System I Pack Sortierung.
Ja auch auch das hatte ich als ich nach Jamaika bin ja wir hatten das auch.
Das Problem war aber auch dass die was wir sind in Berlin los und konnten da nicht landen.
Und das heißt der Flug hatte halt einfach ein bisschen verschoben und der bist noch rechtzeitig angekommen in den Flieger rein gerannt aber das Gepäck kam dann irgendwie so anderthalb Tage später.
Also I das war der erste Tag so Urlaub so theoretisch sollten wir weiter fahren und jetzt ist das Gepäck nicht da.
Aber es hat sich dann glücklicherweise geklärt.
Der einzige Nachteil im Urlaub ich habe meine Wandersachen nicht mitgehabt und Nicaragua Costa Rica hat echt viele geile Vulkane also wer mal richtig gut wandern möchte.
Und auch Vulkane steht was ich leider sehr sehr geil finde,
aktive Vulkane wo man so ein dilaver reingucken kann das habe ich natürlich auch mitgenommen ist nur zu empfehlen Nicaraguan Costa Rica da gibt's alles was aktives und dampft und stinkt wunderschön.
Wie ist das so ich habe noch nie in so ein Lama ding reingeguckt also ich habe jetzt aktivieren aber wirklich gesehen weil es dunkel war und.
Du siehst also hast also halt weil wenn Douglas ich soll diese sowieso ein Flammenmeer sag ich mal so leid dass du so ein guter Dampf hochsteigt und wo sie ist.
Was ist ja schwarz-rot alles gefärbt ist und es gab einen Punkt wo man wirklich dilaver gesehen hat die sich dann so,
umgewälzt hat also wieso Knetmasse oder ein Teig den du knetet und hin und her weil sie hat sich Diesel aber da drin bewegt das wirklich sehr sehr schön aus,
und der Vulkan war auch gar nicht so laut und hat auch nicht so einen extremen Ausstoß von schwefelgase gehabt dass es mich gewundert hat weil ich war in Chile vor zwei Jahren jetzt auch im Urlaub.
Wo der Vulkan auch aktiv war da hast du aber das Lava Gelaber nicht gesehen ich war da tagsüber oben und da dürftest du nur mit einer Gasmaske hören weil das so aus geschwefelt hat.
Und der war viel lauter als ich weiß nicht ob da die Lava einfach höher stand was ist das die laut.
Man hört es so die haben so ein Grummeln das Geräusch also Sohn.
Wasserfall ähnlich wie so ein Wasserfall ja sehr viel Energie und Energie Geräusch hat für mich.
So ist Lava ähnlich aber dadurch dass sie jetzt nicht so nah an dir dran dass wir wie bei einem wie einem Wasserfall wir sagen so ein gedämpftes Grummeln.
Ich weiß nicht wann hört ich find mein hört die Energie von diesem von diesem von diesem Gebilde halt von der von der Lava die da drin ist sie so raus.
Zu Hause bewegt.
Also ich finde Vulkane wirklich das faszinierende was es gibt und ma so in die Lava rein zu gucken hat mich sehr erfreut,
leider habe ich diesmal nicht so einen schönen Vulkanstein mit komme ich beim letzten Mal als ich sammle irgendwie Steiner ganz gern so ein richtig schönes,
Schwarze Sonne Schwarzenburg Arnstein der in allen Farben Zillertaler mitgenommen das habe ich diesmal nicht nicht gefunden leider.
Und hast du auch einen schönen Wochen höre am Vulkan getroffen.
Ich habe gar kein höherer getroffen was nein hat sich niemand Zentralamerika nein ich weiß auch nicht,
Natalie muss ich doch noch mal meine Statistiken checken das geht ja gar nicht nein es hat sich niemand getraut weil ich so grimmig gucken.
Bei Sonne wieder grummels da so gerade rum.
Ja also wenn wenn ich Hunger habe bin ich auch ähnlich grummelig übermäßig genau Kurzform langsam sehr schön.
Du stehst gerade auf diese Story an du hast aber so ein Vulkan Maja ja genau das was erzählt dass so ein geheimer hören Vulkan.
Nee das war damals.
Es war völlig absurd weil wir waren da in diesem National Park Mount Saint helens National Park unterwegs und Kolleginnen und dann kommen da so zwei deutsche an und fragen nach dem Weg.
Und du antwortest und ich habe den Halt auf Deutsch geantwortet also ihr und er guckt mich dann so an und meinte,
sag mal bist du der Robbie woraufhin seine Freundin und mein Kollege beide geguckt haben als wäre hier irgendwer das Mondkalb geschlachtetes war sehr nett.
Donnerstag ja gesagt immer wieder schön noch mal Grüße an dieser Stelle.
Kann man sich ewig dran erinnern.
Nee kein höre gesehen aber ich bin meinem Ziel von sehr leichten reisen wieder etwas näher gekommen weil ich ja ziemlich viel meine Klamotten selbst genäht habe und ich somit zwei zweieinhalb Pax sekken,
vom Wandern ausgekommen was wirklich enorm wenig war meiner fetten den ganzen anderen scheiß jemand wie mitschleppen muss.
Und ja ich habe gemerkt dass zwei Drittel meiner Klamotten mittlerweile selbst genäht sind deswegen wäre es umso schlimmer gewesen hätte die Lufthansa mein Gepäck verschlammt frühestens nicht zu ersetzen.
Schnappatmung mit ich will aber gar nicht nachdenken was ist ein Eingabefeld ins Handgepäck genommen ja ich bin jetzt auch schon am überlegen ob die nächste Reise mit einem wesentlich kleineren Rucksack,
vor allem meine Sachen reinpacken vonstattengehen sehe ich bin jetzt bei 60 Litern gewesen und da wäre auch also.
Der wäre auch noch ein kleinerer Rucksack gelange ich habe halt keinen kleineren gerade gehabt weil man hat immer ja so Sachen die man eigentlich einchecken will.
Also Messer z.b. und.
So andere hier Drogerieartikel du willst nichts da kaufen sowas wie Sonnencreme da bist du mal du kannst du ja noch ein kleines Köfferchen dazu so ein faltkoffer hinnehmen was es nur zum Einchecken benutzt.
Warum bitte Sonnencreme nicht kaufen weil sie sich abzocken meinste und den anderen Ländern.
Ja aber weiß nicht ob sich dafür trotzdem Lohn zu Sonnencreme quer durch die Welt zu schleppen wegen den 5 € Unterschied.
Na du weißt ja vorher nicht unbedingt wie viel es sind also die 20 $ da war ich relativ froh dass ich das günstigste genommen habe alles kommt er wirklich auf die Länder drauf an wo Du hin fliegst das kann unter Umständen ein sehr teures Vergnügen sein oder du findest den er gar nicht.
Das ist noch die andere schuld an den richtigen Stellen einkaufen geht aus wenn ich in den Touri Shop nehmen im Hotel gehen oder was bei uns ist alles nur eine Apotheke erhältlich.
Also musst du halt teilweise also teilweise Sonnencreme gab es in Ecuador nur in der Apotheke ich glaube auch diesmal in Costa Rica oder Panama auch.
Das wahrscheinlich was privilegiert ist für weiße und weiße sind in der Regel immer privilegiert und solchen Region ganz wenig.
Das ist leider was kannst du jetzt empfehlen also Panama nur die Inseln,
also pacifico die kalkwachs deep euch war ein paarmal auf einer der Karibik Inseln den Boca del Toro die kann ich sehr empfehlen ansonsten wenn ihr mit Müllbergen kein Problem habe ist,
Panama bestimmt eine tolle Sache also die Müllberge.
Ja wo ist doch nicht ganz Panama in Mühlberg oder doch.
Na ja und ich finde sie achten da ganz schön wenig drauf ich weiß nicht ob den das egal ist dass das alles rum liegt und teilweise ins Meer gespült wird fand ich wirklich also es fand ich wirklich furchtbar,
schlimm so zu sehen wir da links dieser.
Darling Stylings die Seite links links links links ist Bocas del Toro die Inselgruppe dass er wirklich sehr schön.
Einsame Strände also was wird jetzt meintest wir haben jetzt gerade mal Google Earth Kino unerwartet im gibt ja Google Earth genau also kann ich wirklich sehr empfehlen das.
Sehr schön umfallen wenn man auch tauchen will Shop surfen kann man da nicht aber tauchen und schnorcheln kann man da sind die Korallen und so.
Korallen genau die haben Thailänder Seesterne.
Die hat einige Stellen so auf ploppen ganz ganz viele also habe ich zu superschönen gerade wenn man weg kommt von der Hauptinsel.
Oder Partytourismus dann teilweise auch so ein bisschen stattfindet.
Was man natürlich in Kauf nehmen damit der Flughafen ist sehr lustig aber da fliegt irgendwie ein zweimal am Tag was wenn überhaupt also du kommst da mit dem Shuttlebus und mit einer Speed Fähre,
oder fährt mit der langsamen Fähre in der Regel besser hin und Tim Cook gerade auf so einen sichelförmigen Streifen Strand dass es da wo auch der Friedhof am Strand ist.
Fische die Mikrowelle.
Eine Leiche abgedeckt anderes nicht soweit das war eine schöne Gruppe es hat viel Spaß gemacht.
Nee das sind Häuser.
Das wäre sehr kleine Häuser mehr,
Herr Dennis war dabei stand dir auch überall auf den Bäumen mit deinem Namen Gymnasium Panama diese Inseln sind sehr schön.
Kann ich empfehlen das restliche lang da muss man gucken was man machen will also,
ah okay für die Durchreise Costa Rica kann ich also komplett zu 150 % empfehlen das ist ein schönes Land das ist sehr gut ausgebaut die Leute haben eine geile Mentalität irgendwie.
Ich weiß nicht fand das sehr herzlich und sie haben mir auch irgendwie geschafft sich so ein bisschen im Stress von der Backe verhalten haben kein Militär.
Das ist das Interessante ist ja mal in den Staatshaushalt irgendwie 0,2% geht dann irgend so,
geht denn das weiß ich nicht Günter extrem produziert von den USA das ist eigentlich hier Sicherheitskonzept ist einfach.
Servus a freundlich zu sein das gehört wohl auch glaube ich den zweiten teilen Amerikanern muss man also.
Das muss man zum bisschen einmal berücksichtigen dass du überall in den Gebieten wo es sehr schön ist ich sehr schön leben lässt die ganzen Amerikaner halt hast Wiederaufleben.
Was an einigen Stellen unangenehme so wenn man,
die Art und Weise von denen nicht so mag aber an anderen Stellen dass die können das mit der Livemusik z.b. dein Handy da irgendwie schöne Pubs sich hin gebaut aufpassen dass er dann nicht aber so wo sie halt wirklich auch gute Musik spielen so abseits von dem.
Partytourismus sage ich mal an weil das hast du ja nach wie vor auch da überall wo viele Leute sind dass du dann so Hostels aufploppen hast sie dann so typische Party Hostels sind.
Jawa Costa Rica hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht ich habe da auch angefangen den Tauchschein zu machen was hat sich allerdings mit meinen Ohren nicht so ganz vertragen.
Muss das mit dem Druckausgleich üben und hätte deswegen auch eine Bitte an die Hörer wenn jemanden eine Tauchschule empfehlen kann in und um Berlin vielleicht,
auch wenn es außerhalb von Berlin das muss ich gucken wie ich das mache,
aber ich habe einen Tauchschein angefangen und mir fehlen theoretisch noch die wassergänge wirklich mit tauchen aus dem Pool Geschichten und so weiter habe ich alles erledigt und den Theorie Kram und wäre sehr dankbar für Infos was eine gute Tauchschule ist die auch.
Die auf der geduldig sein ich hatte eine sehr geduldige Tauchlehrer die alles wissen nicht im Pool gemacht.
Und wird Inhalt der sehr gern zu Ende machen und es muss nicht im Meer sein weil so Wellengang und einen Schiff neben dir ist noch mal so ein Stressfaktor mehr wenn du.
Tauchen noch nicht so kannst und auch vor allem vielleicht ein bisschen ängstlicher bist was so neue Umgebung und sich so dran gewöhnen ist.
Deswegen für Hinweise so im Raum Berlin also ein wenn das dann halt nur ein See ist dann ist das halt so,
weil ich würde es eigentlich ganz gerne noch versuchen diesen Tauchschein zu machen was hat echt Spaß gemacht sich mit diesen ganzen Equipment auseinanderzusetzen,
Tauchschein halt eben nicht hier in irgend so ein Berliner oder Umland Seemacht sondern halt eben irgendwo schicke mir halt das Problem mit den Ohren dass ich halt wirklich den Druckausgleich nicht hinbekommen haben können kannst du doch selber üben im Schwimmbad einfach da wo heute 3 Meter tief ist er lässt du dich runter und dann kommen die Schmerzen dann drückst du gegen.
Bist du das halt drauf hast.
Ja aber das kannst halt natürlich nicht wenn du im Urlaub bist und vielleicht so ein kleinen Zeitdruck dahinter hast ne das kannst du ja selber machen zu müssen,
genau das ist die eine Sache aber ich hatte halt an einem Tag war wirklich so ein bisschen so der Massentourismus an der Tankstelle also unser Boot dann kam halt noch andere Boote daran.
Und da ich ohne also ich trag eine Brille und ich hatte an dem Zeitpunkt keiner keine Linsen oder sowas dran das heißt ich habe.
Abstände zu anderen Personen und zu den anderen Schiffen nicht so wahrgenommen also für mich war nie viel näher dran und obwohl es gar nicht so war seit ich habe da ein extrem Stressfaktor gehabt und haben dann.
Beim letzten Versuch dann hat er wirklich sehr sehr viel Panik gehabt und ich würde.
Dann lieber sagen weniger sehen in in Berliner Seen ja aber dafür vielleicht einfach ein bisschen weniger Stress haben und.
Ja das ist doch nicht so geil wie irgendwelche fishies bunte Fisch ist neben dir rumfliegen zu sehen oder einen Rochen oder irgendsowas klar.
Aber wenn es einfacher ist und weniger Stress bedeutet finde ich das immer noch nie angenehmerweise tauchen zittern weil ich find halt schon.
Wenn du da diesen Tauchkurs machst und,
dich nicht nur mit dem Equipment auseinandersetzen muss wie du irgendwie atmest weil wie du deine Sachen ausziehst und so weiter sondern außerdem noch siehst was alles dabei passieren kann also one das ist Trommelfell platzt = noch das kleinere Problem aber irgendwie,
was denn in den Penny Lehrvideos so was passiert wenn jemand irgendwie Bus bewusstlos nach oben kommt was muss man machen und nicht so.
Warum will ich tauchen noch mal aber das noch jemand sagen also es halt selten Risikosport halt wie jeder,
andere Autosport halt in der Reha sich mein lieber im Klettern und beim Klettern habe ich halt auch sehr viel Zeit und geduldige Freunde gehabt die mir einfach die Angst genommen haben und dasselbe hätte ich ganz gerne eigentlich auch beim Tauchen,
und dann wenn ich mich wohl fühle will ich definitiv im Meer tauchen gehen weil ich weiß nicht,
wer will schon nicht ein Rochen gesehen oder ein Hai,
ich habe es ja auch mal probiert mit dem Tauchen aber das sagt mir nichts da gabs neulich so ein so ein Interview mit dem ehemaligen Apple Typ der das ist es dir Cyrus geomorphic Zeug gemacht wie hießen der immer so leichten Silberblick hatte.
Unterhosen Baumwolle für,
egal auf jeden Fall hat Leon bewertet wie er tauchen war und hatte irgendwie so Kameragehäuse aus aus Aluminium so ein größeres für eine dicke Spiegelreflex dabei und,
dann hatten sie aus irgendeinem Grund ein halben Fisch noch dabei um irgendwie Heia anzulocken oder sonst was auf jeden Fall war dann irgendeiner der Haie war dann irgendwie ganz schlechter Laune wegen der vielen wegen den vielen Fisch Blut im Wasser und,
dann erzählt er nur wie er dieses geile Foto schlechthin von diesem high aufnimmt weil er sieht den Heide wird immer größer geiles Bild geiles Bild bis er so feststellt.
Ich sehe die Zähne nicht mehr im suchen und dann macht er heiser schnapp.
Und landet mit den Zähnen aber auf diesem dicken Alugehäuse von seiner Kamera Nordvorpommern Scott forstall genau,
ich war in Neuseeland Fiji in Fiji tauchen.
Wurm hier in Berlin gesagt wenn du schon mal da unten bist in der Ecke Neuseeland erkennt A2 Taucherin Fiji wenn du Langeweile hast kannst du dahin gehen habe ich gemacht,
die Fidschi Neuseeland oder finde ich war in Neuseeland und mein Kumpel war das Wetter zu schlecht,
da kann man auch mal so 20 Minuten Platzregen und dann Blüte wieder die Sonne und dann meinte er will mal wohin wo warmes und dann sind wir nach Fidschi und sind tatsächlich zu diesen beiden Tauchlehrer ehemalige Punks also deutsche.
Ohne Termin in Fiji Islands davon reden wir jetzt und nicht tierisch weit weg davon drei Stunden mit dem Flieger.
3 Stunden fliegen um die Ecke von Neuseeland.
Dann habe ich bei denen Tauchschein gemacht und da habe ich auch Haie gesehen die waren so zwei Meter groß oder so aber das hört sich größer als es ist weil die durch den r************ sind oder die die.
Flosse dann ist der Hauptkörper ist ja dann nur ein Meter groß zurück also die waren nicht so riesengroß und das ging aber es sind schon schon sehr elegante Tiere wenn die da so durch durchs Wasser schleichen das ist schon ist schon.
Beeindruckende aber hat es nicht so viel Angst vor denen.
Ja vor den Barracudas wo der Tauchlehrer meinte wenn die blingbling an dir sehen dann gehen die auf dich ab weil die mögen blingbling und dann habe ich die ganze Zeit meine Uhr zu gehalten weil die ja so aus aus Metall irgendwie so ein bisschen glänzte damit die nicht wieder Beine sind die.
Haben da Bling Bling.
Sind auch hier habe ich dann Jahre später das mit einer von spreewaldplatz übern Weg gelaufen meint er besucht gerade eine Freundin da sind 2000 km ist aus deiner erstmal da unten bist am Arsch der Welt dann ist das um die Ecke.
Garant 2000 km ist aber im Flugzeug 3 Stunden das geht schon mal gleich braucht er 30 Stunden bis ich in Neuseeland war.
Ja okay, machen war nur gerade sogar.
Ich meine das ist einen Flug in innerhalb von Chile ne also.
AWO Bling Bling und Dinge klauen also gab natürlich auch Affen zu sehen vor dem einigen also vor einigen wir dann auch gewarnt so ja nichts nichts hinhalten die Klauen irgendwas und ich habe wie heißt das auf Fleisch.
Faultiere gesehen sind ja so niedlich laugh floor.
Sind ja so witzig sind sie total.
Penn bisschen coden Sport würde mir fehlen hast schon Recht aber du bist immer schön verrückt wie die Faultiere compur mir.
Nadja,
sind halt nicht so schnell beim Tippen ne also wenn du zwei oder drei Finger nur hast du musst ja nicht schnell tippen man muss ja nur gut wird nur nachdenken was man schreiben will dann Strauch mit sehr niedrigen Tipp Frequenzen guter Programmierer werden,
so gechillt wie die gucken denken die bestimmt eine ganze Menge nach so.
Ja das ist auch bitte gibt's ja nicht schon mal so erzählt sonst gleich mal raus entzündet ganz grandiosen.
Vortrag von von rich Hickey.
Bitte schon mal erzählt dass dieser Typ der closure.
Gemacht hat und der hält immer so wunderbar philosophische tagsüber so das Programmieren als solches eigentlich nur noch philosophische Torx,
aber er hat ein beiden Jahre soll ich machte erdental wirklich gut gehalten,
genau und wenn du jetzt gleich weißt was ich meine dann weißt du ja vielleicht auch von welchem Tag ich jetzt gerade rede dann.
Oder.
Nein weil er hat diverse philosophische Torx über verschiedene Dinge gehalten und zwar.
Ich glaube ich habe es leicht Lauchhammer ging um die Hängematte.
Nee sendeverlauf Heimattreffen development genau das ist klingelheller Wikia,
genau das klingst du mich nach das einzige will einzigen plausiblen mit Hängematte,
Inna Hemme German development ich krieg dann mal Rücken in der Hängematte aber das ist ein anderes Thema und vor allem nicht so reinlegen.
Sondern quer so diagonal damit der Rücken gerade.
Casio auf jeden Fall mal eben Ricky der ganz Kleinen Case macht für.
Man muss wenn man halt probieren will mal vor allem nachdenken auch ganz gut wenn man halt.
Vor mir eine Hängematte antreffen heißt es nicht dass er faules oder als unter umständlich schwer am Arbeiten,
ist das habe ich auch meinen Studis relativ also sowohl als ich im Informatik Fachbereich und Victory umfüllen programmieren also jetzt den Designern,
das da gehalten habe immer wieder gesagt,
das bevor sie halt so in den Code rein springen was ja viele ganz gerne machen vielleicht einfach mal so einen Zettel und einen Stift nehmen oder einen notiz Gerät Ihrer Wahl um sich über das Gedanken zu machen was sie vorhaben zu tun.
Um wirklich mal,
navi Sonnenkraft einfach runter zu schreiben und nicht zu programmieren direkt sondern einfach nur so ein bisschen drüber nachdenken was plant man gerade was sollst du können,
weil wenn du direkt ins programmieren startest vergisst du die Hälfte wieder oder keine Ahnung was irgendwelche trotteligen Fehler die mit ein bisschen nachdenken vielleicht nicht passiert werden und also,
Designer braucht man Gefühl zu wenig sagen wenn man Zettel und einen Stift in die Hand und programmiere nicht gleich aber,
bei einigen Informatikern war sie dieses warum denn das jetzt machen.
Japanisch einmal mit dem Bagger mal so ein bisschen durch den kurz Deppen und gucken was er tatsächlich tut ja oder das von anderen Leuten nehmen und sich mal angucken was da so drin passiert fanden viele komisch so einen Hinweis wo ich mir dachte so aus.
Total spannend und wie hilft es einem weiter wenn man.
Schritt für Schritt sich mal Sachen angucken was passiert wenn man irgendwas verändert und so weiter,
was ich gemerkt habe in meinen Programmierer Zeiten damals als die programmiert hat somit,
auf der Familie Schmidt das Ketterer und wenn das abgeschmiert ist dann halt eventuell der ganze Rechner weiter memory protection und so sehr genau was du da programmierst weil wenn das gecrasht ist und dein Rechner musste Gebote werden von Diskette noch teilweise dann hast du halt fünf Minuten gewartet bist du wieder weitermachen konnte deswegen da du wolltest einfach keine Fehler machen heute Tage,
du erstens memory protection und zweitens du baust ja so schnell was damals auch schon ewig gedauert hat bis der Sampler mal irgendwie gebaut hat,
heute der Compiler so schnell du überlegst mich ist es,
ist es so rum oder muss ich so machen willst du immer so eine da lag oder Saarland Entscheidung ist nur welche von beiden ist jetzt das richtige du machst es einfach und wenn es nicht klappt dann nimmt das andere was geht so flott,
denkst gar nicht mehr nach was das Richtige sein können oder du machst das einfach Mona ja viel schneller und dann macht er für eine neue Sprache und dann hast du wieder Zeit zum Nachdenken,
aber auch da kann man halt einfach weil die Compiler und war alles so flottes und nee leider nicht so flott sich nein habe ich nicht gemacht.
Besonders im Zusammenhang mit Objektiv sie ist der verdammt langsam oder kann verdammt langsam sein,
hättest aber auch vor eineinhalb Jahren also noch mal in dem Projekt mitgearbeitet wo Java genutzt wurde,
wie alt bist du dass ein wir zum Staaten gebracht das kontieren wie ein paar Reihen stricken nehmen bei langsamer.
Ja sag mir dann Google Earth,
ich war ja nur bei Fiji gerade vor Verzieren von Neuseeland,
wenig von gesehen ich war aber hauptsächlich um diesen riesigen Nicaraguasee drumrum varrosi Schiffsroute durch bauen.
Ja das ist aber das haben sie noch lange nicht durch ich habe mir das mal durchgelesen also Nicaragua hätte ganz gern auch so einen Geld zum so ein geldproduktion wie Panama mit dem Panamakanal und hat,
glaube ich auch in Japan oder in China einen Investor dafür gefunden,
und wir machen die Chinesen genau und an der Grenze zu Nicaragua und Costa Rica gibt es einen Fluss das heißt theoretisch wäre so ein bisschen was da.
Was aber auch drumrum ist es ziemlich viel Naturschutzgebiet was dadurch verloren gehen würde und die Pläne gibt es wohl insgesamt schon sehr sehr lange und es ist nie was passiert,
und ob da was passieren wird es jetzt ein bisschen fragwürdig und Tim ist gerade im.
Nicaraguasee auf diesen Ometepe Inseln oder der Ometepe Insel wo zwei Vulkane drauf sind da bin ich auch unterwegs gewesen.
Ja krass ja das ist ein ziemlich coole Insel.
Nur mit einem Quad unterwegs sein kann auf Straßen die nicht geklärt sind die ziemlich steil nach oben und nach unten gehen wo aber natürlich trotzdem manchmal noch ein Bus lang fährt.
Denke so okay ich komme mit diesem Quatsch hier gut voran aber habe so ein bisschen Bedenken an einigen Stellen dass man da hoch und wirklich runter kommt.
Aber ja das ist da sind die ziemlich schmerzbefreit.
Und die haben kein Flughafen auf der Insel über den fährt man dann auch drüber weil auf die Straße lang geht also dann immer abgesperrt wenn ein Mann Flieger kommt.
Auf der Hauptinsel auf der AU Grad war es dann halt halt halt halt halt und zwar halt stop da links auf La Paloma,
die Landebahn untergeht halt auch die Straße habe ich auch ein Bild von eingelegt,
Michelle kann Jumbo aber genauso ist das du hast dann davor irgendwie eine Schranke unten.
Ach so ein Gitter was kann ich genau dann ist die Landebahn auch somit so ein bisschen dürftig abgesperrt hast oder halt nicht drauf rum fährst.
Auf jeden Fall schön auf der einen Seite hast du den Vulkan und auf der anderen Seite hast es mehr böse wir mal was.
Also Vulkane gibt es reichlich und einige sehr aktive Vulkane.
Es hat genau am Pazifischen Feuerring gelegen und ich glaube Nicaragua oder Costa Rica Nicaragua hat so auf die Größe gesehen die meisten Vulkane der in der Region.
Weiß gerade um den Vulkan du kannst auch sehen wo die Lara immer so runter kommt ist ganz cool bei euch lieb Google Earth.
Wie immer noch das überzeugendste Google Produkte könnten sie ja längst ein bisschen mehr Mühe geben finde ich.
Das denke ich bei fast allen Google-Produkte ja aber da wäre es immer besonders wertvoll also nicht dass sie sich hier nicht.
Nicht schon Mühe gegeben hätten aber da geht noch was ja ist geradezu die Auflösung und die farbangleichung und so weiter da ist Apple tatsächlich mit seinem Maps.
Schäme mich gute Qualität viel besser die Auflösung sind besser als Qualität die Farbe also das haben wir echt richtig richtig gut raus aber warum in aller Welt ist unmöglich sein soll also ich benutze ja hier.
Ihr wisst das habe ich auch schon paar mal erzählt aber ich kann es gerne mal wieder geben.
Wenn Google Earth dann nur mit dem SpaceNavigator also so ohne SpaceNavigator finde ich albern mit Tastatur kann man Army nichts reißen aber dieser 3Dconnexion SpaceNavigator.
Ist ein ich weiß nicht was das Ding gerade so kostet SpaceNavigator ssgt meine Hardware ne na ja genau sind jeweils.
Also nicht ganz billig der Spaß hier in der Woche sogar zwei davon oder.
Ich habe eine Weile so eine USB Variante aber ich kann von weil es nur abraten.
Kann man auch machen aber ich habe damit irgendwie immer Ärger und mit dem USB Teil habe ich keinen Ärger kosovi 122 €.
Naja das halt so nen Teil was zum Knopf der halt fest auf dem Tisch liegt.
Und der hat sich weiß nicht wie viele Achsen zählt also ich kann die nach vorne schieben nach hinten nach links nach rechts und Mafia.
Welche nach oben und nach unten wechseln kann mein Herz gerade nicht nach vorne so.
Links rechts oben unten sind das nicht jeweils zwei Achsen also jeweils dann sind das nicht nur zwei Achsen.
Straßenbahn 4 Richtung aber nur zwei Achsen habe ich gesagt lieber Freiheitsgrade ist Clara ja die soll ich jetzt zählen.
Ist mir egal alle Pflanzen wachsen also vorne hinten eine Achse links rechts eine Achse.
Dann hoch runter eine Achse eine Achse sind schon mal drei Sorten Denkmal sicher was braucht man sonst noch dann kann man halt rotieren links rechts.
Noch eine Achse noch eine Achse und du kannst aber auch töten also kannst das ganze Ding nach vorne nach hinten kippen noch eine Achse.
Wobei du das auch in Kaisers nur nach vorne nach hinten machen ja.
Genau da seid ihr und kannst halt nicht gucken weil du kannst das Bild nicht irgendwelche auch in dem Sinne nicht nur für einen Flugsimulator eigentlich für den Flieger aber er weiß.
Und Bremen Rotation habe ich schon erwähnt ne egal also wie auch immer gefühlt in jede Richtung.
Und wenn man damit anfängt dann ist man so ein bisschen zittrig aber gibt euch einen Abend und fliegt einfach nur wie die Welt ist es einfach.
Geiles Kino weil es macht so ein Spaß ist das ja hier auch immer ne man kann also wirklich wieso.
Hubschrauberpilot alles gefühlvoll anfliegen genau in der richtigen Geschwindigkeit genau den richtigen Winkel und sich mehr oder weniger in alle Richtungen wo man will gleichzeitig hin bewegen.
Das ist einfach fantastisch also laut webseite hatte six degrees of freedom as du müsstest auch zur Seite kippen können kann nur sein dass Google das nicht kann.
Das kann sein ja genau das kann sein ja dann hast du noch ein paar Buttons dran.
2 mouse button zeigt die werden halt sehr schade das wollte ich eigentlich gerade beklagen es gibt halt keine Möglichkeit für diesen SpaceNavigator an input device zu sein für Apple Maps.
Was wieder so eine Unterlassung ist von Apple.
Dich einfach nur das extra dafür angepasst oder wie läuft der Didi interaction.
Das weiß ich nicht so genau musst du installierst du musst jetzt halt erstmal diese 3Dconnexion zur für die brauchst du halt schon.
Und dann gibt's halt so eine Reihe von so 10-15 Apps wo sie halt explizit supported sind wie diese ganzen 3D autokarten pieper Pulse ganzen so ein alter.
Seitenweise und wird auch nicht so viele auf fasse immer wieder probiert vielleicht geht's ja inzwischen auf der Webseite schlagen sie 14 Seiten vor von Apps die damit funktionieren und zwar 20 pro Seite oder so.
Na vielleicht haben wir jetzt einfach irgendwie okay das meiste gibt's nur unter Windows aber.
Ja das mag sein also die Zahl von Software auf Mac ist auf jeden Fall sehr beschränkt und ich finde nur.
Dass es sich eben schon allein nur für Google Earth ist das einzige Programm mit wichtigstes die weiß benutze aber dafür lohnt es sich nicht einfach oft so.
Situation habe wo ich mir mal nen Gelände genauer anschauen möchte sei es nur für die Reiseplanung oder Salz für eine Ahnung neue Location Camp angucken oder sowas ja.
Man kann auch wunderbar damit planen und was natürlich immer wieder mein Lieblingssport ist ist.
Orte anfliegen wo ich mal war alles alles wieder finden wo man jemals war angeblich kann aber der QuickTime Player das kriegt time wa.
Wird von dem Ding unterstützt laut webseite ach.
Nun ist Quicktime ja ja natürlich auch Technologie herausfinden.
Ja ich verstehe es nicht also ich meine was bitte hält Apple davon ab.
HID Interface für Sohn Gerät bereitzustellen wo man sich rein plaxis.
Begreife ich nicht und warum ist das dann ausgerechnet in Maps nicht drin zu mal eben diese ganze Flug.
Navigation in 20 alles besser aus aber du kannst halt nicht beliebige Blick Positionen.
Einem das nervt mich auch maßlos kannst nicht beliebig raten du kannst nicht beliebig schräg gucken und gerade bei Google Earth das kommt halt vor allem dann voll zum Tragen,
wenn du irgendwo bist wo der halten richtiges 3D Modell auch hast ne also wo die.
Wo die Daten auch so richtig stimmen es ist die Auflösung nicht toll aber du kannst einfach.
Gerade wenn du so das Gelände wenn das so halbwegs gut erfasst ist kannst du halt bei Google Earth hat einfach mal konsequent auf dem Boden aufsetzen.
Rundherum schauen und dann hast du also wirklich mal genau so den Blick wie du ihn auch sonst hättest ne nicht mit derselben Auflösung aber du kriegst wie ein relativ klares Bild davon.
Wie es aussieht wenn man sich irgendwo befindet meldet sich hier gerade mal.
Auf dem Tempelhofer Feld und kriege einfach eine relativ guten Eindruck davon von dieser Seite die dieses Gelände hat von den Dimensionen der Gebäude und das finde ich einfach fantastisch.
Großer Freund großer Freund ernährt das tagelang.
Ja wenn man so ungefähr auf Giebelhöhe das Flughafengebäude mehr kommt man nicht mehr raus ist einfach scheiße also Christa keinen guten Eindruck das ist mal wieder zu kurz gedacht,
ehrlich gesagt ich finde auch da an der Stelle ist Apple auch also ich meine dieses ganze.
Aber muss auch wissen was man weglässt und Pipapo und so.
Am Ende sind einfach Spaßverderber ja.
Also Apple in letzten Jahren eh noch mal so mehr denn je aber.
Pickup ist einfach man manchmal will man einfach auch anders.
Da kommen wir gleich auch noch mal hin.
Du bist die beste wie geht ab Ost pikape würde ich ja sagen aber na ja war schon wandern.
Auf jeden Fall Form vor dem neuen MacBook mit Touch bar.
An seine Freunde sich über Apple reden oder reden wir rein reden wir über Großereignisse die Spuren hinterlassen werden.
Und Elektroautos Elektroautos im Weltall wird keine Spur hinterlassen habt ihr den Staat gesehen habe ich gesehen aber nicht schlecht ich habe mich draufgesetzt und der jedesmal ah okay,
na gut dann machst du jetzt noch mal was anderes und dann wieder noch mal 40 Minuten nach hinten okay dann machst du jetzt noch mal was anderes und dann aber irgendwann kam dann der Staat und dann,
habe ich dir live gesehen ja vom stream.
Ich habe schon so viele Raketenstarts von SpaceX gesehen weil ich das mit diesem Grasshopper so dass die Rakete wieder landet das fand ich so geil also nachdem ich dieses Grasshopper Video gesehen habe wie sie.
Den Test schon so hoch und runter und hoch und zur Seite und wieder runter und das war schon sehr spannend aber irgendwann war es auch nicht mehr spannend weil es sind ja so oft gelungen das ist ja schon usual business bei denen.
Na ja aber das ganz neue Rakete ja was will ganz neueste auch nicht sind noch zwei Dinge links und rechts eine geklatscht,
ja es ist schon vielleicht der Portugiese ist aber die synchron gelandet wie haben sie das sah schon sehr geil aus dass sie nicht geil aber die ganze Zeit war das Bild war immer exakt,
das gleiche von den beiden Raketen.
Fernseher erst hinterher geändert,
die müssen das irgendwie noch mal zusammen geschnitten haben noch mal neu aber ich habe leider was gesehen als die Rakete also als die beiden.
Soweit an dem Land landing pad waren dass du gesehen hast er zeigt das gleiche Pet weil das nur noch einem ich weiß aber andere Beweis und da war es dann klar,
alles gesagt aber jetzt oder danach ich habe Aufnahmen gesehen wo man tatsächlich zwei unterschiedliche landing pad sieht.
Aber live war das nicht bei der Daten so gibt es nicht leicht gut ich habe es einen Tag später wieder gemacht weil ich dachte auch nämlich auch erst in hohen und danach ist mir aufgefallen da leichtes die Leiterin,
zwischen den beiden Stream deswegen waren die deswegen sah man das nicht sofort ein ganz leichtes die Leber hat zwischen den beiden aber es war eigentlich der gleiche stream.
Das hast du gesehen das waren exakt der gleichen uns,
das ist ein bisschen tagestherapie habe ich also nicht wahrgenommen aber ich habe auch nur relativ schlechte Stream Qualität gehabt in dem Moment.
Bitte zu trotz Falcon heavy launch ist gut gelaufen und man die haben dafür gesorgt dass es das rocket science nicht mehr Rock Zeit ist sondern.
Na falls keine Ahnung also das ist also funktioniert das irgendwie nicht mehr so schwer sie haben ja so schon so oft mit dem Landen hinbekommen.
Das ist schon also nicht mehr so spannend ist also nur weil es geklappt hat zu sagen es wäre nicht schwer finde ich jetzt ja,
sehr Miriam,
wollte fragen aber mit Demenz Akoya komplett neu entwickeln müssen weil er auch wieder gelandet,
und zweites Mal war es irgendwie 100 200 Meter von dem Township weg.
Was für das Traumschiff vielleicht gar nicht so verkehrt war wenn der Mittelalter kam weiß man nicht also auf jeden Fall da gab's im Livestream ja auch keine Bilder von die wussten eventuell warum.
Aber ich fand das lustig dass ihn anmacht hinterher gesagt hat,
ja der Centercourt sie hätten ja für die beiden Zeit Booster hätten sie ja die Griffins neu designt in Baden aus Titan und Erforschung und er meinte,
die waren so teuer also für ihn war das viel wichtiger dass die beiden Zeit Booster landen mit den Titan dicker damit sie die sind die Taten Zeit findest diese Griffins wieder haben Alex Center Corsa egal.
Fand ich auch nicht ganz cool ja der meinte auch sie hätten die Rakete also den Chor sowieso nicht weiter verwendet weil irgendwie Versionsnummer fürs nächste Mal ist schon wieder eine andere und das findest eine zwischen,
Victor um diese ewig geschmissen hätten Pipapo vielleicht war das auch einfach nur eine gute Ausrede man muss halt sagen von der Präsentation her war das alles mal wieder.
Top so ist man danach diese Sahnehäubchen a mit dem mit dem Spaceman und dem Auto aber haben die schon gesagt dass ich Space oddity spielen wollen weil das war nicht Space oddity danach Life on Mars.
Aber egal ich hatte gelesen sie wollen space Ort.
Insbes Nauen.
No Hero dog Hirsebrei oder war das so ähnlich wie scream.
Ja jetzt ist dann,
Auto bisschen komische an das zweite Auto im Weltall muss man sie nicht mal ein bisschen sein,
auf diese payload gepackt haben.
Kann ich einerseits verstehen für nicht andererseits ist aber auch irgendwie ein Luxusproblem.
Was ich komisch fand war dass sie nicht mal ein Peilsender drauf gemacht haben.
Das ist irgendwie dann auch Tage gebraucht hat bis der erste Hobbyastronom der Meinung war er hätte das Teil in seinem Begriff im Mikroskop soll schon in seinem Teleskop Entdecker gesendetes Auto sendet keine Signale video stream.
Nee das abgebrochen das Ding ist ja immer leer ja,
Batterie also wir haben jetzt für danach wofür darum dass das Objekt als solches noch eine Weile Strecken zu können wie es jetzt ja wohl in der Natur reden Gürtel rein fliegt.
Was kann ich was auf welchem Kurs sind Sie denn jetzt gegangen also wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe haben sie ja einfach mal versucht,
Datei soweit raus zu kicken wir sie können Flieger zur Sonne ja richtig und sie hat noch mehr Sprit überall sie dachten und genau und noch weiter aber ich weiß nicht genau was das heißt,
das heißt dass das Teil jetzt in einer Umlaufbahn um die Sonne zwischen Mars und Jupiter einschwenken wird sprich irgendwo in den Asteroidengürtel.
Duft ok.
Maso bitte dich auch wie doof gefunden Maßarbeit war ja nie geplant also nicht um den nicht um den Mars sondern Wiemers.
Na ja geplant war ja mehr so ein Maß Transfer Orbit ähnlicher Arbeit also so eine Ellipse zwischen Erdbahn und Marschbahn.
Keine Ahnung vielleicht ist es jetzt auch eine Ellipse zwischen Erdbeeren und hast du reden Gürtel Cannabis weiß ich nicht genau ja super aber ich nehme mal an dass es das Ding halt einfach irgendwie in die Grube generell Richtung gekickt haben.
Wird sich das erst in den nächsten Jahren oder weiß ich nicht Monaten man genau wissen was für eine Bahnnetz tatsächlich hat.
Würde mich nicht wundern wenn Elon Musk irgendwann noch mal irgendwas dahin schickt was dann noch mal dieses Teil sucht gemeinsam den.
Navi hast du denn den Lastwagen über den Roadster wieder einsammeln kann ja sowas.
Abschleppwagen.
Big Falcon Rocket player.
Was soll ich sagen ist das Auto ist das jetzt eigentlich der Saar außer der kommen wird oder dass dieser dieser original allererste Rothrist,
ihn angehört verstehe verstehe also so ein echtes Auto zurück haben wollen alleine für das Geld was du damit machen kannst,
ich weiß nicht genau der hat so viel Geld dass sie doch jetzt egal,
im Weltraum rumfliegt sind viel wichtiger als das Teil einzufangen uns zu Völkern ich gucke ja gerade.
Weil ich habe genau.
Wie heißt das Star Trek Discovery also auf jeden Fall ich habe meine Netflix Liste gesehen ja noch langweiliger als.
Alltag Abenteuer genau aber sie erwähnen irgendwann weil die sind ja da erschweren der Zukunft ja willst du willst du willst du.
Also Seelenheils Leute aus der Vergangenheit auf die wichtig waren und Listen halt Elon Musk auf,
Scheiße garnicht was die beiden anderen waren irgendwie Entdecker von von Amerika oder keine Ahnung was sie erwähnt haben aber da wird auf jeden Fall auch Elon Musk erwähnt als als ca space entrepreneur oder wie auch immer sehr witzig.
Bergschule Popularität ESC und der könnte noch Thema wären sein wenn er dann mal reden könnte.
Stimmt das noch Eis und dann haben sie diesen spacemind das ist ja tatsächlich ein Prototyp von dem Raumanzug den Sie da entwickeln.
Aber haben sie da auch irgendwas an Sensoren drin wenn du sagst sie haben noch nie so meinte nein.
Benjamin machen also kann mir das nicht vorstellen wie ich aber nicht irgendwas wissen also nur sagen Elon meinte nein.
Dudelsack die sind wirklich davon ausgegangen dass dich blockiert ich hatte ja so ein bisschen das Gefühl okay Elon Musk Pack da jetzt ein Roadster drauf,
damit die bei SpaceX alle noch mal ganz genau hingucken weil keiner will schuld sein dass Elon Musk Roadster in einem großen Feuer bei verschwunden ist.
Ich glaube die haben da schon genug Antrieb.
Das alles hinzubekommen und deswegen kriegen sie das auch alles hin was ich immer wieder erstaunlich finde es ja habe ich das letzte Mal schon erzählt.
Bastian wann einschlagen das Eis Dennis wird hiermit alles um sich das.
Dieses Thema Wasser junges.
Also die ganzen Kreisschneider also man darf ja auch nicht immer glauben wenn die da irgendwie Kamera auf und welche Personen halten dann denkt man ja immer das ist jetzt irgendwie so das Team und damit haben sie uns ja schon bei dieser Marslandung von diesem von dem,
marsroboter six minutes of terror.
Gassner Scheißteil University free of the epische Szene wo dieses Teams confirmed bekommt.
Das dann auch einige Leute dabei die eigentlich gar nicht sie sind ihm gehört aber das halt irgendwie alles fitter rüberkommt und wenn ein paar Leute dazu Gesetzen sind die kleinen Tricks.
Jubelperser von dem.
Sana gesehen auf dem vorletzten Kongress auf den 31.03 woher genau diese Szene auch noch mal gezeigt hat.
Was ist daran so I hier ja hier Marslandung und wie bei den Amerikanern alles.
Ich weiß ja nicht wie er damit klarkommt aber ist ja diese amerikanische gib mir irgendwie so ein bisschen.
Sowie das ja zu Beatles Apple aber,
damit weiter drin rum ja und das ist ja auch so eingebrannt bei denen.
Das hat sicher auch schon so ihre kleinsten Moment wenn man so live Podcast hört z.b. aus Amerika.
Wirklich schlimmer Diesel oder auch so so Live-Sendung also auch so Fernsehshows immer wenn.
Totaler Gast kommt rein und sagt ja ich bin aus tollerort und dann gibt's drei Leute die sind auch aus tollerort müssen die alle so,
Cover Finder deutsch ich komme aus Castrop-Rauxel,
Gastronomie ist da wie anfangen zu quietschen und Raketenstart es natürlich dann plus plus plus.
Ein sehr lieber höre hat mir ja hier schöne neue Welt von Huxley geschenkt und da wird in das ja schon.
Ein gesprochen werden sie klein sind so irgendwelche Fragen die die.
Die er im Aufzug zur Aufzucht in Form von Menschen ist natürlich komisch gesagt wir das jung danke ihre Erziehung prägt Ukraine.
Und da muss ich gerade denken die werden das bestimmt auch irgendwie im Kindergarten schon üben dass die das mit dem jubeln auf die Reihe bekommen damit die total euphorisch aussehen.
Es soll ja mehr Niesen Studios dann aber auch so Anhalter die sozialen letzte Hemmschwelle bei den Zuschauern.
Aus diesem danke es geht nicht gar nicht verstehst dann denkst du so was ist denn bei euch nicht in Ordnung also es ist halt wirklich,
was ist ja auch immer alles total amazing und jetzt um und glaubt den den nordkoreanischen Fanblock den du da gepostet hat dir natürlich auch.
Wer geil muss ich mal sagen was wir heute noch die rechte Seite lange nicht dazu gehört und das Joghurt ich muss hier weg,
in puncto Choreografie macht die Nordkoreaner glaube ich vor das gibt's ja auch ganz,
Delta war das ja noch Michael haben du hast sie an Cheerleader erinnert also irgendwie sind die neuen Player und die Amerikaner oder auch schon so ne.
Wir choreographieren unseren Juwel das ist schon so coreografia sehr schön gesagt.
Das hat aber nichts mit also es kommt halt immer alles so gespielt rüber und ich meine gerade bei so einem Ereignis will ich halt eher so davon ausgehen so.
Ja da freut man sich drüber da muss man ja nicht so gespielt rüber kommen weil das würde mir sagen ihr habt ja gar kein Interesse daran wenn ihr so gespielt aussehen musst.
Aber seit immer so dieses du bist wieder bei der Ricarda.
Oder bei den Nordkorea gilt das auch für Nordkoreaner das ein bisschen anders weil die wenig Amerikaner das nicht machen dann werden sie ja nicht gleich umgebracht.
Also nee sie werden wahrscheinlich aus ihrem gesellschaftlichen sozialen Kreis ausgeschlossen aber es ist ihr Leben noch höher,
nein das stimmt schon das kann man vielleicht nicht so direkt vergleichen aber mit dir haben ja die haben das ja auch etwas also vielleicht,
bei den Link gerade rein zufällig jemand am Start hat weil das finde ich jetzt bestimmt so nicht aber da gibt es auch so eine Show und ich glaube es war auch in Nordkorea aber ich kann nicht vorstellen irgend jemand anderes bringt,
wo die tatsächlich.
Im Stadion in seiner Gruppe die locker über 30 reingeht wenn ich mehr also richtig groß.
Audi Arbeitnehmer mit diesen Schilder mit Farbfiltern diese hochhalten und Wink Elemente nee nicht Wink Elemente sondern suche diese Schilder so Pixel mehr ja das weiß ich ja zu dir derzeit noch teilweise gemacht oder.
Ja
Bei dem Video was ich mein schaffen die das halt so richtig Dublin gleichmäßig quasi Animation abzufahren also allein die Choreografie davon abgesehen von von von,
von deren Komplexität der Show,
wie man das in so Leute sogar hinbekommt dass sie das fantastisch ich habe bekannter manchmal das andere Video hier mein Schätzchen,
bekannter Bayern Nordkorea hätten davon auch Videos geschickt also das bekommen die gelernt.
Bitte beachten Sie dass dass dass das ist mit kleinauf ist das drin sind 20 geht es nicht aber.
Na wer das gut genug kann der darf dann mal in den in den Westen bezw Süden bei dir.
Und wenn man kurze läuft da ist das Video von einer Gedanke ist wieder für die fortwährende Previews Liebe spielen hier würdiger Nachfolger von David.
Hund Irrsee jungen LED screen.
Weiß nicht ob das akustisch und wie zu ertragen ist.
Nein es ist nicht das muss ja erstmal gucken ob das irgendwie meiner Schilderung jetzt hier noch.
Standhält adidas im Stadion warte mal also sind da.
Genau das ist hier so eine riesige Wand und alle Leute halten diese Schilder in der Hand und mache da irgendwie einen.
Krasses Bild nach dem anderen und halt immer diese epische pathetische.
Samsung Musik das hier alles gerade ein bisschen gesund und nicht so ganz beeindruckend, noch mal vor.
Man hat keinen Überblick mehr hatte das wunder mich gerade dass das so wie das hast du denn immer weg.
Dann mach doch! Auf dem Feld also.
Von Nordkorea lernen heißt siegen lernen.
Sich herausgeholt angeblich die Franzosen das beeindruckt haben,
ja aber die machen das ja auch.
SpaceX DRK wir eigentlich her mit den Jubel den Amis kommen von Wasser sich vor ihr schon wieder alles kam ja wie das Ganze Gekreische ja genau also junge Leute und.
Die wir noch einiges reißen diesen Lärm auf jeden Fall die richtige Motivation die müssen ja jetzt nicht erst noch irgendwas hinterherrennen.
So außer vielmehr muss man derzeit nicht sagen hat das geklappt alles über Aktionen.
Er hätte das nachgeschaut aber ich hätte gerne mal gesehen wo die eingeschlagen ist dann die andere Rakete also wo die wirklich im Vergleich wie viel wir alle gerne gesehen aber die Bilder sind,
müsste noch noch nicht erschienen also live zu sehen war insofern spannend als dass du halt nicht wusstest.
Schaff installiert oder schafft es nicht so fern war es relativ spannend aber ich meine nach drei Minuten war halt auch alles durch.
Und ansonsten wird nächstes Thema.
Ich könnte jetzt natürlich sein wo wir ihr schon bei Elektroautos sind genau.
Das ist sehr schön zusammengefasst ja ich weiß nicht was hatte ich ihn letztes mal alles erzählt hatte ich da schon erzählt dass was erzählt die Story dass du deinen,
also ich fasse mal kurz zusammen du hast ein Elektroauto gekauft 5 Tage später ist ja einer reingeholt 669.
Daraufhin entspann sich ein etwas awkward Situation weil du versucht hast jetzt Kohle von deiner Versicherung zurückzubekommen,
bin mir nicht ganz so sicher ob ich vielleicht versuchst immer noch ja ja die Chronologie war aber wesentlichen so das Ding stand dann halt irgendwo Walsum abschlepp Parkplatz wo es aber viel Geld frisst.
Und um aber jetzt eine Bewertung für diese Versicherung,
von dem zu können muss es erstmal zum Renaulthändler schleppen kannst es aber dann da wiederum nicht abholen bevor du nicht die Vorlage von der Versicherung hast also irgendwie so.
Also wer ist am Apparat Händler der wollte das Ding nicht hergeben bevor er nicht irgendwie sein Geld sieht oder aber die Versicherung eine Kostenübernahme ihm zu viele Personen.
Letzten Endes habe ich dem dann gesagt so ja jetzt schick mir die Rechnung per PDF und ich überweist das und dann,
hat er das halt dann auch zwei Tage später dann tatsächlich zum Renault Stützpunkt gebracht.
Ohne dann auch die zwei weiteren Tage zu berechnen das war dann schon okay dämlicher Weise hat der Fahrer irgendwie den Schlüssel vergessen musste also noch mal zurück.
Was für eine Strecke Potsdam Tempelhof.
Dreiviertel Stunde schon einfach ja Nadine Hamburg oder so.
Nee und dann frag noch so ein paar Leute Hilse her ist doch kaputt wieso Schlüssel wo ich dann gesagt habe ja aber die Zentralverriegelung funktioniert halt noch und ich habe den natürlich nachdem ich irgendwie den beim beim,
Schrottplatz Lechmann sei dabei dem Abschnitt Abschleppdienst da da habe ich natürlich zu die Sachen die ich nach Hause und wollte rausgeholt habe ihn danach wieder zugemacht.
Batterie war ja auch noch voll ja.
Er war also da bei dem bei dem Renault Händler dann habe ich mit dem telefoniert aber du hast alles gut und dann hatte ich noch ein paar Sachen vergessen bin noch mal hin habe mir das Teil noch mal angeguckt,
dann auch gesehen warum der Gutachter am Telefon schon meinte dass es eindeutig ein Totalschaden.
Weil halt wirklich an der linken Seite man sieht an der Unterkante.
Da ist halt der Rahmen strukturell gebrochen also.
Da war dann wirklich nichts außerdem hat vorne dass das Vorderrad des hat ca komplett aus der Verankerung gerissen links vorne und.
Das war letzte Woche Montag war ich dann noch mal dann habe ich letzte Woche Mittwoch noch mal mit dem Renault Menschen telefoniert und da meinte so ja prima.
Das mit der Batterie das dauert jetzt sieben bis zehn Tage bis die Box da ist wo sie den Akku rein tun.
Momentan nach Frankreich zur Fabrik zu schicken wo die Dinge hergestellt werden Mann weil sie es in Deutschland nicht schicken können.
Na sie haben so viel Gepäck also sie haben so viel checken können dass der Akku nicht mehr einsatzfähig ist weil.
Weil er beschädigt ist also sie konnten sagen dass der Akku beschädigt ist was sie nicht sagen können ist wie viel die Reparatur kostet aber sie können sagen dass der Akku so beschädigt ist dass sie ihn nicht weiter.
An einen Nachbesitzer vermieten können und deswegen müssen sie in der Bahn nach Frankreich schicken weil du da können sie sind Akku Visa weiter verwerten.
Richtig wahrscheinlich nehmen sehen auseinander und verwerten die Zeilen die noch gehen und Bauern mit den Zellen mit dem noch funktionierenden Zellen wieder neuen Akku zusammen und jetzt hat mich.
Heute die Renault Bank noch mal angerufen was denn nun mit dem mit dem Gutachten sei das Problem ist nämlich dass der,
Gutachter der felsenfesten Überzeugung ist er müsste auf die Einschätzung von Renault warten bis er sein Gutachten machen kann während Draenor wiederum der felsenfesten Überzeugung ist der Gutachter müsste das nicht machen,
sondern der Gutachter müsste eigentlich nur das Auto begutachten und der Akku der ist jetzt erstmal außen vor.
Wir müssen nach ihrem Prozess noch mal überarbeiten,
die die renault-bank meinte nur naja sie würden halt jetzt gerne wissen,
wer denn jetzt der Aufkäufer dieses Autos ist damit sie dem dann nachfragen können ob der die.
Akkumiete abschließen möchte oder nicht weil wenn der Aufkäufer des Wagens tatsächlich eine akkumiete abschließen will dann müssten sie dem einen neuen Akku aus Frankreich schicken.
Weil sie vertraglich dazu verpflichtet sind das zu tun.
Na ja du kannst das Auto ohne Akku ja nicht betreiben und du kriegst das auch den Akku aber nur von Renault das heißt ja nicht einkaufen.
Nee bin ich wieso weiß ich nicht muss er mir alles anders als er verkauft Akku.
Hey du kannst nur bei der neuesten Zoe mit dem großen Akku kannst du wenn du das Auto kaufst auf den Akku mit dazu kaufen sie haben keinen Bezahlmodell vorher gehabt.
Es gibt bei der bei der so einkaufen oder genau bei der Zoe gab's dieses also bei der ursprünglichen Zoe gab es ist Verkaufsmodell nicht sondern du hast ihn immer mieten müssen du könntest auch jetzt nicht zu zur Reno gehen und sagen.
Ich würde jetzt gerne einfach kaufen,
shut up and take my money geht halt nicht so und jetzt ist es aber so da habe ich jetzt bei der bei der,
bei der Bank schon durchblicken lassen dass der dass der Gutachter wiederum gesagt hat na ja das mit dem Aufkäufer ist so eine Sache,
ich habe da so um die diversen Kandidaten durch telefoniert und die haben alle nur die Hände in die Luft genommen und,
niemand will das Ding haben und dann meinte die Frau von der Renault Bank ja aber aber.
Ja aber die Versicherung wird doch hier und so weiter und irgendwer muss doch das Auto kaufen weil es immer so ist ja irgendwie schon der Schrotthändler will das Ding haben.
Ich weiß nicht ob es einem Schrotthändler angeboten hat.
Also na ja dann kannst du kannst natürlich argumentieren mindestens mal die hinteren Türen und die Heckklappe und die die hinteren,
Lichter und Scheinwerfer und so weiter die Sitze das ist alles gut das könnte man alles ausbauen und als Ersatzteile für ein anderes Auto verwenden nur,
ich meine ja die Zoe wurde oft verkauft.
Aber das ist noch kein Golf aber halt auch nicht so oft ja das meinte ich zu ihr ja so ist halt kein Golf,
sie guckte mich durchs Telefon etwas Scheel an weil ja also der Markt für gebrauchte Ersatzteile von solchen so es ist wahrscheinlich sehr klein ja.
Selber Schrauber sehr überschaubar und jetzt weiß ich nicht genau jetzt hat die.
Mir versprochen sie würde noch mal mit dem mit dem Gutachter sprechen und dem noch mal ins Gewissen reden dass er jetzt mal sein Gutachten fertig machen soll.
Und dann schauen wir mal und was passiert jetzt im besten Fall für dich.
Im besten Fall für mich macht der Gutachter jetzt zeitnah sein Gutachten fertig schick das an die Renault Bank und vereinigen schick das an die Versicherung.
Und die Versicherung sagt wir haben uns jetzt lange genug über diesem Fall Gedanken gemacht und sind der Meinung wir müssen sowieso bezahlen und hier hast du dein Geld.
Und Zweck was ist denn der.
Wert dieses Auto ist wenn man den fünf Tage vorher gebraucht beim Händler gekauft hat sechs na ja das wird dann in dem Gutachten drin stehen.
Ja aber ich meine wissen Totalschaden ist kann man dann auf irgendeinen anderen Schluss kommen als.
Wenn er vor sechs Tagen noch so viel Geld gekostet hat da keiner ist der Wertverlust.
Der Gutachter hat mir eine Zahl gesagt was er denkt was das Teil so ungefähr Zeitwert oder Wiederbeschaffungswert mäßig.
Wert wäre dann habe ich ihm gesagt wie viel ich bezahlt habe sechs Tage vorher und dann weiter oder haben sie einen guten Deal gemacht.
Und wenn jetzt der die Zahl da rein schreibt und ich kriege die Zahl von der Versicherung mache ich noch zu guten Deal ein geringes plus sollen wir mal sehr für die Autos was für bitcoin.de.
Naja das jetzt vielleicht nicht aber.
Ja es ist jetzt nicht so dass ich mir gleich die nächstgrößere Klasse kaufen könnten er darf nicht trifft auf die Kreuze gewartet bis wieder gerammt wird,
also bei meiner Mutter war jetzt das war jetzt der best case ne der ist keine Ahnung mal sehen wann der Eintritt ist.
Also und was ist eine Alge also mann Mann Mann so ein mega etablierten Markt.
Wo alles irgendwie sich seit 30 40 50 Jahren total eingeloggt hat und alle irgendwie Bescheid wissen und dann kommt man auf einmal mit einer komplett neuen Konstellation mit der.
Keiner was anfangen kann wo es irgendwie noch kein Zweitmarkt gibt keine keine Erfahrung oder nicht mal mehr die Feuerwehr weiß wie sie mit dem Auto umgehen sollen der Feuerwehrmann der.
Der wirkte so leicht besorgten Elektroauto wir wissen gar nicht was wir machen sollen aber irgendwie.
Haben sie es geschafft den Brand der nicht entstanden ist nicht zu löschen also keine Ahnung.
Also bei meinem Motorrad habe ich hätte.
Also in Zahlung gegeben wenn ich mir neues geholt halt noch mal kurz erwähnen dass er einen Unfall mit Motorrad und das war dann auch ziemlich im Arsch dass er noch.
Dann noch ungefähr angegeben.
Hätte ich auch nur ca die Hälfte bekommen von dem was ich dann am Ende von der Versicherung bekommen sie hatte ich sozusagen auch Glück.
Und das interessante da was ich gelernt habe ist dass diese Fahrzeuge also Autos wohl auch und Motorräder,
das ist irgendwie so eine Art Verkaufsportal gibt wo diese Fahrzeuge diese defekten reingesetzt werden mit einer ziemlich genauen Beschreibung was denn defekt ist,
und dann kommen so auf Kauf Händler die in diesen Portalen drin sind und die das GE die ganze Zeit gucken was wir neue defekte Fahrzeuge reinkommen und dann.
Bieten die da alle mit Preis und der höchste kriegt das dann obwohl es noch nie gesehen hat sondern die kaufen das nach Beschriftung und das ist ein zuverlässiges Angebot also die müssen das dann auch nehmen.
Wenn dann die Beschreibung stimmt das wegen sollte die Stimmen bei sonst sagen die Eltern Beschreibung war falsch ich kaufe das doch nicht und so werden dann Autos gleich sofort verkauft oder auf Motorräder und mein Motorrad wurde auch reingestellt hat ein Händler hat doch noch relativ viel für bezahlt,
obwohl es eigentlich ziemlich komplett zerstört war es auch wirklich da war ja nichts mehr heile und.
Die bei der Versicherung wird der Preis dann aber natürlich abgezogene also wenn da Mama du hast deinen Restwert von deinem Fahrzeug ist um die 10000 € oder so,
dann nicht der Restwert sondern an der neu beschaffen ist oder Wiederbeschaffungswert wird mit 10.000 irgendwie angegeben und da findet sich dann irgendein Händler der für den altschrott der der der auf der Straße lag dir noch 1000 € gibt dann zahlt die Versicherung dir nur noch 9000,
und Diana 1000 kriegst du dann von dem Händler der den den Rest nimmt und wenn du,
dich keiner findet da muss die Versicherung die kompletten 10000 Zahlen aber es interessante fand ich dass ich da wirklich so ein Portal gibt,
wurde das rein sitzt mit dieser Beschriftung und der automatisch bieten und der Höchstbietende das Nebeneinander kam natürlich auch so Abzocke Händler die sagen 50 €,
Dieseltank für alles immer sagen 50 € ne weil wenn sie Glück haben dann gibt's keinen anderen der dass ich gerade holt so müsste wie bei ebay für Leute die Sachen und am falschen Namen wir einsetzen.
In der Sonne sitzen die ganzen 1 € Angebot und das ist bei den Autos dann scheint immer so 50 weil da kam erst mal lauter 50 € Angebote sofort,
und dann irgendwann kam einer der müssen mehr bezahlt hat und der hat's dann auch bekommen aber da gibt's halt auch noch so.
Netzwerke und und Automatismen die man gar nicht so kennt deine Autobranche wie das da so läuft und und noch einen noch einen kleinen kleiner Sache am Rande.
Der Anwalt mein Anwalt hat ja erstmal aufgrund der ganzen Aktenlage die ich davor im ausgebreitet habe erstmal David,
gibt es irgendwann Zentralverband der deutschen autoversicherungs irgendwas da gibt's so eine Hotline wo man irgendwie aus einer Autonummer feststellen er seine einem Nummernschild feststellen kann welche.
Versicherung dazu gehört zu diesem Fahrzeug genau das hat mein Anwalt auch gemacht er meint er braucht er braucht gar nicht weiter warum nur ein Kennzeichen.
Der das tatsächlich geschafft hat falsche Kennzeichen nachzufragen,
bei einer falschen Versicherung zu landen und dann war das nicht malereibetriebs sondern ein Altenpflege Vertrieb,
aber das hat sich dann relativ schnell aufgeklärt die haben den Case dann auch wieder zugemacht,
der war recht freundlich der Herr zieht dann noch mal nachgefragt habe ob ich denn jetzt noch was machen müsste ich auch so ey Alter als ich habe echt genug am Hals jetzt mich auch noch das.
Das war ja.
Damit habe ich mich die letzten Tage letzten zwei Wochen seit wir uns das letzte Mal gesehen haben rum geplagt der schön.
Ich suche gerade einen Tweet und du selber.
Alles fing damit an aber ich bin ganz nah dran bei euch.
Das irgendjemand feststellte.
Wobei er nur jemanden anderen Redwitzer wie das so ist aber er kann dann auf einmal so mitten mitten ins Geräusch.
Hat sich um 3 Uhr zur Handel der irgendwie in Deutschland arbeitet und hier auch so ein bisschen mit dem Humor hadert.
Auf jeden Fall hat er ein paar lustige Feststellungen zusammengetragen über die deutsche Sprache die ich bemerkte.
Und ich besuche gerade ich kann das aber erklären ist ja ganz einfach du kannst ja mal den ersten mal raussuchen werde nicht den anderen auch suche Filmtitel.
Nein nicht den Tweet also es fing alles an mit umfahren.
Von der Feststellung des umfahren ja sowohl bedeutet dass man etwas um fährt also überfährt quasi ja.
Als auch etwas um Pferd also außenrum drumherum fährt um nicht zu umfahren also wenn du das Umfallen verhindern willst musst es halt umfahren umfahren.
Kann ich so bisschen grübeln was die deutsche Sprache hier mit unserem Kopf versucht einzustellen ja schön.
Good luck learning Bad language.
Das ist eine Umfang kommt halt auch von Umfallen umschmeißen umkippen umfahren.
Oder andere umfahren kommt von drumherum die Abkürzung um Fahrenheit oder als ich meine eigentlich ist jetzt nicht Atze bedeutet dasselbe Wort ein Gegenteil.
Sondern wie geil und verdammte Axt warum finde ich denn jetzt hier die anderen.
Bitte nicht weil er hatte dann noch eine ganze Reihe an Twitter der viel Alltag.
Schäferhund alter Schwede.
Erstens finde ich bin jetzt schon da wo er sich über die deutschen aufregt die ihn dann irgendwie mit irgendwelchen Details wieder so stackenblochen versucht haben,
und ich bin eine andere Richtung in der Zeit ihr könnt gerne noch ein paar Werbe und Meinungen zu umfahren von euch geben.
Ja ich fand es ganz niedlich aber na ja.
Schön finde ich die Worte die mit n anfangen wo ist die Bedeutung von nicht und nicht mehr gibt.
Also das Ungetüm.
Aber es gibt kein Gefühl oder der Unflat aber es gibt keinen Flath oder flat ich sein gibt nur unflätig und kein PUK wo es Unfug gibt.
Na dann gibt's nur bei der Sendung mit der Maus.
V&B war Holland was gibt auf einen Zug oder nicht das ist das was war Holland Mal raus gearbeitet hat und das Gegenteil Rundfunk bei altfalter Fug.
Aber du hast recht es ist immer wieder spannend wenn man einem nicht deutschen in welche Begriffe dann auf Deutsch sagt wenn er fragt was heißt das und dass,
sagst du wieso deutsch hast und erkennt ein anderes ein Wort dann da raus aber in einem anderen Zusammenhang und fragte ich dann irgendwelche Sachen und dann so,
habe ich mir noch nie so richtig darüber Gedanken gemacht ich habe garnicht was das wofür Beispiel aber an aber gerade wenn es dann um zusammengesetzte Wörter Substantive so geht.
Im übrigen gibt es getrieben.
Es ist halt nur ein altes Wort was wir ja gesagt das ist schon klar dass es das gibt nur ist es halt irgendwie verschwunden und niemand weiß auch genau was ein Getüm ist,
umfahren und umfahren nachfragen ergibt sich das nicht in der Betonung.
Na ja ja im Buch aber nicht im Schriftbild jetzt nicht genug nicht aber dann Text du musst dann halt genau das tun das ist.
Ja also das ist gerade weil ich nämlich gerade so versuche herauszufinden.
Was ist denn das Problem immer wieder dass ich im Kopf halt auch das anders betone also umfahren und umfahren für mich.
Besonders wenn man,
das ist ja schon fast chinesisches hat also was damit zu tun wie du etwas aus sprichst und nicht was du aussprichst und das ist eigentlich sehr ungewöhnlich für deutsch was er für sich immer.
Behauptet doch sehr akkurat zu sein,
na ja ja man kann im deutschen durch wenige Buchstaben Modifikationen zweifelhaft Vorrang erklären wie sich Dinge und welche Dinge sich jetzt aufeinander beziehen was z.b. im englischen komplett verloren geht.
Weck mich doch ein bisschen.
Geschädigt ich habe eine meiner besten Freundin des Logopäden und die erzählt mir dann halt immer so von so sprach Sachen wie sie halt mit Kindern irgendwelche Sprachübung übung macht und da es mir das dann also dann halt aus ne zehn Jahren und dadurch.
Ist das für mich gar nicht mehr so so eine akkurate korrekte Sprache sondern dass es dir sehr viel mit Betonung und.
Find ich ja so stutzig dass du das in so einer Karate sollen wir auf eine andere Beispiele ein wo,
deutsch auf einmal komplett anders wird weil du es anders betonst na ja wenn du wenn du jetzt die Länge von Vokalen z.b. nimmst dann schon sowas wie Masse und Maße.
Ja wird anders geschrieben wird anders ja aber das geschrieben aber und in Massen ist halt ein anderer Buchstabe.
Wenn du in sslz hast ja.
Was bedeutet Anästhesie.
Kommt das nämlich auch wieder häufiger vor aber das ist ja die deutsche Sprache beleidige.
30 unter der Maßgabe bewerten ob man eine Tasche wird deutsche Tastatur hat oder nicht dass der deutschen Sprache mal erstmal scheißegal sein.
Bin ich,
so ich hoffe das Jahr auf der Sieger 16 tendiere zu deiner Meinung aber mich wundert es nicht dass es bald dass man Beispiele findet wo hier eine Betonung die Sie die Bedeutung auch ändert,
also ich glaube das ist nicht es gibt nicht viele Beispiele aber man wird sie sicherlich finden also das ist so ist halt so.
Verdammte Axt.
Man sie ganzes JavaScript verseuchte browser scheiße hier die funktioniert auch alles nicht mehr Hallo.
Man kann auch nicht in den Cheat von einem User suchen das geht nicht doch kann man ja ja aber ich weiß gerade nicht genau wonach ich suche ich weiß nur alles.
Ich weiß noch in etwa wonach ich suche und irgendwie macht es diese ganze hier hat eine Eins.
Sparkasse und Sparkasse das ist großartig.
Andere Sachen ja wird aber gleich geschrieben ja interessant finde ich aber wo sitzt dann das selbe Wort sowohl die eine Bedeutung hat als auch etwas exakte Gegenteil davon.
Ja okay the deep waschsachen sind wahrscheinlich sehr rar gesät und da hat er Glück gefunden gehabt dass er sowas gefunden hat.
Naja Teilen z.b. ja also Teil heißt er sowohl es irgendwie in.
Als ob das jetzt für dich Gegenteil ist und muss man wenn man argumentieren aber Teil heißt ja sowohl dieses sharing.
Den sharing Aspekt also du teilst etwas Besseres gemeinsame teilen heißt aber halt eigentlich auch es auf.
Air Sharing reading this now 2 unterschieden aber da kommt doch dasselbe also,
als ob sharing und divide jetzt wirklich wirklich so ein Unterschied ist da bin ich mir da früher war das halt mit dem Teilen war halt das Brot und zwei Hälften teilen und dann das war das Teilen da kommt das her oder nicht.
Ja weiß ich dass das selbe mal gewesen und zwischen deshalb ja.
War denn das andere.
Dante ist bzw halt dann gibt's noch so diese Beispiele, retten Leben ne.
Wir essen Opa.
Wie ist das schlaue Menschen Remscheid die das genau Punkt gebracht haben diese antonymen Sachen sind das Magazin Wikipedia-Eintrag dazu Erfurt.
Schlaue Hörer Hörer Antonym.
Das habe ich auch gerade so einen schönen Artikel hier noch gab es nicht so eine gesunde Gerichte Scheidung in den USA wo auch sozusagen ein, in einem Gesetzestext dazu geführt hat das irgendwelche truck driver ihr Recht bekommen haben,
ja das ist das ist ne wirklich absurde Absurdistan mir echt Park Songs wo es ja immer wieder Beispiele gibt,
klar ist oder du kannst Deutsch genauso passieren,
ja aber die Argumentation die DT die da aufmachen würdest du im deutschen so nicht machen können weil du in jedem Duden findest wie es gemeint ist.
Ja weil deutsch halt sehr viel genauer ist aber das heißt ja nicht dass es nicht auch Fälle gibt wo ein, ein riesen Unterschied machen kann ob du das willst oder nicht.
Ja natürlich und ich finde gerade im juristischen was ja Samuel eigentlich so die Disziplin ist die.
Obwohl perse eigentlich nicht technisch den programmieren doch der am nächsten steht.
Nicht nur code is law sondern auch läusekot Vergleich zu Grad.
Messer mit Programmieren wo sehr viel Interpretation ist bei recht.
Ja dann wie viel Interpretation da ist das hängt halt von deinem Gesetzestext ab wenn du einen Vertrag schreibst dann muss der halt.
Möglichst unzweideutig rüber kommen weil genau dafür ist er ja gemacht ein Vertrag ist ein Gesetz Gesetzestext oder ein Vertragswerk juristisches Werk ist gemacht um im.
Falle eines Falles mit klare.
Bedingung wollen eine klare Reaktion auf diesem Fall darzulegen das soll eindeutig dann sein.
Vertragswerk ist halt in dem Moment gut wo es eben.
Richtig kodifiziertes in deinem mit dem was du haben möchtest und deswegen und das ist auch eine Meinung die ich auch von Juristen schon geteilt bekommen habe mag auch welche geben die das anders sehen,
Baustelle nicht ganz alleine das eben das Gute Verfassen von von von Rechtstexten sehr viel auch mit mir zu tun hat.
Weil du ja im Prinzip genau das macht ja es gibt aber keinen Compiler das ist das Problem.
Hast du ganz offensichtlich keine formale Sprache Programmiersprache formale Sprache die,
formalen Regeln entspricht die du prüfen kannst ob die eingehalten werden und das hast du bei der Rechtsprechung so in dem Sinne nicht,
mag sein dass es da Dinge gibt die man ab prüfen kann aber du kannst zumindest.
Na ja also obwohl als ob Programmiersprachen jetzt immer so unzweideutig werden also formal ist eine juristische Sprache sehr wohl,
das sehr viel vorm drin da ist sehr viel Terminologie die klar definiert ist ist ja deswegen haben wir ja solche Probleme mit solchen Texten weil sie halt so bestimmte Worte benutzen wo wir überhaupt nicht wissen was die eigentlich bedeuten sollen die aber tatsächlich in der Verwendung.
Genau deshalb verwendet werden.
Weil im Kleid was sie bedeuten schon klar bezugnehmend und gehört dazu wohnen pieper pronobis gar keine guten Beispiele.
So und von daher ist der Mindset mit dem du daran gehst nicht so sehr viel anders als programmieren weil du eigentlich genauso.
Playa du musst quasi einer Maschine die eigentlich versucht sehr,
unidirektional durch etwas durch zum Marschieren sehr klare Anweisungen geben muss was in welchem Fall zu passieren hat,
auf der anderen Seite hast du natürlich erst deine dich immer wieder diesen Effekt und ich glaube bei bei Netzpolitik,
Logbuch Netzpolitik Gespräche glaube ich da auch manchmal davon das halt die Bundesregierung dann mal Gesetze auf dem Weg bringt wo Dinge drin stehen die nicht so genau sind,
damit man dann im Zweifelsfall vom Verfassungsgericht gesagt bekommt was geht und was nicht geht.
Hättest das überdrehen der der der Zuständigkeiten ja.
Ja aber halt auch den Text zu formulieren dass er halt dass die Auslegung Spielraum größerer,
besteht damit man dann am Ende irgendwie nicht zu doof da steht oder auch einer weiteren Informationen auch den Raum lasst lässt ne also das ist natürlich was was du beim Programmieren,
nicht tun würdest du schreibst ein Programm nicht so in der Hoffnung dass dir der Rechner hinterher schon sagt ob es läuft oder nicht.
Oder wir sind dann bei dem Thema was ist wenn eine Programmiersprache eine Sprache wäre dann wären wir das eine Programmiersprache auf jeden Fall British wäre mit diesem.
Ganz höflich sein kennt ihr das nicht diesen Vergleich mit wie würde man programmieren wenn,
eine Programmiersprache eine gesprochene Sprache es wurde dann ebenso Englisch halt so eine ganz höfliche dass du so nach dem Motto könntest du bitte mal.
Aber keine strikte direkte Ansage hast wie heißt denn das Winter Carl Winter Kall.
Die Programmiersprache intercarpale.
Nee ist gerade mal eine Seite wo wirklich da stand was wie würde ein ein Stück Kot geschrieben sein wenn es einer realen Sprache entsprechen würde.
Das hält so die Auflistung das bei Englisch.
Also was wahrscheinlich mit deutsch vergleichen würde in Deutschland halt so strict untereinander Fehler Befehle Befehle weil deutsch halt für viele so eine Befehls Geschichte ist und bei Englisch halt immer dieses.
Could you please an dieses Mal und so weiter also das sind halt diese vorangestellten Sachen hast ich weiß nicht genau wie das genau das ist ja eine Programmiersprache nicht richtig und das ist aber finde ich dann.
Wenn es diese Klarheit nicht gibt hast du aber trotzdem Vergleich dann diesen Gesetzestext erhält so ja so ein Schwamm ist und Auslegungssache ist.
Tim hat ja gerade argumentiert dass wenn du wirklich guten Text schreibst ist er eben kein Schwamm und bietet nicht soviel Auslegung Spielraum Wien wie vielen Fällen passiert das wirklich.
Da habe ich ja gegen gehalten mit dass es oftmals vielleicht auch gar nicht,
beabsichtigt ist dass es keinen Auslegung Spielraum gibt wie vielen Programm zu wie vielen Fällen tun Programm immer genau das Richtige also das ist Quatsch.
Also du bist als Programmierer nicht bemüht dem.
Dem Rechner möglichst viele Chancen der Interpretation offen zu lassen von dem was du da gerade was.
Viel Interpretationsraum einräumen von welchem Programm redet jedem.
Gucke mal nimmer irgendein Programm irgendeins was eine Eingabe braucht ja was I test bin ich mache wenn ich ein Programm Test ob es was taugt.
Weiß ich nicht ich lege mich erstmal 15 Minuten lang auf Keyboard und dann drücke ich getan David steigt schon mal die Hälfte aus.
Fasching unerwartete Dateneingabe wenn du wenn du programme mit Dingen fütterst mit denen sie nicht rechnen du hast Scheiße mediales du hast mein Argument nicht verstanden dann sag noch mal es ist nicht Inter.
Es ist nicht im Interesse des Programmierers und nichts Intention des Programmierers ein Programm so zu schreiben.
Das ist Interpretationsspielraum hat was es tut sondern jeder Programmierer wird versuchen ein Programm so zu schreiben das ist genau das tut was er will was er tut.
Ja und ich unterstelle mal das Gesetzestexte nicht unbedingt so geschrieben werden,
sie werden nicht unbedingt so geschrieben werden dass der Interpretationsspielraum 0 ist sondern bei manchen Texten ist es durchaus gewollt,
das Interpretationsspielraum bleibt damit hinterher in der tatsächlichen Rechtsprechung einer entschieden wird was gemeint wäre eine Anmerkung,
du redest von Gesetzestexten ich Ende von juristischen Texten Gesetzestexte sind eine Untermenge davon spezieller Fall.
Mein Beispiel sind Verträge ich finde Verträge haben die ganz andere.
Bedeutung ja bei iTunes Lizenzvertrag.
Was auch immer du leihst dir Geld keine Ahnung wann die und so weiter,
nö Versicherung und so weiter also das sind das sind Verträge die versuchen alle möglichen viel Läufer der Qualitäten alle Eventualitäten alle Fälle quasi,
abzufangen so dass das immer alleine ist dann ist okay und und und so sehe ich halt aufs offene und mit IE kleiner Hinweis ich was mit der Höflichkeit nur so anders weil du verstanden aber Hinterteil solltest du noch mal anschauen,
ich habe das da rein geschmissen weil er gibt es in der Tat dieses ist pls war halt auf PAP damals gemünzt,
ist PHP British und dann hast du halt so was drin wie would you mind Exodia du meinst also wenn es halt um netacad Geschichte geht.
Ja also weißt du dann halt nicht so ach so sozial PHP in von 90 $ Variablenname wird.
ich weiß also dieses wenn es darum geht was ist wenn wenn eine Programmiersprache nicht mehr.
Wenn man nicht mehr weiß was ist das macht dann wenn du hier halt wirklich so diese diese Höflichkeit erstmal anfängt mit Paps und otherwise und Schanz ja einfach so,
ja also da ist ja geil schon mal ein früher Einsatz gewesen 572 an esoterische Programmiersprache.
Abgekürzt Compiler language Fresno pronounceable an Kunden und.
Ich zitiere besonders bekannt ist in Türkei für den Befehl come from die 5c in der Carl eingeführt wurde.
Na so ein Scheiß Gotu gibt's hier in come from,
und man muss halt immer sehr höflich sein das Programm kompiliert nicht wenn der Programmierer nicht freundlich genug ist und zu selten please schreibt Fehler e07 9,
programa ist Anpfiff efficiently polite auf der anderen Seite wird die Compiler selbst verliert,
und verweigert seine Tätigkeit wenn dieses Wort zu oft vorkommt e009 programme is over Lipo light.
Aber ich finde ich finde schön hier class also normal class Republic,
und dann publicar privat b protected c wird zu,
Upper Class Empire State Ape privat beyond hair edit Theresia.
Protected.
Re d'Italia ist das Wort intercolor intercolor ist auch nur so ein Joke oder.
Would you mind 4.
Try catch with your mind Tattoo.
Ich habe da hat einfach jemand noch mal Spaß an der Sprache.
Ich dachte das würde es eigentlich dachte es gab wirklich mal eine Auflistung von mehreren Sachen also ich habe irgendwie gesehen.
Das ist mein Vergleich gehabt mit welche Programmiersprache welcher Staat ist aber ich fand jetzt nicht so lustig.
Ja also ich meine das ist halt so ich finde sowas halt niedlich wenn man wirklich andere zutreffende Begriffe darf.
Also statt class in the upper class.
Gut so viel zu der Sprache und der Logik.
Aber dennoch Feindes.
Zeig mein kleiner Hinweis hier Termin einen Termin hier.
Und zwar mir schon mal dieses luftdaten Info Projekt hier vorgestellt.
Das ist ja so ein wesentlichen in Stuttgart beheimatet.
Na ihr wisst schon da kann man sich irgendwie so Bausätze bestellen an seinen eigenen feinstaubsensor Kandidaten in die Cloud hängen und dann genau ich habe einen du hast ein.
Übersetze sein Leute ich auch mitgenommen ich habe keinen würde ich einen haben wollen könnte ich am 24. Februar in die seabase gehen hier in Berlin.
Da gibt's nämlich ein.
Donnerstag in Bottrop wo man sich das Ganze an die nicht ganz Tag 19 Uhr.
Tipps zum Vortrag und da kann man sich dann sozusagen das error und wie auch noch zusammen.
Basteln was ist nun Vortrag ich dachte es wäre so eine Bastelaktion keine Ahnung ich mal kannst auch bei Segor kaufen.
Also wenn ich ihn richtig verstanden habe das Kit echt.
Also auf dem Kongress und neuer bei Huawei funktioniert bei Sieger.
RAM kann man direkt hinfahren abholen hat man das hast du Feuer ich glaube 70 € hat er gesagt gemerkt aber nicht so sicher ohne online gucken also,
ja schon deutlich deutlich deutlich teurer als wenn man das so wie sich so besorgt mehr bei alice ist die haben es verdient wenn dann die also bei Aliexpress kannst du ja Teile glaube ich so für 20 Uhr 30 € zusammenklicken.
Aber muss er halt bei Aliexpress anstecken und was halt auch schmerzhaft ist nadja ist es von die Rechnungs Lage.
Satteldach die perfekte Überleitung zu deinem Rechnungs Thema.
Achso ja ich weiß nicht ob das so ein richtiges Thema ist ja ich hadere generell mit diesen ganzen Rechnungswesen.
Da draußen das irgendwie echt immer wieder erstaunlich wie viele Dienste im Netz doch.
Einfach scheitern dadran einfach mal so ihre Business Prozesse auch ausreichend transparent zu machen.
Dass er mich schockiert das ehrlich gesagt wenn du kaufst ist alles okay.
Dann hast du das in deiner Bestellliste dann hast du da direkt ein Link hier Rechnung und dann hast du ein PDF vor der Nase abspeichern alles gut was heißt von Amazon er.
Verkauft ja auch auf Amazon von anderen ja gleichzeitig ob als auch eine Shop Plattform.
Und ich würde meinen dass das Großteil von dem was man so also so umso esoterische ein Produkt umso höher die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass du.
Woanders kauft so ne und was schon echt auffällig ist ist das.
In zunehmendem Maße Produkte eilig aus China kommen und zwar direkt.
Und da kommt keiner alles Rechnung mit ihm erstmal siehst du überhaupt nicht am Preis.
Also im normalen Amazon siehst du überhaupt nicht wie viel Mehrwertsteuer dran ist.
So keine Rechnung dann schon mal was es für ein Endkunden jetzt auch erstmal kein Problem ist weil er muss ja in der Regel das sowie auch bezahlen aber wenn du das sowieso selbständig machst macht das ja schon mal ganz relevant sein.
Und vor allem hast du halt in der Regel kriegst du diese ganzen Sachen zugesendet und es ist keine Rechnung.
Drin Personal Lieferscheine das wenn überhaupt also wenn überhaupt dann Lieferschein drin.
Und wenns gut läuft hast aber auch eine Rechnung drin das hängt dann aber auch immer so von dem jeweiligen Shopbetreiber abzusagen guter Shopbetreiber der wirft einfach eine Rechnung mit rein und fertig ist die Laube dann muss man sich dann nicht mehr groß.
kümmern bzw du kannst ja dann übers Amazon Interface zumindest für deine Bestellung Rechnung anfordern.
Das also da wo normalerweise scheiße dass man die Antwort haben muss das schon mal Scheiße Smitty anfordern muss ich muss sich automatisch beim Melken genau.
Ich müsste normalerweise kommen nur ist es ja so dass wenn du.
Jetzt auf dem normalen Amazon.de unterwegs bist ein bisschen by default erstmal Privatkunde und als Privatkunde hast du gar keine an das überhaupt gar kein Anrecht auf eine Rechnung nicht wieso.
So sicher ja ich kaufe aus und habe kein Recht auf eine Rechnung ist aber neu.
Das mag so sein aber aber wenn ich ihn in jedes Geschäft wo ich dir egal was ich kaufe dir sage ich will eine Rechnung haben müssen wir meine Rechnung geben richtig.
Ich habe schon recht auch eine Rechnung nicht im.
Nein eigentlich nicht weil du das nicht hast also das du hast das Recht nur wenn du selber Gewerbetreibender bist dann.
Hast du ein Anrecht drauf aber für Endkunden verkauft muss in dem Sinne nicht eine Rechnung es in erforder also entspricht ein Anforderung einer Rechnung immer wenn Supermarkt gehst du auch keiner wissen.
Aber ich kann sagen sie eine haben oder nicht du hast kein Anrecht als Privatkunde auf eine Rechnung.
Außerdem im Supermarkt kriege ich doch mein ausdrücken dass alles drauf was man braucht,
das kann sein muss aber nur die Anforderung der Kassenführung erfordern also die Anforderung ist nicht die einer Rechnung seines die Anforderung eines Kassenbons der im Wesentlichen wichtig ist für den Betreiber der,
vor dem schummeln bewahrt werden soll.
Laufende Nummern und so weiter aber du hast nicht in dem Sinne dieses Geld nicht dieselben Formalien wie für eine Rechnung ist mir neu dass man kein Recht auf eine Rechnung hat.
So
wenn du als Gewerbetreibender bist also die Tobi machst dann hast du sehr wohl ein Anrecht auf eine Rechnung dann muss dir dein Geschäftspartner eine Rechnung ausstellen,
jetzt gibt es irgendwie seit einer Weile ich habe es gar nicht richtig mitbekommen seit wann kann man sich jetzt bei Amazon.
Ein Business Account klicken wenn man halt Business ist.
Na so dass man Geld macht das man isst was er gab es keinen großen überprüfungs Prozessor,
kannst du halt machen also wenn du quasi selbständig bist oder zumindest teilweise Geschäft Einkäufe also Sachen die du quasi dem Finanzamt vorlegen möchtest,
hast wohl deine Rechnung auch relevant ist dann kannst du halt Dir quasi so ein Business Account machen das noch mal zweiten login.
Da läuft er wieder in Prime auch noch irgendwie mit das ist so wie alles so ein bisschen verwoben aber dann doch irgendwie getrennt und sie werden groß damit der hier jetzt damit irgendein anpreisen du kannst aber im Wesentlichen dieselben Scheiß angeboten und du kriegst halt ein bisschen Nettopreise genannt.
Weil das ja für dich dann sozusagen relevant also siehst.
Dinge werden dann billiger für Dich weil sie halt Umsatzsteuer sind 9 % weglassen aber wohl drin ist deswegen deshalb Preis halt derselbe.
Ja mach das mit dem Rechnung kriegen auch nicht einfacher das war ja so ein bisschen meine Hoffnung damit haben sie irgendwie groß geworden ist aber Quatsch.
Und kann man machen kann man nicht machen also wer ein Vorteil hat es wenn du was bestellst kannst du so.
Bestellnummer oder was auch immer unten String kannst du halt ausdenken wenn du es bestellst kannst du quasi was sagen mit hier ich habe nix bestellt und dann wird auch sichergestellt dass bei der Abbuchung.
Dieser String auf.
Dumbledore Suchauftrag das wiederum ist sehr hilfreich damit man das wieder einordnen du wenn du da viel Amazon hin und her hast und dann irgendwann überhaupt nicht mehr weiß was jetzt hier in welchen Teilen abgebucht wurde wofür man sich 10,
Sachen irgendwie überschneiden dass du mich so ein kleiner Vorteil die man hat,
also richtig der Knaller ist es jetzt auch nicht aber es ist schon mal schonmal ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung.
Also ich hoffe dass.
Das hier irgendwie dass ich das noch mal einen Artikel kann noch ein paar Anmerkungen im Chat mal kurz hinterher lesen.
Also mit diesem.
Rechnung ja genau also wohl hoffen anderes eine Quittung aber nicht unbedingt auf eine Rechnung und weiß nicht was hier normalerweise genau du kriegst halt normalerweise rentenrechnung.
Und bei Sanifair miralia Regale verdingkind ja wurst sein ne.
Ja da läuft wohl alles noch nicht so wunderbar mal gucken wie sieht das so ein Gruft.
Ich finde auch mal wieder erstaunlich wenn ich mal wann erinner anderen Onlineshops kaufe dass die.
Dass du den auch immer wieder gelingt alles um nochmals komplizierter zu machen Bezahlvorgänge.
Kommt drauf an es gibt auch irgendwie so kleine Läden die so so ihre Shops haben da bestellte was,
dass du kriegst ordentlich Mails wanderst du dass es raus oder Bestellung ist da oder jetzt folgendes hat sich geändert,
dann kommt das dann ist auch eine Rechnung drin wo einfach alles irgendwie schlüssig ist und so ne und so na ja was hast du jetzt mit und was besonders gute Erfahrung.
Na fällt mir gerade nicht ein doch letztes Jahr zweifarbig glaube ich bei so einer fahrradbude was bestellt bei components oder irgendwie sowas.
Dazu muss ich das alles immer irgendwie super auch angerufen stimmt etwas nicht sagt mir ja gar kein Problem den mal zurück oder hier machen wir so und so also sehr kulant und und auch immer so eine Rechnung und wie mit dabei und.
Lief alles super auch einmal mit zurückschicken meins ist gar kein Problem einfach abgeben kommt an und dann muss man auch nicht hinterher telefonieren sondern dann wo das Geld wieder zurückgebucht und so also das ist alles,
alles cool ich glaube das müssen auch kleinere,
Onlineshops mittlerweile machen weil sie irgendwo eine Konkurrenz zu Amazon Amazon schon sein müssen und ich finde halt auch das irgendwie.
Amazon ist halt irgendwie das was alle nutzen aber ich weiß nicht.
Goodbye Auto Sachen bestelle ich halt wenn dann häufig bei Bergfreunde glaube ich heißen die und das ist auch immer alles ganz problemlos und fluffig also wirklich richtig gut.
Ja also ich würde glaube ich auch also viele nehme Amazon wahrscheinlich weil sie da schneller direkt einfach in dem größeren Markt irgendwie suchen können,
und und auch waldpreise mäßig irgendwie dadurch die Konkurrenz immer guten Preis kriegst aber ich glaube ich würde auch so ein bisschen,
extra bezahlen wenn ich sonst shoppette wo ich weiß es läuft irgendwie alles gut ab ich kriege meine Rechnung ist kommt irgendwie ordentlich und wenn ich ein Problem habe kann ich da auch mal anrufen und dann sind da auch welche oder irgendwie so bei Amazon habe ich schon immer das Gefühl es ist ganz schön so rum der Akatsuki einfach keinen mehr anrufen,
was ich bin was so Auto Sachen es wäre in Berlin unterwegs ist,
Liebe ist ja nach wie vor das cam4 weil da weiß ich auch heute direkt Hündin genau da kannst halt glaube ich sogar auch sagen hier bestell mir das mal die bekommen also wann bekommt das dann halt zugeschickt und wenn du da Kunde wirst.
Kannst du da halt auch z.b. was ja häufig ein Problem ist wenn etwas kaputt geht brauchst du eigentlich dein Kassenzettel.
Wenn du bei cam4 irgendwie deine Daten hinterlegt ja haben wir halt wieder deine Daten aber du brauchst halt nicht mehr deinen beschissenen Kassenzettel und muss damit dahin Rennen.
Sag mir ehrlich wie häufig hier passiert ist also gut im hat so einen Einzugsscanner über den ich sehr neidisch bin jetzt mittlerweile und wenn du das aber nicht hast du deine Sachen erledigen haben die geteilte bin ich reich Dinger kosten echt ganz schön viel.
Du darfst auch bei mir scannen das ist nett mach dir noch auf deine Wunschliste.
500 € Wunschliste oder noch mehr egal jedenfalls die haben halt echt einen guten Service und bei den weiß man irgendwie.
Die Leute die da arbeiten ist das von denen die man sowas erzählt haben die wir halt auch behandelt und so weiter also ich hätte noch,
echt gerne einfach in diesem Laden rein gehe oder halt auch online bestellen kann weil die halt auch im Onlineshop das ist schon.
Und alles was Auto Zeug ist habe ich mittlerweile nur noch über cam4 und in Ausnahmefällen über Bergfreunde.
Heinrich weiss nicht Amazon kaufen.
Solltest du jetzt erstmal bei Google suchen wo ist das gibt weil du könntest ja auch das gleich bei Amazon eingeben und dann hast du es auch gleich und und dann kannst du auch die gleich klicken und das geht halt Stück schneller und wir sind alle natürlich auch ein bisschen mal von unserer Faulheit getrieben,
und ja.
Das ist ja auch vollkommen in Ordnung von seiner voller getrieben zu sein ich meine wir.
Also hör auf mir Sachen die man sonntags zur Faulheit also wenn ich mir.
Wenn ich wenn ich jetzt so fünf Dinge die ich so für meinen Haushalt und die Kinder brauche so und das ist alles so ab so das Zeug mit immer hier besonderes Stück Kleidung und.
Wasser so auch auch so aller Welt Sachen.
Wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwie in die City fahre jetzt zum Alexanderplatz und mich dann und wie durch 5 Läden durch Wille und dann festzustellen dass irgendwie zwei von den Läden genau drive.
Varianten davon haben wir keine gefällt und dann anderer Laden noch mal das eine das andere und ich glaube stundenlang darum durch Weihnachtsmärkte und Geschrei Wetter das dauert.
Ja da muss man um ihn Nahverkehr benutzen und vielleicht auch noch finanzieren welchem Alter was kommt alles noch mit rein also allein der Suchvorgang,
dauert Stunden und kostet Geld offen und ich kann überhaupt gar nicht so gut vergleichen also sieht man die ganze online kam hat ja einfach auch,
elementare Vorteil aber es gibt ja auch andere online Sachen ja ja auch etwas für einen ne und was du Faulheit nennst nenn ich irgendwie warum soll ich,
Zeit in so etwas stecken wenn es mir nichts bringt,
Zeit dann manchmal anderen Stellen kostet wenn man nämlich mal ein Problem hat und bei Amazon dann Schwierigkeiten hat dem hinterherzurennen was bei anderen lebenden bisschen schneller von sind weil man da anrufen kann gleich einen dran hat und nicht drei Stunden zum Robotik Koldingen tralala irgendwo drin ein Test bei der Vergleich mit sofistik ist doch ne,
anrufen goodnight wegen ne so jetzt wie viele universalen vitella gibt's denn eigentlich online.
Mir fällt ehrlich gesagt setzt außer Amazon gar keiner ein Muster in dir noch nicht universalen sein na ja,
also ja gut aber es in guten Lagen aber wenn du sie Hamburg gesagt aber wenn ich jetzt fünf Produktkategorien brauch ja weiß wie ich unterwäschestück Elektronik gut mit Lebensmittel wenn ich es nicht anfangen,
dann klick das Video Amazon zusammen kriegt vier Pakete weil mir vier verschiedene Versender Dichter im Dach,
so wie unter einem Dach habe, alle einzeln Geselle aber alles über count Prozess wegen gesamten Checkout Prozess mit irgendwie alle meine Konten alle man bei der Security Hang.
Wir haben in der Firma derzeit das Problem DHL wurde von irgendsoeine Bombenbastler erpresst und Security bei uns in der Firma ist jetzt der Meinung alle Fische aussehen den Pakete extra prüfen zu müssen.
Okay irgendwie und das ist super nervig und dann schreiben Sie einen keine Mail und dann fragt man sich was das Paket geblieben und.
Soll sich bei Amazon z.b. nicht mag ist dass sie ihr.
Webinterface halt an an Ihre Handelspartner durchreichen was ja okay gesagt dass der das nicht nur Amazon selbst verkauft sondern auch andere Handelspartner aber das Telefon web interface das alles so gleich aussieht dass ich einmal was bestellt habe.
Kopfhörer vor zwei Jahren diese Sennheiser die ich mir geholt habe und dann waren die defekt und ich will die einschicken und merke okay ich brauch zum einschicken eine Rechnung,
habe ich keine habt habe ich den Typen angeschrieben dass ich gerne eine Rechnung hätte Weißwein nicht selber Amazon sondern unsere Typ und da meinte der nee das wäre ein Privatverkauf und da gibt's keine Rechnung aber er schickt mir jetzt mal irgendwas er ist ja nicht so und dann kam irgendso ein Wisch,
keine Mehrwertsteuer ausgewiesen kein gar nix und ja das war halt irgendwie mehr oder weniger ich weiß nicht irgendwie Fantasieprodukte was ich dann bei sehr heller,
Sennheiser eingereicht ab und Diana gesagt nervt das ist keine Rechnung und dann musste ich mit Sennheiser rum handeln,
dass ich den erklären konnte ja das Produkt ist ja noch gar nicht so alt ich habe auf jeden Fall Garantie und dann haben sie es halt auf Kulanz gemacht aber da hatte ich halt Glück dass ich hätte auch Pech haben können hätte das nicht repariert,
der der gebraucht Typ,
hätte gesagt neuer gibt mir aber keine Rechnung weil wie ich als höre man hat anscheinend gar kein Recht auf ein und dann würdest Du irgendwie da stehen also finde ich schon bisschen komisch das Amazon sind Typen der.
Sachen als gebraucht verkauft dass ich mein das Gerät verwirklichen neu und zu und richtig geklebtes konnte man schon sehen dass es wirklich ein neues Produkt war aber sie geben ihm das gleich Interface und ich kann als Kunde ohne wahrscheinlich irgendwo im Fliegendreck irgendwie in dem kleinste Druck,
auf der Webseite zu suchen nicht erkennen dass es ja Zeit irgendwie ein Gebrauchtartikel gewesen ist also zu uns als ausgewiesen als.
Scheiße dass man das da nicht erkennen kann dass er sich der Unterschied nicht so deutlich ist genauso wie zwischen Amazon selbst und.
Und wieder wenn Sie das über jemand anderen verschicken dann muss man auch jetzt schon immer mehr deutlicher gucken dass das wird weil es immer häufiger stattfindet und ich habe halt eben manchmal nicht Bock wenn ich drei Sachen bestelle.
Dass das als drei Pakete ankommt bei mir zu Hause an ich hätte gerne drei Sachen bestelle dass das vielleicht von dem gleichen Händler ist oder eben von Amazon selbst in das alle drei Sachen in einem Paket kommen.
Ich bin auch diese Seite wird immer furchtbare also noch mal aufgefallen weil,
andere Shops können das definitiv mit den Suchfilter Sachen wesentlich besser und zu versuchen immer aggressiver dieses Prime drücken also dieses nein ich will nicht,
nervt mich jedesmal und macht mich auch wenn sonst der ganze Rest stimmt so ein bisschen zu einem unzufriedenen.
Cunda revoltiert innerlich was in mit versucht meine Rechnung für deinen freien Betrag zu bekommen ich habe keinen Plan würde ich nie haben wollen weil das ist eine Odyssee finde ich immer weniger zu bestellen.
Endlos nervt.
Das merke ich halt immer mehr so dass ich auch ewig keine Wunschliste deswegen haben wollte weil ich von Amazon halt einfach nicht so nicht so doll.
Ja aber was willst du denn deutsch.
Je nachdem was ich kaufe also Stoff Stoff möchte würde ich nie online Kauf also stimmt nicht ich kaufe wenn er extremtextil weil ich viele von den Stoffmustern schon zu Hause habe die mich interessieren also Merino Stoffe z.b.
Dann habe ich die gesamte Bandbreite als als Muster zu Hause dass ich weiß was ich kaufe.
Extremtextil es ist eine Berliner Dresdner Firma die sehr viel Outdoor Stoffe und Zubehör verkaufen.
Total super und die haben auch also ich habe den häufiger schon bestellt und weiß nicht dass es immer alles problemlos und.
Noch nie ein Problem wenn sie jetzt auch noch ne.
Wunschzettel und so weiter haben sie halt irgendwie auch alles aber ich weiß nicht die sind super die Stoffe hören also extrem gute Qualität also dass das ist halt ja einzige Shop wo ich noch wirklich online kaufe und ansonsten gehe ich in der Tat.
Wenn ich shoppen gehe heißt dass ich dir entweder Technik kaufen oder Stoffe also ich hätte auch überhaupt nichts gegen weitere gut diversifizierte ordentlich geführte Onlineshops die einfach so eine gewisse.
Spezialisierung haben und die vor allem auch besser suchen können die einfach besser sortiert sind also es ist teilweise ist es ja auch sowieso ein wenig so glücklich versucht,
von Problem zu lösen und zwar möchte ich gerne meinen Wohnwagen Wassertank betanken.
Wasser rein Verlängerungsschlauch Gießkanne.
Das kannst du einfach dann wird man erstmal Gießkanne Giesskanne hat das Problem.
Muss man diese Gießkanne irgendwo befüllen transportieren und hoffen dass er nicht schon mal irgendwelche Mittelchen für Pflanzen drin waren.
Ist deine Gießkanne hör auf weißt du was wenn du die frisch gekauft hast diese Problematik.
Wenn es kein Problem ist wirklich Wasser von A nach B,
kriegen ja wenn du besonders luxuriös gepackt bist dann halt irgendwo in der Nähe ein Wasseranschluss und kannst mit dem Schlauch direkt vom Hahn rein so ist aber nicht die Regel die Regel ist Wasser ist irgendwo kann,
2 Minuten mit dem Fahrrad wechseln so Gießkanne kriegt man so halbwegs transportiert aber läuft irgendwie über und hat auch um mir nicht zu die richtige für Kapazität und jetzt auch nicht einmal.
Genau reicht nicht einmal Mutter hat mehrere Male unterwegs sein irgendwie dachte ich mir so muss ja auch besser gehen wie ich da so oft auf faltkanister umgestiegen weil nimmt wenig Platz weg,
passt eine Menge rein kriegt man auch nicht hinten aufs Fahrrad drauf kann auch ordentlich transportieren machst du zu na ja dann stehst du so ein bisschen Kanister davor und hast du so ein vertikal angebracht das Loch ja wie kriege ich jetzt das Wasser da rein so also so gibt es vom Kanister in die Gießkanne und dann.
Ja dann,
musst du wieder wenn du willst ja auch nicht so viel Zeug mitnehmen und wird auch nicht tausend Mal um gießen wo du immer wieder Wasserverluste hast und so weiter mit unterschiedlichen Kapazitäten dass mir so okay alles klar wäre ja besser wenn ich da jetzt auf jeden Schlauch habe dann um die alles mögliche probiert und dann einfach irgendwann von dieser Problematik.
Verdammte Axt es kann doch nicht sein dass es nicht einen Wasserkanister Anschluss gibt.
Wo man einfach ein Gardena Schlauch rein machen kann weil es gab nämlich auch für den Wohnwagen Wasser für den Schraubdeckel.
Hatte die auch einen mit dem Gardena Anschluss wurde dann einfach so Gardena Standard Clip Clip machst und dann kannst du einfach deinen Kanister hochhalten und dann läuft die Scheiße labern.
So ich versuch mal in Deutschland online irgendwie herauszufinden Summer Gardena also diese Lösung.
Das war echt soll ich bin verzweifelt da dran es noch mal normal also du brauchst einen Wasserkanister mit einem Gardena Anschluss entdecken abnehmbaren Deckel hat.
Ja
Der Macht sind komplett schließt Deckel Masse ab und macht dafür einen Deckel dann der diesen Gardena schnupsi hat wurde so einen Schlauch mit dem Gardena ins lass mich raten den will keiner selber bauen.
Ich wollte dich nicht also wollte ich nicht unbedingt selber bauen aber ich war schon verzweifeln war schon hat schon so einiges ausgedacht.
Sohn auf der anderen Seite wieder Gardena Anschluss und dann geht das halt direkt in den Wohnwagen reicht einfach mal so an der Tankstelle ran fahren und sich das mal wie voll füllen oder so.
Wie mache ich einen anderen Männern Wagen Fahrer dass du stehst auf dem auf dem Campingplatz soll ich jedesmal um Wasser zu holen Fessel nicht zur Tankstelle.
30 km verstehe es nicht kurz bevor der Urlaub fährst und dann musste währenddessen auf immer wieder schnell gehen schlechtes Wetter regnet keine Ahnung willst du irgendwie ist matschig.
Ja
Ist ja jetzt auch alles scheißegal das eigentliche Ding ist du willst halt irgendwie ein Spezialshop dafür haben der dir einfach mal ordentlich Auskunft gibt also bin ich in baumärkte reingetan weil ich das Meerwasser kann es sein müssen sich auskennen.
Da muss es doch einen Standard geben die haben nicht kümmern nicht wissen wir nicht keine Ahnung das Problem habe ich auch immer.
Bis man nicht mehr an die alle halt unsere China Ware schon in ihrem Leben habe ich noch nicht auflösen mit mit mit mit irgend so ein summ summ summ Decke.
Ja der natürlich irgendwie an nichts anderem Pass als genau an diesen Ding also es ist es wirklich erstaunlich.
Und ich brauchte dann einige Zeit.
Bis ich dann tatsächlich herausgefunden habe dass es sehr wohl einen Standard gibt für Wasserkanister also wohl nicht im Kopf dass es in Deutschland kein Standard gibt für ein Schraubverschluss.
So bis auf diese China Ware macht die Standard kaputt nördliches Rohr oder was DIN 61,
din 61 ist Rudi ist der Nummer nach zu urteilen schon sehr alt,
ja also den einseitig weiß nicht ob das so eine Abkürzung ist aber so wird es gemeinhin geführt wenn du nach DIN 61 Deckel suchst dann findest du sozusagen genau diese Größe dann kannst du ja dann Wasserkanister so besorgen dann hast du da halt auch entsprechende,
der Profi verwendet doch GK achso gkgk ja keine Ahnung dass ich würde wieder alles fetten.
Sind auch probiert jeder mal Wasser in den Wassertank reinkommen,
also ich finde das nicht verladen wenn man eine ordentliche Lösung haben wollte mit meinem,
Fahrrad daran fahren das ist in unser Kanister dich auch schwer das in 20 Liter Wasser drin ist das ist alles schwer das hat nur 20 kg genau dass das kannst du nicht zehn Minuten irgendwie halten dann willst du das irgendwie von da darüber und relativ wenig Zeug.
Die Lösung habe ich jetzt auf jeden Fall so aber hat Amazon mir da geholfen nicht sehr also ich musste durch durch durch diffuses gegoogelt,
habe ich dann irgendwann durch die Kombination von 1000 Produkten und noch mal suchen und noch mal suchen weil ich dann bin ich irgendwann auf dieses DIN 160 gekommen,
das hat einfach zu lange gedauert also ich meld dich ganz gerne einladen ja gut aber ich fürchte das Fürchten,
da wir alle anderen Läden auch nicht weiterhelfen konnten Märkte haben keine Ahnung gehabt alle.
Egal ob Obi Hellweg pieper Florian Silbereisen,
na die habe ich an meinem gärfass dran dasitzen und entlüftungsstopfen Sohn Sohn Sohn Sohn Sohn so ein Ding und dann hast du den Lüftungsschlitzen Rams oder einmal so rein,
der machte Bozita so ein Loch rein und dann hast du so einen kleinen Haaren mit dem dann quasi die Entlüftung an und ausmachen kannst aber das Wasser da rauskommt weil sonst bleibt irgendwie drin.
Dieser Anschluss erinnert mich an meine beste Investition letztes Jahr vom Wandern weil was will man halt auch haben ein Wasserkanister wie du krass sagtest falls du mal das Problem hast dass dein.
Deine deine Wasserquelle vielleicht nicht so direkt trinkbar ist oder nicht so unklar ist ob deine nächste Wasserstelle die du erreichst.
Trinkwasser es oder irgendetwas in die Richtung nicht Salzwasser und so weiter und habe mir von.
Ortlieb ein ein Wassersack gekauft den man auch als Dusche benutzen kann,
ja Ortlieb hat sieben Sachen und träumchen besten Agenten klorollenhalter von Ortlieb wirklich großartig.
Wassersack den kannst du halt der ist sehr multifunktional,
und du kannst ihn halt so als Wassersack nutzen um dein Trinkwasser von A nach B zu transportieren das habe ich halt gemacht weil in einer Wasser in einer Beschreibung einer Wanderkarten Beschreibung stand explizit drin dass die Wasserquelle ungeniessbar ist.
Und bin dann halt mit so einem 10 Liter Sack durch die Gegend gerannt aber der hat sich sehr gelohnt.
Cindy von Ortlieb aber wenn man den Begriff die in 61 erstmal hat findet man auch bei bei Amazon relativ viel ne bei DIN 61 selber wiederum ein Standard für Sechskantschrauben ist und ich verstehe überhaupt nicht was sie mit diesem DIN 61 meinen also manchmal ist das auch so historische geprägte Begriffe die dann wiederum mit der Realität nichts zu tun haben.
Genau da ist der,
mit der klorollenhalter von Ortlieb der ist Wasserfarbe dadrüber Regenschirm oder Wilo Rollenhalter von Ortlieb,
vor allen Dingen der ist halt auch wasserdicht also du hast das Klopapier bleibt halt trocken und gleichzeitig kannst du es aber so wie es in dem Sack ist halt auch direkt verwenden.
Der Profi Kemper.
Jana ich habe ihn selber nicht weil ich das dann auch eher fragen sich verrannt aber heiß da drauf ich weiß,
Ortlieb klorollenhalter.
Erstelle der klorollenhalter der hat nicht klorollenhalter oder was weiß ich wieder Eistorte Tag ist das schon das Teil was du brauchst du das hast du selber gepostet und das hast du schon gefunden oder wie oder hast es jetzt gerade erst gefunden 61f Gardena auch nicht verkehrt.
Genau also DIN 61 ist selber.
Eigentlich die richtige Bezeichnung vermute mal dass das wieder irgend Abkürzung von einer längeren DIN-Norm ist und bleiben nicht mehr alle sagen halt einfach nur das.
Ja blöd ist DIN 61 dass das Feingewinde DIN 61 Feingewinde das ist wahrscheinlich Gewindesteigung.
Das Ortlieb t-pack ist immer dann wenn man es braucht also pack die pack heißt das ja.
Immer dann wenn man es braucht es ist nicht da oder nicht mehr brauchbar,
Toilettenpapier schöner damit das jetzt ein Ende hat gibt es den wasserdichten Outdoor Toilettenpapierhalter von Ortlieb oder wird das Papier in den reißfesten Tierpark transportiert.
Am Ziel angelangt hängt die Rolle auch schon in der geöffneten Tasche und ist vor Regen geschützt,
das ist würdig definiere Luxuswelt ja also das Teil ist aber auch geil weil du kannst das Ding wirklich so klick klack irgendwohin hängt dann machst du unten klick klack schraub hinauf und kannst direkt das Papier raus ziehen das ist einfach,
Otitis wirklich.
Da in einer ja wirklich eine geile Marke und was sie nämlich auch haben ist eine faltwanne,
jetzt auch immer großer Beliebtheit auch richtig geil.
Abspül faltwanne,
dann macht spielen Spaß bis ungefähr so groß wie so eine normale kitchen sink ne nicht ganz so tief nicht ganz so tief und dann kannst du auch Falten machst du warmes Wasser rein kannst abspülen.
Das ist irgendwie genauso wie es sein muss.
Jeden zip-lock Beutel fürs Klopapier das nutze ich derzeit noch das ist auch über den Ortlieb t-pack z.b. die gibt's nicht über Amazon nee das ist mir auch aufgefallen Wassersack habe ich auch nicht gefunden also ich habe diesen Wasserbeutel gepostet ja.
Den habe ich mir ich weiß gar nicht in wie viel Liter letztes Jahr geholt.
So und dann gibt's nicht nur die Frage wo kauft man den dann meine erste Wahl ist oder so wenn ich Auto Sachen gehe wenn ich Ortlieb rauche wacklig zu cam4.
Ja aber gibt es da online wahrscheinlich sogar also könntest sie natürlich jetzt bei Ortlieb direkt kaufen ja.
Geht das ja da steht da ist ein in den Warenkorb Bayern stimmt.
Ich betrüge meinen dass sie das dem cam4 das im Online-Shop drin haben finde ich gerade.
Finde das viel wenn ich nach Tierpark suche aber nicht t-pack.
Das nämlich dann auch schon wieder so ein Problem dass die anderen Onlineshops meistens einfach extrem schlechte Suchfunktion haben ja also ich habe jetzt hier irgendwie für Ortlieb t-pack.
39 Fundstellen und nichts davon heißt hip Pack.
Sonnenpark weil da steht ja Pack drin und Bindestrich es dann irgendwie nicht wichtig genug Anführungsstriche helfen auch nichts,
das sind so die Momente wo ich immer so leicht verzweifelt Schlüssel auch dass er wenig geil Bindestrich und interpretiert das 1 - so dass es nicht mit dabei sein darf und so ja das ist die falsche genau,
nee was was ich am schlimmsten finde bei Amazon ist dass du.
Dass du diese binäre such Attribute hast obwohl du eigentlich trinere bräuchtest ne also mein klassisches Beispiel ist irgendwann habe ich mal gedacht vielleicht schaffe ich mir doch meinen Fernseher an,
ich will aber kein Smart TV.
Und es gibt nur den Button Haken Smart TV es gibt aber nicht den Haken kein aber kein Smart TV.
Ja ja Baker.
Genau also da wiederum gibt's ja dann das interessanterweise diese Plattform diese ganzen Preis empfehlungsplattform teilweise sinnvoller also Geizhals z.b.
Vibrieren mit solchen such features insbesondere im Fernsehbereich.
Sind dann allerdings auch nicht unbedingt immer richtig und auch nicht unbedingt immer topaktuell also das Hauptproblem ist dann das eben die Daten auch für dich nicht mit der allerletzten Konsequenz eingepflegt werden,
so und dann hilft dir natürlich auch nichts wenn du dann genau die Auswahl die du meinst Vorhaben an der Stätte der nicht hast weil dann einfach genau das Produkt wahrscheinlich auf dich zutrifft ja.
Kann ich erst gelistet wird oder umgekehrt dir Sachen gelistet werden wo es eigentlich gar nicht zutreffend Fehler können natürlich immer passieren aber da ist das User-Interface schon mal ganz interessant mehr weißt du diese ganze Filigranität mit ich will das nicht oder nur im Rennsport,
so alles bräuchte man das sowieso eine Programmiersprache die Post immer so eine Amazon Curry language oder sind online shopping hilft die oql online shopping osql online shopping language,
ja da, vielleicht auch noch.
Hin gibt kein Tewaag bei cam4 wahrscheinlich wird nicht so nachgefragt.
Die Leute sind wahrscheinlich einfach mitnehmen,
Griffins Laub immer noch besser bedient,
Creme Argument kann ich nicht vergeben.
Ja da ist was dran.
Na ja also Online-Shopping wünschenswert aber verbesserungsfähig verbesserungsfähig da geht auf jeden Fall noch so einiges auf jeden Fall.
Ich hoffe ja das Amazon ist ja.
Weit vorne Weise hat sich das geleistet haben da viel Geld reinzustecken Ihr System aber da das durch durch Open-Source-Projekte und und Frameworks eigentlich jede kleine Bude sich auch so ein bisschen leisten kann dieses diese Software anstatt zu bringen,
das dauert ja noch ein bisschen mehr von kommt dass ich das noch so ein bisschen bisschen mehr verbreitet dass man auch bei kleinen Booten was Ohren kann ja das hoffe ich auch,
dass das mit den Jobs noch besser wird und das irgendwie da gemacht Dienstleister gibt die nicht Amazon sind weil sonst ist meine ansonsten ist ja auch wirklich schon absehbar,
dass wir wirklich so eine Shopping Singularität ist genau was man arbeiten will also alles zentralisiert sich immer automatisch aus Gründen genau und da will man auch ein bisschen von weg aber ich würde dann mal nächste Termin.
Na und aber noch so einen Aspekt oder auch mal.
Gleichsam also Amazon hat ja auch deshalb so viel Erfolg weil so viele Leute dafür werben.
Bitte Casa z.b. wir.
Hirte ich versuche das nicht so raushängen zu lassen so ja aber wir nicht na ja ich.
Wirst mich nicht nicht dabei beobachten wie ich die ganze Zeit alle Leute dazu aufrufe irgendwie,
über Amazon Dinge zu kaufen die meinte Philipp Fink verwenden oder so sein dass das findet zwar statt aber ich versuche das jetzt auch nicht so die ganze Zeit raus hängen zu lassen ich mache da jetzt nicht eine Kolumne draus,
davon profitiere ich natürlich so aber ich finde es halt auch gleichzeitig scheiße weil ich ja eigentlich werbefrei.
Sein will und von daher ist das eben so ein Balanceakt brauche ich aber eigentlich in auswil ist.
Diese dieser Incentive existiert.
Nerf und das was man bei Amazon tatsächlich darüber verdienen kann ist nicht unerheblich also wenn du da also du kriegst ja auch mehr Prozente umso mehr darüber verkauft wird.
Salzgitter so um 3 4 5 Stufen die du irgendwie nehmen kannst und je nachdem was gekauft wurde und wie teuer das ist,
kann das irgendwie rechtliche Summen an mal was was ich für eine Waschmaschine beim Tisch geht oder so ein Blender auch mal um die 10 € hängen.
Was jetzt für keine Arbeit.
Irgendwie okay ist so nah einerseits weiß man natürlich gut dass alles Gelder die gehen an und wie von diesem Preis auch wieder ab ne lustigerweise wird das ja alles unter Werbungskosten geführt und ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch.
Bei den niedrigen Maßen die manche Produkte haben wonach müssen sich dann manchmal sowieso schon so.
Wer wer verdient jetzt hier eigentlich nichts daran und wer verdient ihr überhaupt noch irgendwas daran wahrscheinlich ganze Menge vor allem erstmal nichts.
Oh wie hast du das denn dieser Incentive quasi über Amazon was zu empfehlen ist halt einfach da.
So aber es gibt halt auch gar keine Alternativen.
Also andere Shops bieten halt teilweise auch so Affiliate-Programme an.
Das habe ich dann um die auch schon ein paar mal versucht mich da irgendwie durch zu wüten die ändern am laufenden Meter ihre technischen Anforderungen haben irgendwelche.
Tritt Vermittler Affiliate Plattform die irgendwie unbenutzbare Webseiten haben die irgendwie auch eine extrem schlechte Beleg Lager haben und würdest alles irgendwie total tranig und schwierig ist und auch nur so für so power.
Empfehler gedacht ist die würde ich nichts anderes machen als die ganze Zeit sich irgendwie eine verliert Programm nach dem anderen zu klicken gerade eben was so dujour gerade so die besten Prozente hat und dann.
Na diese ganzen Scammer Webseiten die sich halt überall anfangen aber nur eigentlich nur so ein okay was weiß ich ich habe hier irgend in der Öffentlichkeit,
wir empfehlen so Sachen aber eben nicht weil Leute uns dafür bezahlen dass wir dir empfehlen soll man will immer einfach so einfallen oder irgendwie Erfahrung mit haben und so weiter warum nicht auch links bereitstellen wo man die kaufen kann und davon profitieren,
Zooplus daneben fuzzy zwangsläufig eigentlich nur Amazon nehmen zu können weil nur dazu finden oder nur da,
gibt's überhaupt diese Möglichkeit irgendwie so eine Philipp Link zu machen das zwingt er natürlich auch so ein bisschen fitter immer total schade dass die anderen Shops sich da sozusagen so so raushalten kann ich auch sagen,
die wollen halt nicht auch noch den letzten Rest ihrer Marge auch nur so daher gesagt Podcaster verlieren.
Ja okay gut aber die Realität ist halt auch irgendwie eine andere und natürlich sind links die mandovi im Web platziert und,
bis dahin auf hat macht und so weiter auch Arbeit und von daher ist es in gewisser Hinsicht auch gerechtfertigt auf Einsatz wie lautet die da irgendwie,
in ungerechtfertigten Größenordnung Geld verdienen naja das kommt dafür war noch ein bisschen dazu und ich beklage das eigentlich so ein bisschen dass es eben nichts anderes gibt was ansatzweise so eine Alternative ist und das prangere ich an.
Jobdag noch online shopping.
Oma beim Mac reden ja bitte ja.
Was zu reden ich weiß nicht also ich habe nur so ein paar Apps im Moment der ersten an.
Der ersten der VLC ist irgendwie in der neuen Version rausgekommen.
Die mich noch nicht so hundertprozentig überzeugt nee mich auch nicht ich muss auch sagen ich habe VLC schon.
Weiß noch wie das hier einer Sendung hatten oder seit wann ist schon noch damals als das Ding auch VideoLAN player hieß also ganz am Anfang zu maculan Client genau Video Clan,
VideoLAN Platten,
darf ich den schon benutzt weil es der erste Player war die man überhaupt auf dem Mac auch nicht benutzen konnte ne und dann kam aber später noch mplayer extended und dann habe ich den genommen bei der bisschen schlanker und und.
Leichtfüßiger war wenn was nicht geklappt hat so wie mit Audios habt hält sich auch immer dann vc100 mit dem tam meistens ging so als Notlösung immer VLC noch.
Da haben und in letzter Zeit benutze ich ja diesen MPV der noch schlanker ist irgendwie vom Gefühl her noch ja dadurch irgendwie Flotte oder.
Ja weniger Latenz ich weiß nicht wie man das sagen soll er kann irgendwie ganz wenig aber es ist einfach funktioniert einfach immer super aber auch so Notlösung immer voll cmtv,
mpva den benutze ich jetzt gerne weil ich mag es auch mit den Cursortasten schnell vorspulen und so und man brauche eigentlich sonst nichts weiter und und der hat auch nichts weiter wenn der Film vorbei ist dann geht das Ding auch automatisch aus also es ist wirklich der ist ziemlich ziemlich gut,
Sohn da kam letztens habe ich sogar noch nicht mal als Update angeboten der VLC der neue 308,
oder ich weiß nicht was inzwischen schon wird war es noch nicht der Fall aber ich habe gelesen dass es den 30 ergibt und zwar mit Hardwarebeschleunigung,
und da ich ja durch meinen Fernseher auf 4k content viel gucke und auch hier hatte er 10 Bit und so und und hevc also wirklich die schweren Brocken.
Habe ich erst gestern wieder ab dann finde 60 Gigabyte groß war und da brauchst natürlich Hardwarebeschleunigung und.
Das hat dieser VLC 3.0 und ich habe das mal gemessen an so normalen HD video also 19 Uhr 20 Uhr da hat er vorher.
Ihr MPV z.b. 60% CPU gebraucht dann was genau abzuspielen also HD video 19 20 Mai.
8 900 oder so normales halt die Kinoformat also schon schmaler als HD sondern halt dann nicht 1200 in der Höhe sondern 8 900 also schwarze Balken sozusagen schon weg und das.
MVZ das dann nur noch so 12% gebraucht also so ca ein Viertel oder ein 55 von dem was was die Player vorher gebraucht haben darf ich das erhalte Hardware.
Support Renato das hört man sagen ja was interessiert mich das irgendwie ist ja nicht so schlimm aber so viele Leute wie halt mit dem Zug fahren und da wir noch einen Film gucken und gerade die neuen MacBook Pros die ja eigentlich ne gute Batterie Zeit haben und wenig verbrauchen,
muss aber schon noch sein dass es eine kleine Batterie ist und dass sie so wenig verbrauchen wenn nichts los ist aber in die CPU erstmal was tun muss dann geht das Ding doch schon relativ schnell in die Knie.
Und gerade da lohnt sich dann so ein vLC der einfach mal nichts verbraucht,
kann man wahrscheinlich nicht so ein Zeit umrechnen dass das nur noch ein Fünftel der CDU ist weil ich denke mal die GPU wird jetzt minimal mehr verbrauchen weil es ja halt hat der Beschleunigung die Hardware muss es ja machen aber ich denke mal dass es trotzdem,
deutlich weniger Strom insgesamt dann am Ende verbraucht und das ist deswegen so also klare Empfehlung jemand der viel Videos guckt und viel Batterie.
Sparen will sollte sich auf jeden Fall den neuen VLC 3.0 runterladen.
Wasser aber nicht so gut hat es wenn man seinen seinen kontern den man guckt.
Wenn man die nicht lokal auf der Platte sondern irgendwie sich run mounted von seinem filestorage irgendwie da hat VLC auf die mit dem Buffer also wenn man da so springen will schnell mal 10 Sekunden dann steht das Bild gleich für.
Ja dann steht auch für zehn Sekunden war da irgendwie das nicht schnell genug irgendwie nachgeladen kriegt also das ist noch nicht so schick das können die anderen Player meiner Meinung nach so ein bisschen besser kann aber auch an den fetten Content liegen den ich da getestet habe dass das dann nicht mehr so einfach geht aber,
wer war der neu vorziehen hat mir nicht ganz so gefallen beim hin und her springen.
Aber was jetzt geändert haben früher konnte man immer nur mit ich muss auf die Tastatur gucken konnte man nur mit optischen und command Cursor zur Seite springen,
das haben sie geändert inzwischen kann man normal mit den Cursortasten springen ohne extra Taste drücken zu müssen das war früher mal nicht belegt oder Lautstärke oder irgendwie so das geht jetzt leichter also dass das fand ich z.b. den anderen klären auch mal besser sie einfach mit den Cursortasten,
noch vor und zurückspulen konnte also weil das brauche ich wirklich.
Einfach mal schnell mal klingeln noch mal das ist cool noch mal was hat er gesagt um einmal so so eine Tasse 10 Sekunden zurück weil mit optischen geht aber gar nicht jetzt nicht irgendwie langsam oder so,
aber auf jeden Fall ist VLC hat jetzt wirklich mit diesen 3.0 einen riesengroßen riesengroßen Sprung gemacht.
Was auch schickes ich glaube das konnte der alte falls ihr auch nicht es gibt von dem Apple TV 4k da gibt's ja diese screen.
Selber Bilder da wo sie ganz langsam durch die Wüste fliegen oder ein von Dubai von oben so Aufnahme auch in HD haben die das auch,
und die kann selbst der QuickTime Player kann diese Videos nicht abspielen zu müssen nicht auf auf dem Mac Asus kann nur das Apple TV abspielen diese Dinger wo man kann ich aber mit so einem Link und wie downloaden bei Golem gibt's glaube ich aber danach Apple TV 4k Screensaver sucht dann kommt da so eine Seite wo die sind und der VLC der kann diese Dinger jetzt auch abspielen also das ist auch super also da.
Doch es sind es sind es unterschiedliche hier nach Apple TV.
Weil ich habe ja die nicht 4k ja die gibt es als als 2K HDR und ich hatte er ohne gibt's als 4k als normal und hatte er also auf diese auf diese Golem Seite gehen.
Muss mal suchen bei Google.
Apple TV Screensaver hatte jetzt nicht vor die runterzuladen weil die AppleTV macht das ja von sich Apple TV 4k Screensaver.
Passiert hier gar nicht auf meinem Rechner doch da die Sehne ist das genau die geile Teile diese Video sind die.
Schmeiß mal in na gut vielleicht nicht ich habe ich habe das lag nicht dass das gemacht musst ihr müsst ihr machen.
Aber die kann er auch auf jeden Fall abspielen und das ist das ist super ich habe mir das den Verein deshalb installiert weil es eben mir ist auch 360 Grad,
pizzaportal er schon bei der vorletzten sein oder meintest du bist da gerade am machen mit 360° genau ich habe jetzt eine Kamera auch wenn ich gerade irgendwie muckt und habe einen Guru auch Bilder gemacht jetzt hin,
selawat noch eine ganze Menge interessanter Einsatzmöglichkeiten also 360 Grad Video ist glaube ich wirklich Issing also da gibt's Ärger.
So viele gute Gründe warum man das haben will.
Ja und wenn man Planetarium an der Hand hat ja auch einfach auch fürs normale Videofilmen wird es irgendwie ein Ding sein.
Okay noch nicht überzeugt.
Kannst jetzt quasi also so zum exploring von Gegnern oder von Häusern oder Sachen einfach auch als Alternative zu normalen Film weil wenn du mit 360° video.
Double Fisheye oder was auch immer du für ein Objektiv hast durch die Gegend läuft dann kannst du im editing bestimmen wohin du guckst.
Ja ja du willst dir quasi dein Bildausschnitt den du sehen willst also der ganze Kameraschwenk muss nicht in dem Moment richtig sein weil du nimmst alles auf.
Und du kannst danach in der Post genau deine Kameraschwenk.
Was ist im virtuellen Raum und hast genau den Ausschnitt den du haben willst aber du meinst das ist noch für den Kattas kommt der Moment User nicht mehr an.
Bitte sieht kein 360° beson du willst nur in dieser 360° Kugel die Qualle dein Rohmaterial ist ja den Bildausschnitt den du haben willst und dadurch hast natürlich eine ganz andere Freiheit weil du auf einmal.
Nur noch an der richtigen Stelle sein muss aber nicht mehr in die richtige Richtung gucken muss ja also das eher selten wie du das beim Film wie soll die das bewerten.
Das ist halt für bestimmte Situationen ja was weiß ich angenommen du nimmst auch irgendwas was nur einmal aufgenommen werden kann auf,
ja weil irgendwas danach so kaputt ist und das war so teuer dass es nur genau einmal machen kannst wurde dann dann ist sozusagen einmal alles aufnehmen schon mal ganz gut weil dann kann ich kein Detail verloren geht,
dass man nur so als ein Aspekt das andere ist natürlich die ganze Action Videos kann ich mir gut vorstellen wo du sowieso Probleme hast die Kamera auf dem,
Action drauf zu richten also das was GoPro ja vorher Warnung,
da hattest du immer das Problem dass die GoPro halt relativ gut ausrichten musst und hoffen muss dass sie dann noch alleine drauf ist das nicht irgendwas genau anerkannte verbindet und so weiter ist also dann genauso kannst du natürlich darüber und das machen ja auch schon viele Kameras.
Kannst du darüber natürlich auch rütteln und Erschütterung rausrechnen weil ja quasi virtuell,
weil du so viel drumrum hat das ist einfach nur du kannst den Bilder haben der das eben muss schon rein physikalisch ausgleicht du kannst es in dem Moment indem du einfach nur die Beschleunigungssensoren und Solar Kamera auswertet kannst du eben das auch schon ausrechnen da du ja immer alles aufnimmt.
Lässt du halt einfach dein Bild sowie die besonderen kannst du quasi schon mal das Material bei der Aufnahme in drucken,
kostet aber auch dann richtig viel Platz.
Klar ist nicht für alles und munter und nicht jetzt normale Kameras werden verschwinden dass wenn sie nicht gerade mit objektive und so weiter über bisher auch sehr eingeschränkt aber.
Ist jetzt auch nicht so dass es überhaupt gar keinen Grund gäbe für 360 Grad Videos nicht so dass man sie sagt also ein Quatsch es braucht doch keiner also es ist nicht so wie.
Was ich.
3D im Kino oder so wobei 3D ist das auch noch so ein Ding weißt du bist das letzte Mal auch schon erzählt ne insta360 Kamera besprochen haben wir darüber gesprochen oder wenn ich darüber sprachen.
Keiner kann mich auch nicht erinnern.
Ich weiß es jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr wenn man mit so vielen Leuten wird so viele Sachen redet was weiß ich was ich indem ich sage jetzt einfach noch mal also eine Kamera die derzeit von vielen empfohlen wird,
um solche 360ball du hattest oder vorletzten Sendung die Pro.
War das wieder installieren ich die Google kann ich mir nicht an aber so ein anderer nicht aber nicht mechanische Renate davor.
Mit umzingelt was dazu 180° Helferteam GoPro Fusion genau aber die habe ich damit gar nicht erwähnt die hat ja auch nicht.
Die hatte jemand anders dabei die hat er sich allerdings noch bevor ich zum Einsatz bringen könnte es ihm irgendwie über den Beton gekullert weil das nicht richtig am Stativ festgemacht hat da war sie dann gleich breit,
für eine Kamera die man soeben 3700 € auf ruft schon nicht so schön ne na ja gut Pech gehabt.
Das ist halt ziemlich Monster also Ding ist ungefähr so groß wie so ein Handball.
Wo meine Fresse ja ungefähr das ist im runter geplumpst na ja verstehe ich hörte es nur so klack klack klack klack Geräusche.
Ja und das Video ne habe ich leider nicht in dem Moment oder was weiß ich auf jeden Fall im Prinzip ist das hier das selbe Prinzip.
Brigitte Prinzip better Tapete dummes Zeug also lass uns endlich siehst du es ein Fischaugen.
Quasi auf dieser Kugel also annehmen also quasi dem Aequator dieses bald angeordnet also mal 60 Grad oder ein bisschen mehr zum überlappen.
Du hast du mal 60 Grad Unterschied und hast aber 180° Fisheye das heißt die Überlappung,
bin ich ganz sicher ob es für dich 180 Grad sind es auch etwas weniger weil sie dich brauchen vielleicht sind auch nur einer 20 weiß ich nicht genau auf jeden Fall haben sie eine signifikant Überlappung die brauchen sie ja ohnehin,
ja aber bei diesen double Fisheye Dingern wurde ja nur zweimal 180 hast oder vielleicht 185 ist halt die Überlappung relativ gering und deswegen diese stitching auch,
nur mit extrem hohen,
Software Aufwand gut hinzubekommen und wenn du so Extremsituationen hast wie viel Licht auf der einen Seite dunkel auf der anderen Seite dann ist alles vorbei,
hier kenne ich jetzt noch keine konkreten Ergebnisse aber das Ding hat natürlich erstmal schon eine ganz andere Auflösung also das kann irgendwie 8k Video machen,
8k Bilder machen,
es hat einen Streaming Server direkt dran du kannst quasi aus der Kugel direkt raus drin was wenn das Ding auf die auf dem Stativ irgendwohin stellst dann kannst du 360 Grad video streaming machen mit dem Teil hat andere neuen 4k laut,
webseite ja das mag sein genau ist streaming,
Livestream geht dann nur vier Karten zu verschiedene Limitierung also wenn du sozial recorded hast du alles in auch in 8k,
oder immer anhören Framerates und wenn du es irgendwie ziemlich machst dann dir sagen 4k stitching bzw Livestreaming in Echtzeit und 8 Casting in der Nachbearbeitung.
Genau sowas,
wobei 4k streaming jetzt auch mal völlig ausgereicht mir sowieso indiskutabel genau.
Was aber auch noch so ein interessantes Feature ist dadurch dass hier so viel Überlappung haben bis diese sechs Kameras sehen sie quasi auch jeden. Doppelt.
Also am Samstag voll Überlappung heißt.
Sie sehen Nazi jeden Punkt doppelt und das bedeutet dass sie halt auch gleich 3D machen können.
Was ist total nicht nur eine rundumkamera das ist auch noch ein rundum 3D Kamera und 3D machen sie auch in 4K in Echtzeit allerdings nur 24 frames.
Aber immerhin nur Kino mehr nicht 3D machen in 30 friend.
Also für mich was ich geil finde ist sie schreiben hier sie haben vier eingebaute Mikrofon ich frage mich ob da tatsächlich auch 4 Spur Audio rauskommt auf jeden Fall kommt das und Surround Sound raus.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau ob das mit fünf nur mit 5.1 abgelegt wird oder wie sie das machen oder ob sie da sozusagen sind in den Jahren Surround Kram haben da wird auch teilweise noch mit viel bezahlt Kollege arbeitet bei GoPro.
Sind das hört sich irgendwie alles einnorden aber das ist das ist wirklich schon ein extrem solide verarbeitet das Teil und ich mag ja sowieso Geräte die serienmäßigen Ethernet Steckdose haben 1,2 Kilogramm.
Es ist ein ziemlicher Klotz dass es 1600 Euro das ja 37 oder so was hältst du mal nicht mal eben an der Hand also da brauchst du dich schon richtig richtig gutes Stativ und und wenn du es,
wenn du damit rumlaufen willst dann brauchst wahrscheinlich so ein Steadycam Gurt.
Na so ein Helm dass du das Ding auf dem Kopf weh,
zu viele na ja ich weiß noch gar nicht was sieht alles so spannend ist das auch nicht allein wohnt.
Susanne 360° Kamera gehabt hättest du mal genau gewusst was da auf mich zukommt aufpassen was da passiert ist mir was über die jetzt anschauen wollen aber ist egal hätte mich interessiert Tatsache ist na siehst du mal nächste Mal nächste Mal mit einer Fusion auf dem Helm.
Vielleicht auch mit einem Achsen Sensor.
So was soll ich jetzt eigentlich sagen ich wollte sagen es gibt schon wirklich ziemlich amtliches Gerät für na ja also finanzierbare Bereich wenn mein Sohn Interesse 4k steht hier auf der Website vom Preis her wann weiß.
Hey I offizielle Preis kriegst wahrscheinlich mabea Shipping free tax included ja irgendwie sowas in der Größe 9 mal sehen auch 4k.
Bin im Jahr Küsse für die Hälfte aber würde ich mal was das für eine irre Technologie ist und wie schnell ist das natürlich jetzt noch weiterentwickeln wird wenn die Prinzessin power,
ja da musst du aufpassen musst aber wirklich Projekt haben wo du das wirklich brauchst das jetzt nicht eben mal so nebenbei so als Gimmick oder für eine so eine Sache weil du bei 4k musste schon.
Du musst ja dauerhaft im Einsatz sein damit sich das lohnen.
Ja aber das ist ja wirklich nicht hinstellen wenn er nur zweimal im Jahr damit schämst nein natürlich nicht aber ich muss jeder selber wissen.
Erinnert euch wir als wir hin als wir auf der Locationsuche waren für ein Kongress.
Aber hat Michaela hat ja doch auch schon so einen dicken Ball gehabt jetzt offen fettes Teil 2 Wochen sind 3000 € das hat sich irgendwie gemietet von dieser berlinerbude werden auch drüber gesprochen gestellt bekommen sogar damit sie damit Sachen macht,
ja genau sie war irgendwie damit unterwegs oder haben wir das gemacht und haben halt diese Bilder gemacht vom Messe,
Zentrum in Leipzig bei der ersten das glaube ich, ich kann ohne hieß ja ich glaube das war's genau.
Und diesen und wieso hat pleite gewesen ne nononononono kommen.
Gibt's noch.
Dass wir werden komplett pleite die waren irgendwie Pleite gibt es aber irgendwie noch genau kann oder die ist ja noch mal ein bisschen extremer die hat so rundum überall ganz viele Kameras,
die insta 360 denke ich mal schafft in etwa dieselbe Fidelity.
Mit weniger Kameras ja wahrscheinlich hier hochwertige Kameras genommen und machen das irgendwie alles mit weiß ich nicht bessere Optik keine Ahnung.
Auf jeden Fall wird das sehr für amtliches panono wird schon sehr Plastik mäßig das Teil ist so richtig Metallgehäuse ordentlich verarbeitet so das fand ich schon sehr überzeugend habe ich es nicht getestet daran.
Stopp das natürlich relativ schnell weil man sich irgendwie auch anguckt die Gruppe Software das ist auch alles so Leute echt irgendwie user interface mäßig erstmal wieder alles neu erfinden und dann.
Völlig.
Komische eingeschränkte Operationen also so richtig geil ist das alles noch nicht aber es soll ich von der GoPro für morgen nein nein ich meine Musik GoPro Software ist ist komisch,
bei der Ricoh halt irgendwie ja da hast du deine Smartphone App,
und dann reißt immer wieder die WLAN Verbindung ab und dann noch mal auf das Leben und wirst es einfach bekloppt mit izazov Ersatzteile naturverein hast du die.
Die Theta V habe ich schon auch ein Link auf was jetzt auf die ja.
Kamera kann ich dir auch bieten das ist halt so die discount Variante die die die Theta v.
Kann man halt ganz gut damit kann man ganz gut rumspielen als die ist die ist ja relativ erschwinglich und ist von daher.
Von daher so zum Ausprobieren ganz gut die kann man auch so eine Hand halten aber es würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt machen.
Wann hast du mal deine Hände mit auf dem Bilde machte unten so ein so ein kleinen Griff dran und damit kannst du das irgendwie ganz ordentlich.
Treiben darf ich jetzt auch gerade darf ich mich auch lange lange lange lange gesucht also wird hatte Dich Interesse hat sich so ein teil.
Zu holen du meinst jetzt die Täter ich meine jetzt die Täter genau.
Wahrscheinlich erst mal hier auf meinen anderen Account wechseln und das ist rufe finden also ich habe lange gesucht das richtige Stativ concept dafür zu finden das war irgendwie alles gar nicht so einfach Bärentöter.
Die hattest du hier ne die hat mir angeguckt ja genau aber die hat sich irgendwie gerade ein wenig verabschiedet.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau die schaltet sich gerade irgendwie nicht ein keine Ahnung was mit dem Teil gerade los ist.
Das Internet also ich habe das hier noch mit in die.
Handy schon aus rein dieses nette handstativ was nämlich sehr schön zum Verlängern ist für normale Stative aber auch super sitzen mal eben in der Hand halten das ganz gute Ergänzung.
Hallo habe ich da nicht zu sehr viel zu zu sagen wollte wandern voll viel kann diese Videos jetzt abspielen genau und vorher nicht oder.
Übersetzen neues Feature jetzt kannst du das halt irgendwie rein Dragon ist nicht besonders gelungen dafür.
Ja für jedes Mal wieder wie das heißt wir 14 Uhr gesprochen dass du wieder Bezeichnung für die Art und Weise im Prinzip das ja nichts anderes heißen Fischaugen.
360° Bild auf normale Kamera Viereck Dimensionen.
Alter Laptop Airlines also.
Hallo ja im Prinzip von oben nach unten 180° hast aber von rechts nach links dran also wenn das jemand weiß wie diese Bilder heißt Mist ist es gerade in falschen wie wie man das nennt diese diese Verzerrung.
Aber das ist halt irgendwie das was letzten Endes aus dem stitcher rausfällt und das wirst du halt einfach in falls ihr an ist auch das was du zu YouTube hochladen kannst also als Video.
Wobei du komischerweise bei YouTube noch vorher dir so ein Download ist und so ein Tagging tool Downloaden musst.
Guten Video rein schmeiß wo er irgendwelche Metadaten sitzt damit du wenn du die hochlädst er erkennt dass das das ist ein shutter irgendwie Sonne.
Vielleicht kannst du machen mit bitte hier einmal 360 Grad na ja.
Leider den Chat noch die Frage wie wie fährt man 360 Grad Bilder also ich denke das ist alles so ein Thema das wird sich so im Laufe dieses Jahres erledigen,
kann ich mir jetzt nicht vorstellen dass das jetzt noch lange dauert weil diese Verfügbarkeit von 360° Kameras die wird jetzt einfach dazu führen dass wir immer mehr solche Bilder sehen und dann werden solche Viewer einfach,
eine schöne Eva also glaube ich warum es ja auch kommen würdest durch diese vr-brillen ne.
Mama da drinne dann so schön rum gucken kann weil sonst finde ich die ganze spannt diese 360° Videos.
Richtig du musst natürlich einen richtigen Betrachtung Kontakt haben da gibt's halt drei Möglichkeiten also das hat ein Planetarium oder oder Bauverein.
Kommt werde ich auch noch mal so dass das Heimplanetarium sich schon kommen zum aufpusten ja.
Wieso nicht mehr brauchst eine 360° Leinwand fürs umrechnen.
Sag oder sitzt das perfekt an der Mitte und dann rechnet er so aus als wenn die Ecke da gar nicht da wäre der homepod akustisch dein Zimmer vermisse und Laserscanner drinnen und Naomi das fehlt somit Bump Mapping direkt auf deinen auf den ganzen Innenraum drauf kopieren kann aber nur mit einem Gerät ab,
spielen und anhören so so,
bei diesen 30° Dingen Schwanen in Panama in dem Bio Museum.
Jung Museum das ist ein Museum über so Biodiversität spezielle Mittelamerika und warum Mittelamerika wichtig ist als Austausch zwischen Nord und Süd und wann das halt entstanden ist also.
Ziemlich interessantes Museum und die hatten Installation wo sie versucht haben mit manchmal überlegen 12345.
Display Wars einen Rundumblick zu bauen was ganz cool wäre sowas halt gesessen auf einem Glasboden was unter die halt teilweise Dinge gesehen und dann vor die Leinwand und oben.
Also drei Leinwände so um mich drumrum nur hinter dir war nichts und das war ganz nett gemacht.
Aber an einigen Stellen merkt man halt noch so dass man mit dieser zicken ist halt so ein bisschen Probleme bekommen kann wenn da.
Videos noch nicht so gut abgestimmt sind oder du hast zu schnelle Kamera wechseln mit sie hat nur so eine Späße gemacht wie erst geht der erste Bildschirm an zum Spiel unter dir und dann,
schalten sich die anderen alle dazu und wenn du dann halt so sehr rum.
Rumdrehen dich nicht so rum drehen musst mit deinem Kopf merkt man dass das noch mal ein ganz schönes so ein Dämpfer ist an dem Spaß an sowas,
das muss schauen muss schon aufpassen damit das gehört nicht ins Eiern kommt.
Ich habe einmal auf einer Messe gesehen da hatten sie Daten sie Displays an die Decke gehängt.
Und dann so eine Videos wo jemand auf Nase von unten durch eine Glasplatte durch gefilmt.
Wo sie dann Zeug gemacht haben oder am schönsten war wo hat jemand Zwiebeln geschnitten hat auf der Glasplatte und zwar halt von unten gefilmt und hast du nach oben geguckt und hast du einen von oben gesehen,
also von unten gesehen wie er oben Zwiebeln schneidet unsere 20 ganz niedlich höher Kapellmeister,
kapellmann Kapellmeister ja also ich habe ja in den Ort habe ich noch mal diese Stativ weil noch mal kurz erwähnen warum das so praktisch ist erstmal ist das okay,
ja ja also das mega-entwicklung ich gerade nicht liegen.
Ja weil ich hatte erst das Problem als ich die Reise geplant habe dass das Stativ nicht das Fotostativ nicht hoch genug war ich wollte das ja so über Kopf haben und normale Fotostative die Enden halt alle um die Suppe 1.
80 und ich wollte was haben was ich einfach.
Muss aber so eine Viertel Zoll also Herr bist ein Viertel Zoll Schraube Stativ Schraube quasi am Ende.
Wo ich einfach Viertel Zoll drauf machen kann und noch mal verlängern kann das geht damit aber ist auch ein super handstativ weil halt unten den Griff hast und nach oben verlängert.
Und kannst du es mir ebenso mit mit einer einfachen schraub Bewegung kriegste das Ding rausgezogen mit der alles wieder in die andere Richtung also alles auf einmal und dann wird es irgendwie fest nicht so mega fest zum drauf stellen aber so reicht schon.
Und wenn halt oben die Kamera hast kannst du halt mal eben irgendwo stehen machst den Arm hoch.
Hat das Ding irgendwie ein Meter über deinem Kopf oder machst du einfach mal korrektes 360° Bild.
Oder Video je nachdem muss dann halt über dein Telefon fernbedienen wo du Glanz war noch irgendwie unten zu sehen bist aber du bist halt wirklich nur unten zu sehen und du hast nicht Obi noch deine Griffe so weit ins Bild rein ist richtig.
Stört.
Und das schon mal sehr praktisch und relativ günstig und meiner Meinung nach fast das einzige Modell auf dem Markt was jetzt genauso aufgebaut ist und Sohn Dual use,
hat sodass mit einer Täter kombinieren oder mit einer anderen günstigen 360° Kamera man ist irgendwie schon dabei und ich finde zu die,
die dokumentationsqualität deshalb wollte ich vorhin auch nicht sagen als du es erwähnt dass mit Michaela nein in Leipzig.
Die Bilder die werden vom vom Messegelände gemacht haben die war danach auch ins Bett gepackt haben mit unserem JavaScript Mumpitz.
Vergessen habe was gibt da unsere JavaScript Bibliothek mit den du eben mal eben auch so ein 360° Viewer ins Web Chris nicht nur der nicht nur so diese Entzerrung macht sondern der,
auch noch die Möglichkeit bietet die Seelen miteinander zu verbinden so dass du quasi das Geld habe.
Dennis besser wo ist die Taste wenn man sie,
weiß ich nicht probier's aus muss die drei drauf stehen in alten Zeiten es in die richtig alten Zeiten also.
Wann war das 92.
Kann Quicktime for errors ich habe das gemacht für zwei Fotografen Mann ist das lange her und hat das alles funktioniert aber an mehrere Skripten MPW.
Command line war das mit dem man diese Vernetzung machen konnte man halt immer diese 360 Grad Bilder das gab's ja quasi schon und dann kannst du die mit so hot,
Pons miteinander mit verlinkungs Punkten vernetzen das ist halt Ludwigsfeld und wo drauf und dann,
vorzugsweise von Raum zu Raum marschieren was schon mal ganz ordentlich ihre Stative Kamera drauf machen aber so ein Stativ mit der Gradanzeige haben und muss dann genau immer 12 Grad oder so musste so weitergehen und das nächste Bild man das musst aber auch wirklich stimmen dann war das ditching nachher im Eimer und so also das war alles da mal so eine frickel Arbeit,
die haben da glaube ich auch gut Geld verdienen für Sohn,
Firmen die gerne so 3D mäßig Ihre Räume präsentieren wo man dann so rum wandern kann und sich drehen kann und so ja den habe ich das alles.
Ja wieso zeigt digitalisiert die beiden Foto mehrere 360 Grad Bilder,
also miteinander vernetzen das ging halt bei dieser Software auch gerade noch mal rausholen ich wär so ein bisschen Google,
Google Street Wetteraussichten genauso wie Google Street View Brentano ja das kann sein dass es das ist genau schlimmer name,
der Effekt war dass wir uns,
das auch Leute die nicht da waren aber auch dorthin und Jana gehörten ein extrem gutes Gefühl für diesen Raum bekommen haben die nur so aus normalen Fotos.
Das hat noch nie funktioniert das funktioniert nur wenn du dir irgend detailsmerken willst Beschriftung oder wie,
welche Kabel meinst du dass es eines Tages so geht das so einfach dass die sagen hier du läufst mit dieser 3D Kamera du läufst da durch die Gegend mit dem Ding lass das einfach an nimmst alles auf,
dann kommt nachher so ein cooles 3D Tool Wasserwiderstand in 3D.
Also was dient die Ecken aus dem Film und wie mehr oder weniger raus rechnet die Texturen an die Wand klatschen Trainer noch so ein 3D macht das der,
nachher da da drin rum läuft nicht so läuft wie du mit deiner 3D gucken auf dem sondern dass der sich komplett voll frei bewegen kann so wie man jetzt in Apple Maps ABBA 3D Welt auch darüber fliegt das damit innerhalb von Räumen genauso machen wie die das von oben mit der Stadt machen,
Getränke ich kenne deinen Traum daraus projizieren und und und und am besten Leichen im Propeller Drohne machen das also nur so eine kleine Drohne nämlich gleich mal kurz alleine 60 Grad Kamera drauf das Ding fliegt irgendwie dicht über dem Boden.
Und was weiß ich dreht sich dann vielleicht noch mal um und und und und und und denselben,
nächsten paar Jahre kommt das wahrscheinlich dauert noch ein paar Jahre bei Stunde sind wir jetzt schon nah dran dass ich habe so 360° Videos vom Kongress jetzt schon gesehen mit Flügen über also jetzt nicht mit dieser Berechnung aber.
Da passiert was ich glaube 360° is here to stay und die die Anmeldung sind vielfältig und das wird fortgeschrittener Immersion führen.
Also durch digitalisierte und ohnehin Fortgeschrittene Immersion.
Darauf läuft raus.
Oder Tim Ja ich will auf jeden Fall da unten mein Zeug noch erzählen bevor ihr alle wieder flüchten weil sie meinen sie müssen nach Hause erzähl mal einen Witz.
Jannis erzähl mal soll ich da unten jetzt machen mal kurz weg Spruch von den Apps ja okay ja,
ja ich hatte ganz in der vorletzten Sendung schon hatte ich dass der kurz angeschnitten dass ich vektorisiert werden soll ich weiß gar nicht ob du das weißt du ja,
was vektorisiert werden ja wie du meinen Internetanbindung zu Hause ich weiß es noch so ganz nebenbei hatte ich da ein bisschen rum gehört hast mein PPPoE dann wegfällt und dass ich ja Schiss habe ich dann nicht mache und so erinnere mich genau schon geschrieben alles kein Problem,
da würdest du ein Gerät geben das heißt Draytek Vigor 130.
Habe ich mir auch geguckt habe gesehen das machen Leute das ist ein ganz normales Vectoring Modem was nichts weiter hat als den DSL ein,
dank unten Ethernet Ausgang und also kein Telefon kein Schnickschnack und auch nicht mal eine zweite Switch Boxer sondern einfach wirklich nur DSL rein Internet raus und PPPoE dadrüber.
Und schon geklickt dann habe ich auf die Umstellung gewartet die haben sie natürlich verkackt da war ich noch mal zehn weitere Tage komplett ohne Internet.
Weil Telekom hat irgendwie den Termin verschoben bis sie da einen umswitchen wie auch immer dann war der Tag da.
Ich hatte diese Standard Homebox to die man da vorher zugeschickt.
Kommt dran weil das jetzt ja Vectoring und ich normales DSL heißt dass die alte Kiste hat ja nicht funktioniert das hat sofort geklappt natürlich weil es ja deren Kiste nachdem ich gemerkt habe okay die Leitung geht.
Habe ich das Draytek Vigor Teil dazwischen geschaltet mein FreeBSD Route hatte die Passwörter schon gegeben und normalerweise ist ja so wenn man neue Technik kriegt man will immer bisschen so rum spielen und testen und man weiß es geht erst nicht immer muss ich beschäftigen und so na ja.
Passwörter ich beim Friebe Station eingetragen ich mache diese Draytek Vigor das modern da rein und das Internet ging so scheiße ich kann gar nicht rumspielen also das war wirklich ultra easy.
Dann dachte ich naja wenn Direktorin bei mir machen müsste ich ja,
Viktring ist LW 25 Mbit und 50 Mbit und mit Tier Vektor ja so das eine noch das VDSL mit wegbringen dann eigentlich sogar bis 100 Mbit muss der hat auf meiner Leitung bisschen was gehen was ist aus mein 16Mbit wurden jetzt 14 einhalb,
weil eben nichts geht.
Was geht da halt irgendwie nicht mehr wenn du fragst bei meiner Location was dann gehen würde dann sagen sie auch maximal 16 Uhr in meinem Fall halt 14 halt,
das einzige was ich verbessert hattest weil sie jetzt ja den Teil die Frequenz die vorher fürs Telefonieren benutzen oder wo kann man den Splitter brauchte das Benutzen sehr zu den Uplink deswegen habe ich jetzt anstatt ein Mbit Uplink zweieinhalb Mbit.
Was schon mal okay ist weil ablegen will man ja ein bisschen mehr und das ist ganz gut aber sonst.
Ja ist bei mir weiterhin Netz er so vorsintflutlich da geht nicht so viel,
aber ich kann für alle Leute sagen dies vielleicht vor dem gleichen Problem stehen weil es wird jetzt eine Menge umgestellt also wer über seinen PPPoE selber machen will und nicht irgendwie sie Homebox tun haben will und so weiter und so fort erholt sich diese,
Draytek Vigor 130 kostet 100 € das Ding,
da macht man sich seinen seinen der Selter selber macht sich deine FreeBSD Linux Kiste oder was auch immer auf eine Fritzbox oder dahinter ist alles gar kein Problem und dann funktioniert das,
und habe ich da noch was gemacht ja wenn Leute das machen meinen.
Was ich noch geändert habe ist ich habe immer festgestellt dass unter FreeBSD bei meiner PPPoE spricht oder PPP das halt das bei meinen 16Mbit vorher mein kleiner Tom Rechner hat irgendwie wenn die Leitung vollen Benutzung war der hat der PPP Prozess.
10 % CPU Last verbraucht also.
Für alle für 16 Mbit also wo sonst irgendwie die Dinger weiß nicht wie viel Megabyte oder 100 MB auch von Platte und von sonst Netz schieben ja hat mich das ein bisschen gewundert.
Und dann habe ich mal von dem Bild in PPP auf mpd5 gewechselt dass es so ein Multilink PPP,
der auch PPPoE kann natürlich und der so das alles,
wenn ich im Userland macht sondern so auf Kölner Seite was viel weniger CPU verbraucht und der hat jetzt einfach bei.
0 % rum egal wie viel ich da drüber ballere weil der das alles dem Colonel gibt und der können macht das und.
Ja da deutlich weniger CPU-Last und da kann man noch viel mehr einstellen und gucken und so dann ist man richtig so low level da an sein Paketen dran kann und die Mitte MTU rumspielen und Mitte,
ja kann alles viel besser anpassen und so hast es hat mir die letzten zwei Wochen sehr Spaß gemacht da die letzten Sun Performance aus meiner Leitung rausholen weil ich brauche das ja auch weil ich habe jetzt nur noch 14 halber wieso hast du denn nur 16.
Nicht mehr meiner Gegend.
Ist der Leitung der schlecht die wird gerade die geraten noch mal 5 irgendwas mit acht lightoller.
Gibt's auch mehr Netz,
was er wahrscheinlich machte wenn ich das du hörst ja zu es gibt für den Dreck wie Igor gibt es verschiedene Firmen wär's,
und eine davon die nennt sich M7 ist speziell halt für das Telekom Vectoring also der sind super Parameter schon irgendwie angepasst und für Deutschland oder für die Telekom halt.
Soll man die M7 nehmen die wer wohl am die Welt das ja wohl die richtige,
und ich habe auch im Internet schon gelesen dass einer meint ja er hätte einfach mal die 18 genommen wobei ich nicht genau weiß für welches Land M8 ist oder wo die überhaupt,
zu kriegen es wahrscheinlich auch mehr FTP Server aber wenn man auf der Webseite geht dann sieht man die dann nicht und dann wär's ein Stück schneller aber ich behaupte mal dass meine,
14 Mbit wirklich deswegen nur 14 weil ich wahrscheinlich keine Ahnung für 100000 km von von der.
Gegenüberliegende Stelle weg bin dass es einfach nicht besser wird oder vielleicht mit M8 komme ich dann auf 14,7 oder auf 15 MBit aber es wird mich jetzt nicht irgendwelche anderen Dimensionen befördern und.
Bist du denn so weit weg vom Verteiler weil ich weiß ja nicht wo der ist ich weiß dass mein nächster Link steht was mit BR un,
wenn das richtig ist was ich denke dann ist es Brunnenstraße und ist von mir zu Hause verdammt hinweg das stimmt müsste man sowas nicht auf OpenStreetMap mittlerweile auch ich weiß nicht auch diverse Informationen hat,
dann würde mich das schon auch interessieren wie wie weit weg ich bin weil bei mir gegenüber die Straßenseite ein bisschen weiter hoch die Straße ich weiß sag jetzt mal nicht wo ich wohne aber da haben die 50 Mbit also ich weiß nicht ob.
Die da drüben schon auf deiner Seite ein bisschen weiter Pause man weiter zu Seite ob die an der anderen Station ansprechen wollen Berlin bitte ich wohne in Berlin Mitte ja Alter wo sonst Mann und wer Brunnenstraße,
der Brunnenstraße ist das noch bitte nee das nicht mehr mit dir da oben und Straße ragt in Mitte rein ja also die letzten Reste,
na ja jedenfalls in meiner Straße ist,
also wenn man Verfügbarkeitscheck macht ist kommt da 16 Mbit und mehr geht auch nicht wir würden einen gerne empfehlen 125 weil das nächst kleineres 10 x 16 gibt es anscheinend gar nicht mehr weil sie hat auf diese VDSL Größen umgeschwenkt haben also 10 25 50 100,
und mir empfehlen natürlich 25.
Und sagen dann aber wir können natürlich dann nur das liefern was technisch geht was in meinem Fall anscheinend wird fünf sind aber der wird es wenn ich das jetzt umgestellt hätte ich ja nichts von weil ich habe ja schon Vertrag und die neuen Verträge haben alle.
300GB Max Telekom o2.
Können bei o2 o2 aber die dissecting macht ja die Telekom also die kaufen sich das bei denen ein was kann ja nur einer machen aber warum bist du immer hin.
Weil das war die guten waren dachte ich Hansenet und damals helles ja lange noch vorher.
Körnerkissen die auch amedi Hilfen für andere Hansenet nicht anders und daran dazwischen wie es nicht einmal Melissa LSA.
Ja ja.
Sicherlich noch ich war auch bei wir gehen da kommen ja noch eine aber nur die nur die Mobilfunker okay,
weil da bin ich auch bei denen ja okay dann bin ich wieder Günther kommen bei bei mobil wir sind auch noch alle,
genau ne aber ist ja 3 Gigabyte o2 schickt euch und wenn du bei Netflix 4k HDR guckst.
Und bei mir mit meinem vierten Mbit,
dann schraubt er so ab und zu mal bis bis 11 Uhr oder er wird auch ab und zu mal 15 merken das reicht nicht und dann schreibt er wieder auf 11 MBit runter das heißt wenn du mal sonst Film in 4K HDR guckst wenn du deine 25 Mbit hättest oder ein bisschen mehr und da gibt's auch eine Drohne Gigabyte ne,
dann kannst du im Monat ja vielleicht irgendwie Film gucken na ja so eine oder zwei Staffeln irgendwie bin ich waschen und dann sind deine 300GB weg.
Und also das geht gar nicht also 300 Gigabyte ist ja mal ist ja mal nix Gigabyte ist prekäres Internet ja.
Also sie sagen sie drosseln dann ein aber auch erst wenn das 3 Monate lang also trotzdem dass alle also ich freue mich mein Bitcoin die man ja die ganze Zeit rum rund um die Uhr als unity,
wie sagt man ja also Angebote Funkbereich ist o2 noch zu ertragen weil sie.
Zumindest nicht völlig indiskutable Datentarife haben sondern nur sind nur scheiße aber halt nicht,
nicht so kriminell wie bei der Telekom,
und dass sie jetzt aber auch diesen Drossel Kram dann wiederum bei DSL also da kann ich dir halt nicht ernst nehmen also nicht nur 300 und es wird nicht mal mehr wenn man das ob man 50 nimmt oder 25 das immer,
100 Gigabyte ist ein bisschen bisschen nachmachen im Meer werden ist einfach lächerlich und wenn ihr euch irgendwie.
Es ist es ist es ist alles so krank in diesem Land warum muss das so sein das gibt einfach aber keine Gründe dafür war ich ja im Club und habe rumgeheult dass ich kein Internet habe mehr.
Und dann meint einer von den Kids war es noch nicht mal mit geht eigentlich aber er war gerade da und das öfters so such mal da ja hier willst du willst du meine bz meine LTE Karte haben er ist demnächst im Urlaub und er hat dann noch Restguthaben und der braucht ihn nicht.
Meine Liebe Restguthaben hast du denn ja da sind noch 60 GB drauf auf einer LTE Karte.
Was oder wo gibt's denn sowas ist aus Italien aber die geht ja hier in Deutschland auch weil die kümmern sich dann nicht und du kannst ja einfach verballern weil die ist ja egal also bist du hast dich halt bis zum Monatsende also habe ich diese LTE Karte,
bekommt nachdem ihr ja scheiße mein Phone will ich dir nicht weil ich will ja da weiter in Mainz haben was mache ich nach dann der andere im Club ja ich habe ja noch so.
Wie ist das Ding eigentlich Box LTE und wann Netgear,
r-card ist ein kleines Teil mit Batterie schon drin schiebst du deine LTE karte rein hat auch im Display vor der kannst du alles einstellen und so legst du einfach hin und Ela dass Ihr WLAN über deine LTE Karte kannst auch sehen wie viel darüber geht wie viel der runtergeladen hast und alles habe ich gemacht.
Da habe ich mehr mit rüber geballert als über mein Festnetz also das schafft die hat wirklich 30 40 Mbit oder so gemacht und damit habe ich.
Netflix 4k movies gucken können habe ich nicht gemacht weil ich wollte die 60GB dich,
doch muss ja nicht wie lange die brauchen werde ne und habe mich ein bisschen zurückgehalten aber das Ding hat perform das war das flutscht,
also Latenz war natürlich nicht so toll Pakete waren auch nicht so toll weil die mussten erst nach Italien und wieder zurück und heute ging wirklich über Italien weiß ja nicht derjenige karte und mein google war danach in Italienisch und so aber Performance mäßig das.
DASDING was also wenn man so eine gleiche Karte von dem deutschen Provider hätte die da nicht über Italien Fliesen Sohn die Pakete dann wäre das richtig flott ich also,
kann man nur empfehlen dann im Urlaub sind ne Kauf LTE card also kaufDA SIM-Karte mit LTE drauf kann sie sich also lohnt sich.
Du bist billig billig sogar nachher Grundsteuer senken wenn irgendwie Glasfaseranschluss vorhanden wenn man die Forderung.
Fieber senken Grundsteuer senken ich meine rate mal das Problem Glasfaser ich meine liegt ja schon auf der Straße teilweise bloß nicht in die Häuser.
Bin noch nicht so richtig viel weitergekommen hierbei Projekt x ja unsere Häuser hier versorgen weil hat keinen Kopf dafür aber.
Du hast eine neue 100ml oder immerhin ja ich habe 100 Mbit.
Ich war froh wenn ich 25 hätte oder meine 16 Uhr wieder ja nur weil du dann schon darüber froh wärst weil du noch prekären Sklaven Zuständen liebst muss ich ja nicht auf mein Recht auf Gigabyte 40 also.
Was ich sagen will ist das Problem sind jetzt nicht immer nur die Telekom Unternehmen die auch und die Struktur auch Hammer alles tausend mal hier durch diskutiert.
Was sind einfach tasty house Betreiber die teilweise sich eben auf so.
Verträge mit Kabelanbieter in eingeladen Erde braucht Kabelfernsehen und kriegt er billiger wenn ihr dann keinen anderen rein nimmt und so weiter was ich ja auch schon mal,
das geht gar nicht das muss einfach verboten werden sowas ja solche Verträge darf es nicht geben darf kein Ausschluss von Konkurrenten geben keine Ahnung ob das bei uns hier im Haus so ist aber habe ich gehört dass es das gibt was habt ihr hier,
Kabel Deutschland jetzt immer kommen wir das andere gehabt,
möchte Etablissements in Jena Primacom was war das dritte was es noch gibt bald hast du mich bei dem mir die sind auch ganz schlimm richtige Vodafone Türdrücker nicht also hier,
Drückerkolonne.
Bruder Melone Tele Columbus.
Aber was also was wollen wir in meiner Wohnung da ich dir sagen ja mal Hausvertrag wahrscheinlich abgeschlossen dann irgendwas,
nach dem Motto wir liegen euch hier mal was rein und dann gibt's auch ganz schnelles super Speedy Internet mit nur und will mit 200 GB im Monat und so toll und,
und dann ist das aber dann sozusagen der exklusive.
Das Ding was exklusiv ist teilweise wird es auch mit diesem Haus so teilweise wird das dann auch noch mit der Haussprechanlage kombiniert das heißt die kommen dann da rein installieren quasi neue System und machen auch noch die Haussprechanlage dadrüber.
Erfurt Anger technischer Dienst dass man die Hausbetreuer die Hausverwaltung.
Will eigentlich gar nicht immer Waldemar diesen ganzen Technik scheiß aber nichts mit zu tun haben und deswegen kaufen die sich auch sowas wie eine Sprechanlage mal eben mal gerne mal ein und dann heißt es ja Sprechanlage heißt ja du musst einen.
Audio bidirektionalen audioweg in jede Wohnung haben und damit bist du ja quasi schon mal auf dem Pfad des Glücks weil damit legst du,
Kabel im Haus zu Teilnehmer und das ist ja sozusagen das eigentliche Gold du willst ja diesen Zugang haben zu der Wohnung der war dann halt wieder explosiv ist und Pipapo,
so aber solche Deals machen die daneben und da gibt's ja so ja hier guck mal das haben wir ja auch Kabel dann könnt ihr ja aber das Kabel kann ich auch Internet haben und Telefon und alles und alles wird schön und so und das finde ich gemacht planet,
gib mir aus der Sonne ich will ja irgendwie stabiles DSL haben und nicht irgend so einen kranken Telekom Telefonkabel Quatsch.
The mir irgendwelche Traum Download raten,
verspricht die vielleicht auch manchmal gibt aber daneben vielleicht manchmal auch nicht wenn man sie braucht überwiegend nur mit Uploads zahlen die sowieso nicht diskutabel sind sie für mich tausendmal wichtiger sind,
aber die die Glasfaser Fuzzi ist die verkaufen natürlich auch gleich das Kabelfernsehen mit dazu.
Ja gerne aber das ist ja nicht so sehr das Problem das Problem ist dass sie eben wer trägt die Kosten für den eigentlichen Anschluss der Wohnung also.
Die mit der Hausaufgabe Geschichte ist dass er auch noch so eine Geschichte dabei das wenn du dann zur Telekom wechselst.
Bitte dann wie festgestellt dass die Kabel teilweise die die Verbindung um nicht ankommt in deiner Wohnung und dann komm halt zigtausend Techniker ich weiß gar nicht wie das bei uns beendet ist mit,
was willst du Titel um zu dir.
In der Wohnung und ich habe mich da aber nicht drum gekümmert weil alles was Netzwerkes wollte mein Bruder machen also.
Gib ihm Hand da terra ständig sollen wir mit diesem Techniker dann rum kommunizieren und gucken ob Musik abelade oder normales Kupferdraht für Telefonanbieter,
muss ein extra noch ein Techniker kommen und gucken ob überhaupt der,
also da kein Signal liegt in überhaupt dieses Kabel ist das ist das Kabel überhaupt da also ich ein ewiges hin und her zwei Wochen glaube ich kein Internet und so weiter geht ja überdies Fernsehkabel.
Sind ja wieder zurück nein ja aber trotzdem der Anschluss erfolgt ja was Fernsehkarte sind 2 Grad Kabel Deutsche Telekom,
das sagte doch das ging das ging nicht der gut warum das nicht ging aber das nicht nicht weil jetzt der,
Telefonkabel Internetanbieter dieses Kabel benutzt hätte sondern weil wahrscheinlich jemand Kabel abgemacht hat,
Rivendell der Erdkabel der das ja das kann natürlich alles sein das weiß man nicht kann aber auch einfach sein das bei irgendeinem anderen Umstecken von Irrgang darin.
Passiert ist ich hatte ja auch das Problem bist ja wieder nur dich hier erzählt dass ich nach der Umstellung auf Vectoring auf einmal total langsam ist nett habe,
stellte sich am Ende heraus oder noch ein Telekom Techniker da war auch echt pfiffig und das alles schön analysiert festgestellt unten im Keller alles kein Problem Problem liegt sozusagen bei mir in der Wohnung und war das tatsächlich so dass die,
hirntoten Elektriker die schon so lange nicht mehr zählten was Sache ist dass dir wie die Kabel falsch angeschlossen haben ist habe ich den den Übergangspunkt habe ich jetzt gefunden und passt ja nicht wann hat die Paare falsch verdrillt so Kabel richtig angeschlossen alles wieder gut.
Was heißt Badewannenfaltwand Hellas ja so 4 Draht Kabel also zwei Jahre.
Ja das sind ja ja das sind zwei Paare die jeweils also ein paar ist immer verdreht und dann sind die beiden Paare noch mal untereinander verdreht ein dieselhorst Martin Vierer wie man so schnell.
Woher auch die passende Band zur hat ne und das geht bei mir auch in die Wohnung aber die,
Elektriker aber keine Ahnung von Telekommunikation und deswegen haben die halt einfach irgend so ein 4 Draht Kabel was nicht only verdrillt ist genommen und da dachte ich erst daran aber das Hauptproblem war,
wir haben halt einfach.
Nur quasi ein nur ein einziges dieser Kabel bei mir wirklich eine Dose an der richtigen Stelle an verstörender nach der Umstellung nicht mehr.
Landestheater im man das anders vertauscht seitdem das gut also zweimal noch nicht das richtige Kabel konnte ich jetzt nicht ersetzen weil wie eingegipst aber da ist halt nur ein paar Meter sind ist es nicht so das Problem.
Na ja also um normal den Punkt kurz zu Ende zu machen ich machen wollte wir haben unter anderem das Problem und das hast du ja auch.
Dass man die Hausbesitzer nicht dazu zwingen kann Glasfaser auch zunehmen selbst wenn es da wäre und sie ist deshalb auch nicht tun oder Incentive nicht da ist erstmal so was interessiert mich das Internet von meinen Mietern das kostet alles nur Geld.
Wenn das irgendwie ihr Fett etwas entspannter sehen und gutes Verhältnis zu ihren Mietern haben oder vielleicht auch mal begreifen dass sie damit den Wert Ihres Hauses ja auch steigern.
Behörden Argumentes.
Dann ist wieder mal das Problem wer zahlt die verglas Faserung der Steigleitung in die einzelnen Wohnung weil da wird dann halt oft sehr knifflig weil jedes Haus anders und ist der Platz und was muss man alles aufmachen was macht man damit alles kaputt,
Opel Corsa alles Zeit und Geld und Pipapo wer trägt diese Kosten ne das ist die Frage,
die Motivation das zu tun ist einfach zu gering und ich denke es wäre sinnvoll wenn man hier wirklich mal über Breitbandversorgung spricht und Glasfaser wirklich bis ins Heim dass man jemand wach Incentives liefert immer halt sogar,
zbfs besondere Idee über die Grundsteuer geht und sagt na ja wenn Glasfaser habt dann gibt's halt über die Grundsteuer Ermäßigung.
So oder für ab wenn dir das macht ab dann für ein paar Jahre oder so keine Ahnung ja auch wieder keiner Incentive.
Sparticket damit hast du halt das Geld Neuanschluss kostet aber Niederrhein steuersparer der Staat sozusagen.
Das hätten ja anscheinend auch nicht.
Nee weil wir ja nur bekloppte CSU Politiker haben die irgendwie von Tuten und Blasen keine Ahnung haben wollen uns was ich 15 in den Bussen WLAN einführen wollen das ist wichtig 15850.
80 50 50 50 50 50 so und überhaupt sonst ne.
Also ich brauche kein WLAN in Bussen und Zügen in 2000 nee wir brauchen einfach in der U-Bahn wäre es halt schon ganz geil weil das immer noch nur EDGE.
Ja dann x15 General und fertig Berlin überhaupt noch.
Was erlaube wahrscheinlich heute irgendwie ein 20 Jahres Vertrag damals abgeschlossen hat oder das ist der totale Holzweg man sollte das ist so als Patch.
Für den aktuellen Zustand,
teilweise okay und ich bin voll hinter solchen Initiativen wie Freifunk dieses Jahr eine ganze Menge Mühe geben auf der Basis was aufzubauen und hat die auch sinnvoll Touren zu haben die verseuchten Telekom Provider halt komplett.
Auch unabhängig funktionieren das ist alles super aber wenn man erstmal large-scale denkt und wohin ist halt hingehen sollte brauchen halt einfach liberalisierten,
die Ulli kumulierten Markt der,
freien Zugang zu den Basis Netzstrukturen zu den Glasfasern den large-scale Glasfasern bietet bis ins Heim hinein und,
der Staat muss dafür sorgen dass diese Glasfaser einfach nur universell verfügbare Anschlussfähigkeit wird.
Nicht nur interconnect auf Netzwerk Ebene sein eben möglich bis ins Heim mindestens bis ins Haus ja und du musst halt du musst halt Dienstleistung und Infrastruktur voneinander trennen genau.
Na sonst wird es nie was genau das ist ganz wichtig wären wir mit kompetenten Politikern.
Wahrscheinlich Costa Rica wann erhält man da schnelles Netz können von da Podcasten.
Mit einer kalten Kokosnuss das wär jetzt wirklich fein,
so war jetzt noch irgendwas durchkauen oder müssen wir mit mit mit über 4 Stunden schon bedient.
Ich bin ganz zufrieden werde jetzt bedient ne lucky ist bettreif ja alles andere verschieben wir müssen wir mal so zu Diskussionen und dann sehen wir weiter.
No todo ist es neue Kalender.
Gut Leute das war's Freakshow ich hoffe wir haben euch wieder einen angenehmen Tag bescheren können denn so ist es immer unser Ziel.
Wir bedanken uns fleißig für zur Arbeit über alles Gedanken und Unterstützung dir auf allen Wegen und Kanälen hier auflaufen lassen auch alles highly appreciated.
Und so weiter gib angenehme Nachtruhe.
Music.